ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYAN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON RIO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG AZUR FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
BLACKY LEE LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SUSHI
NAZARIAN QUINN O'DONNELL
ANDERSON PETRIE-NORRIS CORK
CORK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEEN
BROTHER THERE AS THE APPROVED
WHAT. HELLO WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SESSION THIS
MORNING. PLEASE COME TO THE
CHAMBER. KEEP US COMPANY.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE HAVE SET OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DACE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. LORD
SOMETIMES WE ARE BEWILDERED BY
WHAT OCCURS AROUND US. THE FEAR
OF PAIN REVEALS US AS HUMAN. WE
ARE VULNERABLE WHEN
ANTICIPATING TROUBLE SOMETIMES
FORGIVE US IF WE THINK OUR
DIFFICULTIES ARE SO
EXTRAORDINARY. ALLOW US TO
REMAIN POSITIVE AND TRULY
GRATEFUL TO YOU. GIVE US THE
STRENGTH TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS WE CAN MAKE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU REVEAL
YOURSELF AS THE GOD OF
COMPASSION YOU ARE CLOSE TO ALL.
WHO GO THROUGH DIFFICULTIES BE
THEIR STRENGTH IN YOUR NAME
THEY MAY PERSEVERE AND SEEKING
JUSTICE AND DOING WHAT IS RIGHT
I MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MEDINA. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
OUR NATION'S FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THERE'S
A- YES. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY SERVER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY BENNETT NINETY M. THE
AUDIBLE REBEKAH POWER KING IN A
SPECIFIC WRITTEN FOR THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
TO PROGRAM A DANCE RECORD DAVID
BOWMAN READING WILL CALL THE
ROLL WAS CALLED ONE CALL THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN MOVE A QUORUM CALL
THE ASSEMBLY MOTION CARRIED
TIME NINE AM ISRAEL'S MOVES AND
MISS. WALDRON SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE. WE
ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. AND
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE. ONE
FIVE TWO ALLOWS SIMPLY MEMBERS
O'DONNELL MAYES. PETRIE-NORRIS
CHOI AND JONES SAWYER TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB THREE
NINETY ONE VIA BOTH WANT TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. BEVERS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY ROLE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO. I AM REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM THIRTEEN. AB FOUR OH SEVEN
SALAS TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. I AM
THIRTY AB SEVENTY FOUR GONZALEZ
TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE. I'M
EIGHTY SEVEN A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY. ITEM EIGHTY TWO A. B.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN GRAYSON TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. ITEM
NINETY THREE AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
KALRA TO THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE. AND
FINALLY ADAM ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY FLORA TO THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH A NUMBER OF BUDGET ITEMS.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF BUDGET
ITEMS BEFORE THE HOUSE. WE ARE
GOING TO BEGAN. WITH FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FIVE. THIS IS SENATE
BILL. ONE SEVENTY. FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FIVE SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY AND THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACCOLADE TO
THE STATE BUDGET MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
MISTER TANK YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU BUT SPEAKER THIS IS S. B.
ONE SEVENTY ARE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AS WE REFLECT ON THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET I THINK ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. WE WENT INTO THIS YEAR
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT OUR
BUDGET PICTURE MAY LOOK LIKE WE
WERE STILL IN A WE'RE WE
CONTINUE TO BE A PANDEMIC. OUR
BUSINESSES WERE CLOSE WE WERE
STAYING AT HOME WE WERE WORRIED
VERY WORRIED ABOUT WHAT OUR
REVENUE OUTLOOK WOULD BE WE
PLAN FOR THE WORST AND WE GOT
ONE OF THE BEST BUDGETS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY ACTUALLY BE
LARGEST BUDGET IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. WE STARTED OFF THE
YEAR VERY FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT SCHOOLS WERE
INCENTIVIZED TO RE OPEN WE DID
AN EARLY WILDFIRE PACKAGE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT AHEAD OF
WILDFIRE SEASON WITH THAT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PACKAGE
TO. SEND SOME OF THE LARGEST
TAX BREAKS BACK TO INDIVIDUALS
WERE STRUGGLING BUSINESSES THAT
WERE HURTING FROM THE PANDEMIC
MAKING SURE THAT OUR ECONOMY TO
CONTINUE TO GROW AND TO
FUNCTION AND EXPAND EVEN AS WE
WERE CONTINUING TO GRAPPLE.
GRAPPLE WITH COVERT. IN JUNE
WEEK. THE BUT IS STATES.
HIGHEST INVESTMENT IN OUR QUEUE
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM HI THIS
POOR PEOPLE SPENDING IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. WE MOVE TOWARD
UNIVERSAL T. K. SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN CHILDCARE SO
PEOPLE COULD GET BACK TO WORK
WE EXPANDED OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SO WE COULD MOVE CLOSER
TO OUR GOAL OF UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIANS. IN OUR STATE THEN
WE PUT IN. THE FUNDING FOR
CLIMATE PACKAGE FOR OUR
WILDFIRE PACKAGE IN OUR WATER
PACKAGE WHICH WE'RE DEALING
WITH TODAY. IT OF COURSE LAST
BUT DEFINITELY OT LEAST. SEE
HUGE INVESTMENTS FOR HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS THE ISSUE THAT
REALLY- WE CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE
WITH AS WE TRY TO FIND A WAY.
TO HOUSE EVERY CALIFORNIAN WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO AS
CALIFORNIANS MOVE HERE AS
PEOPLE MOVE HERE TO CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE
COULD NOT ONLY GOOD A JOB. BUT
THAT THEY CAN FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE. SO TODAY IN OUR SB ONE
SEVENTY ARE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
OUR MAJOR ITEMS ARE WE HAVE
NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WILDFIRES.
THE SIGNIFICANT SPENDING FOR
FOREST HEALTH AND PREVENTION.
WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE MILLION FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY. OF LARGEST PART OF
THE GOING TO WORK
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM AS WELL AS-
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
URBAN GREENING IN. OUR VARIOUS
CONSERVANCIES. EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOR
DROUGHT RESILIENCY. WITH A
HUNDRED TWENTY FOR SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER. FOR THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT AS WELL AS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
WATER RECYCLING IN THIRTY
MILLION TO BEGIN OUR INVESTMENT
FOR P. FAST CLEAN UP WHICH HAS
BEEN. IN A FORTUNATE
CONTAMINANT OF OUR WATERS. OF
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION FOR
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE WITH
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN ABOUT
FOUR FARMERS TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM ENCOURAGE THEM TO REPLACE.
THEIR OLD DIESEL MOTORS AND-
MACHINES WITH NEWER MORE ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND LESS POLLUTING
MACHINES. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR OUR PARKS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
HOUSING WE'VE BEEN SO WORRIED
ABOUT. MAKING SURE. THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. YET WHILE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP OUR
FEES FLAT. THE COST OF LIVING
HAS GONE UP AND UP AND OFTEN
TIMES THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO GO
TO SCHOOL NOT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE FEES. BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE SO
IT'S TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UCCS YOU TO
INVEST IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR STUDENTS. SIX HUNDRED
MILLION FOR OUR COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE PROGRAM TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES HARDEST HIT. BY ARE
TRANSITIONING TO A CLEANER
GREENER ECONOMY ARE REALLY
GOING TO GET INVESTMENT TO HELP
THEM GET OUT OF OUR COVERT.
KOVITZ A HERE DRAW THE SECOND
ON. DOWNTURN IN AGAIN TWENTY
FIVE MILLION TO ELIMINATE
CRIMINAL FEES WHICH TO HELP.
REIMBURSE COUNTIES AS WE
ELIMINATE THESE FEES HELP
BACKFILL THE REVENUE THAT'S
BEING LOST. BY THE COUNTIES AND
THEN LASTLY- TWENTY SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO SUPPORT AFGHAN
REFUGEES WHO RECENTLY. LEFT
AFGHANISTAN AND HAVE COME HERE
TO. CALIFORNIA WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE FOR
SB ONE SEVENTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG MR FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I UNFORTUNATELY RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
FIRST LET ME SAY THAT I HAVE
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SHARE WHO I'VE WATCHED
NAVIGATE A BUDGET YEAR UNLIKE
ANY OTHER BUT MEMBERS OUR STATE
IS FACING TREMENDOUS CRISES ON
TOP OF THE PANDEMIC OUR STATE
IS FACING CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES WHICH THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS. BUT THE
ONE CRISIS I'M AFRAID WE ARE
NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESSING WITH
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS IS THE
DROUGHT THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
DURING ESPECIALLY FOR US IN THE
CENTER VALLEY CALIFORNIANS ARE
FACING THE MOST SEVERE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN HUMILITY'S A RUN
OUT OF WATER. FARMERS ARE
FORCED TO DESTROY CROPS THAT
PROVIDE NEEDED FOOD PRODUCTION
JOBS ARE BEING ELIMINATED IN
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE FACING
THE REALITY OF HIGHER FOOD
PRICES CALIFORNIA'S LAST
SIGNIFICANT WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT WITH
THE STATE WATER PROJECT WHICH
WAS BUILT OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO
WHEN THE STATE'S POPULATION WAS
A MERE SIXTEEN MILLION PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIA IS NOW HOME TO
NEARLY FORTY MILLION PEOPLE OUR
STATE NEEDS A RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLY IN THIS FUNDAMENTAL NEED
REQUIRES INCREASED WATER
STORAGE AFFECTED CONVEYANCE
FACILITIES THAT CAN MOVE WATER
ACROSS OUR STATE. THIS BUDGET.
PROVIDES NOT ONE ADDITIONAL
DOLLAR. FOR ADDITIONAL WATER
STORAGE PROJECTS. IT WAS
CONFIRMED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AT A BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING. CLAIMING THAT
APPARENTLY PROP ONE WAS
APPARENTLY ENOUGH. IT'S BEEN
SEVEN YEARS SINCE PROBLEM WAS
PASSED AND LESS THAN 7% OF THE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN SPENT. PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED ARE
STILL STE TRUCKSTOP IN A
REGULATORY VORTEX WITH
UNCERTAINTY FACING PENDING
PERMITS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW. BUT DOES THIS BUDGET
FASTRACK THESE PROJECTS TOWARD
COMPLETION. NOW DOES THIS
BUDGET PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO GET THESE PROJECTS
DONE FASTER OR EVEN BETTER GET
EVEN MORE WATER STORAGE
CAPACITY ONLINE. NO DOES THIS
BUDGET PROVIDE INVESTMENT TO
COMPLETE THE CONVEYANCE AND
SUBSIDENCE ISSUES HINDERING OUR
ABILITY TO MOVE WATER ACROSS
OUR STATE. NO ALL THE WHILE WE
KNOW WE WILL SEE AN INDOOR MORE
DROUGHTS IN THE FUTURE. THIS
BUDGET IS A MISSED OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES WE HAVE
THE PROJECTS BUT WE APPARENTLY
LACK THE POLITICAL WILL.
MEMBERS ALL OF US HAVE STATED
THAT PORTRAIT OF ABRAHAM
LINCOLN THAT HANGS ABOVE THIS
CHAMBER. HE SERVED AND LED IN A
TIME OF GREAT UNCERTAINTY. BUT
ALSO TOOK ACTION THAT PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE. WE ALSO SERVE IN A
TIME OF GREAT UNCERTAINTY AND
WE MUST MAKE DECISIONS THAT
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE I WOULD
MAKE IT THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
WATER AND WATER STORAGE THESE
ARE DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS. WE
TALK OF BEING BOLD WE TALK
ABOUT BEING AMBITIOUS WE TALK
ABOUT BEING FORWARD THINKING.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO INVESTING
A WATER STORAGE NOT JUST FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
ACTIONS TAKEN ARE NOT BOLD.
THEY'RE NOT AMBITIOUS AND
THEY'RE NOT FORWARD THINKING.
THIS IS OUR FIFTH THE BUDGET
BILL. WE HAVE INDEED. MADE IT'S
A ROCKY FIVE OF THE BUDGET
SEASON. AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS
IS NOT A SEQUEL I CAN RECOMMEND
I URGE IN ABOUT. MISS FRIEDMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE SEVENTY I
FIRST WANT TO COMMEND. OUR
BUDGET CHAIR AND ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ON THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
HISTORIC BILL I DO WANT TO JUST
MENTION ONE. POINT ONE ELEMENT
OF THIS BILL. AND HASN'T BEEN
MENTIONED YET AND THAT HAS TO
DO WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL. AS
MANY OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW WE
HAVE BEEN- IN ONGOING TALKS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY AND ARE SENATE
PARTNERS. ON THE BEST WAY TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
INCREDIBLY TRANSFORMATIVE AN
IMPORTANT PROJECT THE LARGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IN OUR
STATE- AS WE- ALLOCATE THE REST
OF THE BOND MONEY THAT IS OUR
ROLE ARE CORRECT ROLE AS-
OVERSIGHT- AGENTS FOR THIS
PROJECT. THE TALKS ARE
EXTREMELY PRODUCTIVE AND I'M
VERY CONFIDENT THAT BY JANUARY
WILL BE SEEING THE RESULTS OF
THAT AND ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD-
BUT I DID WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET
ALSO DOES CONTAIN BASELINE
FUNDING FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL.
GINGER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECT WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WHILE WE'RE HAVING OUR
TALKS TO THERE'S NO
INTERRUPTION OF THEIR WORK. I
JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT
UP FOR MEMBERS AND FOR THE
PUBLIC AND WITH THAT I RETURN I
BOTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN DR WHAT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE CHAIR
AND SPEAKER. INCLUDING IN THE
BUDGET FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A BRIDGE LOAN TO DISTRICT
HOSPITALS. MANY DISTRICT
HOSPITALS ARE SMALLER
FACILITIES LOCATED IN RURAL
AREAS. IN ADDITION TO BEING HIT
HARD BY THE PANDEMIC THEY HAVE
TRADITIONALLY STRUGGLED
STRUGGLED FINANCIALLY. EVEN
PRIOR TO THIS PANDEMIC. THIS
MONEY PROVIDES GAP FUNDING FOR
THE DISTRICT HOSPITALS AS A
TRANSITION TO A NEW
REIMBURSEMENT MODELS. WITHOUT
THIS ASSISTANCE MULTIPLE
CLOSURES WOULD HAVE COULD HAVE
OCCURRED. THIS FUNDING DIVERT
SECOND TASK IFFY. AND IT'S
GREATLY APPRECIATED BY THE
COMMUNITIES THAT RELY ON THESE
HOSPITALS. BUT ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS THANKS FOR THE HUNDRED
AND FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STATE PARKS. WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL RESOURCES TO ENSURE
THAT THESE JAMS CONTINUE TO BE
SAFE. AND AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THIS INCLUDES
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
INCREDIBLE REDWOOD RIDING
REDWOODS RISING PROJECT IN MY
DISTRICT. I HOPE YOU ALL GET A
CHANCE TO VISIT ENJOY THIS
INCREDIBLE WORK BEING DONE. TO
PRESERVE THESE ICONS OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WITH MR COOLEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I'M
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND AGAIN I THINK OUR
BUDGET YEAR OF ALL OF OUR
BUDGET TEAM FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK IN THESE. MANY BUDGET
BILLS. AND I WANT TO JUST
REMARK UPON ASPECT OF THIS ONE.
LAST WEEK I SHARED THE WHEN I
WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD. I ROUTE
WROTE A LETTER TO A KENNEDY
JOHN F. KENNEDY- MUCH MUCH
LATER EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO I
RECEIVED A LETTER FROM A
KENNEDY. THIS ONE BEING THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE ANTHONY KENNEDY WROTE
ME A LETTER RIGHT BEFORE WAS
SWORN IN AS A CITY
COUNCILMEMBER AND LITTLE RANCHO
CORDOVA. IN A BODY THAT LEVER
HE HE ACTUALLY SAID SO THAT I
THOUGHT I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN TO
HEART IS IMPORTANT FOR US ON
THIS FOR. SELF GOVERNMENT MUST
NOT BE AN ABSTRACT IDEAL. BUT
MUST BE A REALITY. AND WE MUST
BE IN C. SOONER EFFORTS TO MAKE
IT MORE EFFECTIVE. AND
RESPECTED BY OUR PEOPLE. I
OFFER THAT COMMENT TODAY
BECAUSE THIS BODY TODAY IS. IT
A HISTORIC POSITION. BECAUSE
THIS BILL CONTAINS A LTTLE BIT
OF FUNDING TO FURTHER THE
PLANNING OF A VISITOR CENTER.
FOR CALIFORNIANS COMMODORE
STATE CAPITAL- ELEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION IT'S A TRIFLE IN
THE TOTALITY OF OUR BUDGET. BUT
THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE WE AS A
BODY AS AN INSTITUTION.
AUTHORED BY A FORMER DRUG RULE
CHAIR I MUST NOTE THAT YOU
SKINNER. ARE PUTTING MONEY.
FORWARD TO ADVANCE THE PLANNING
SO THAT ALL OF THOSE FOURTH
GRADERS ALL THOSE OTHER
CALIFORNIA'S ALL THOSE OTHER
AMERICANS PEOPLE FROM AROUND
THE GLOBE. WHO COME HERE TO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT DEMOCRACY IS
ABOUT. WILL BE WELCOMED IN THE
BUILDING. AND THERE IS A LEGACY
OF EDUCATION CONCERNING THE
NATURE OF OUR DEMOCRACY OUR
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY ARE
DELIVER TORQUE DELIVERED OF
DEMOCRACY THE BIGGEST PERSON
HERE. AND THE FOR SO LONG.
ANYONE ENTERING THIS BUILDING
DID SO FROM THE WEST SIDE BUT
IS BEEN SHUT DOWN FOR A LONG
TIME. ONCE AGAIN WE RESTORE THE
PRIMACY OF THAT GREAT WESTPORT
ECHO AS THE PLACE THAT WE
WELCOME CALIFORNIANS AND OTHERS
INTO THIS. TEMPLE OF DEMOCRACY
AND SO I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT HAS
BROUGHT US TO THIS MOMENT. WHEN
WE ARE. IN A DRAMATIC WAY
WELCOME CALIFORNIANS AND OTHERS
INTO THIS PLACE. ADVANCE IN
THIS PHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MISTER CHANG
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE MEMBERS ALL THEIR
COMMENTSTHIS THIS PACKAGE
AGAIN HAS A HEAVY FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR WILDFIRES WHAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
CLIMB IT WE'RE DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR OUR DROUGHT
RESILIENCY. AGAIN IF WE DON'T
REVERSE THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WE DON'T SEE GREATER
SNOWFALL WE DON'T SEE GREATER
WATER COMING WE WILL SEE PRETTY
RAINFALL THE SECOND ANY WATER
TO STORE SO THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY REVERSING THE ACTUAL
IMPACTS ON OUR WATER SYSTEMS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WILL TRY
TO BE VERY PREVENTATIVE FROM TO
GO BACK AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
TACKLING THE OVERARCHING ISSUE
WHICH IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I BUILT ON SB ONE SEVENTY.
THANK IMAGE TAKEN WITHOUT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS. WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLARK WELL THIS AMERICAN
GRANT AGREEMENT WITH. BLACKWELL.
NOW CLOSER ROLE. HIGHS FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE. OPEN FILE ORDER TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN SP ONE
FIFTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY FIVE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW WHEN ACTING IN
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES A MAKING A
PROVISION OR FORTY
SIGNIFICANTLY RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED UP ON THE MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB ONE
FIFTY FIVE IS OUR RESOURCES ON
THE MYSTERY OF THE BILL. THE
BILL CONTAINS A NUMBER OF
STATUTORY CHANGES NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IT
ALSO ENSURES STABLE FUNDING FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. BY
SPENDING UP BY CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OF OUR CAPTURED
FUNDING INTEL. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY NINE REQUIRES
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ARE HOW
OUR WILDFIRE DOLLARS ARE SPENT.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES A
LIMITED AND TEMPORARY SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT RESTORATION PROJECTS
BUT THIS EXEMPTION WILL NOT BE
APPLYING TO THE DELTA TUNNELS.
LASTLY IT PROTECTS CALIFORNIA
BY HAVING THE RIVER FROM HAVING
THEIR WATER SHUT OFF BY
EXTENDING THE PROTECTIONS UNTIL
THE END OF THE YEAR WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON SB ONE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FONG YOUR
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. I
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER WITHIN
THIS BILL IS ONGOING FUNDING
FOR NEAR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
FUNDING. FUNDING THAT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH SIDES THE
I'LL FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR BUT
ESPECIALLY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE COMMITTEES THAT ARE
PERSEVERING THROUGH INTENSE AND
BRUTAL CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
THAT BROWN ON FEAR ANXIETY AND
DESTRUCTION. WE ALL WE ALL
AGREE THAT THIS INVESTMENT IS
NEEDED BUT WHAT IS STILL
LACKING OTHER CRITICAL
STREAMLINING OF REGULATIONS
THAT ALLOW FOR MORE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PROJECTS TO BE
STARTED. AND COMPLETED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. LAST WEEK
SEVERAL OF US HEARD FROM
HEALTHY FOR STEWARDS THAT
BURDENSOME RED TAPE OR A MAJOR
ROADBLOCK TO REMOVING OUR
FORESTS OF DEAD TREES AND
COMBUSTIBLE VEGETATION THAT ARE
FUELING THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES. THE IRONY IN THISBILL.
IS THAT WHILE FORESTERS AND
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EXPERTS ARE
CALLING FOR THE STREAMLINING OF
SEE WHAT. THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROVIDE THAT RELIEF BUT- IT
DOES STREAMLINED DIKWA FOR FISH
POPULATION HABITAT IN THE
REMOVAL OF DAMS. S. SOMEONE
AGAIN WHO IS PROUD TO CALL THE
CENTER VALLEY HOME DRIVING
EVERY WEEK UP THE FIVE NINETY
NINE AND TO SEE THE VISIBLE
IMPACTS OF THE EXTREME DROUGHT
WE ARE FACING AGAIN THIS BILL
IS A DISAPPOINTMENT. CROPS
DESTROYED BARREN FARMLAND
LIVELIHOODS IN JEOPARDY IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN NEED OF MORE
WATER SUPPLIES AND CONVEYANCE
MANY OF YOU DURING THE PANDEMIC
ACTUALLY DROVE. UP TO
SACRAMENTO AND IT'S ALL. THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. BUT WHAT YOU
SAW AT THAT TIME. AND WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING TODAY OUR NINE
DAY. GIVEN THE STATE'S THIRTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS WINDFALL
THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR NEEDED
WATER STORAGE AND IS
DISAPPOINTING THAT THIS
OPPORTUNITY AS PASSING THIS
LEGISLATURE BY. IT IS OFTEN
SAID THAT BUDGETS REFLECT OUR
PRIORITIES FOR US IN THE CENTER
VALLEY. WATER IS LIFE. WATER
STORAGE IS THE FOUNDATION. AND
THIS BILL IS SILENT I CANNOT
SUPPORT A BILL THAT FAILS TO
ACT ON THIS CRITICAL LONG TERM
NEED OF OUR STATE I REGRETTABLY
URGE ANOTHER. THANK YOU MR ON
MR MULLIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ONE YEAR AGO TO THE DAY. THE
SUN NEVER CAME UP IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA AS A NATIVE
IT WAS SIMPLY THE AREAS SEEN
I'VE EVER WITNESSED AT THE
SKIES REMAINED A FOREBODING
DARK ORANGE IN THE SUN REMAIN
HIDDEN BEHIND LAYERS OF SMOKE
FROM A HISTORIC WILDFIRE
SEASON. A STARK REMINDER OF THE
CLIMATE EMERGENCY SO IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE ARE TAKING
ACTION ON THIS ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY ON THIS THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE IMBEDDED IN
THE RESOURCES TRAILER BILL I AM
PROUD TO STAND IN SUPPORT. OF
THAT PACKAGE AT THE HEART OF
THIS BILL IS AN OUTGROWTH OF
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE BONTA MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE IMPERIAL
VALLEY MR GARCIA AND I HAVE
BEEN PUSHING FOR THREE YEARS
NOW. WE ARE THRILLED TO SEE
MANY OF THE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
BECOME A REALITY IN THIS BUDGET
IN PARTICULAR I PERSONALLY I'M
MOST EXCITED ABOUT THE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING AND PROJECT
ELEMENTS AS WELL AS COASTAL AND
BAY WETLANDS RESTORATION
ELEMENTS SO WE MAY PROPERLY
PREPARE FOR SEA LEVEL RISE JUST
ONE PART. OF THE CLIMATE
EMERGENCY MANY MANY THANKS TO
THE SPEAKER STAFF AND BUDGET
STAFF WHO HELPED CORRAL THE
SPRAWLING NEGOTIATION INTO A TO
HOUSE COMPROMISE PACKAGE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO FULL FRUITION
OVER THREE YEARS WILL REPRESENT
THE LARGEST STATE LEVEL
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE
RESILIENCE EVER. BUT MAKE NO
MISTAKE IT IS MERELY A DOWN
PAYMENT ON CLIMATE RESILIENCE
GIVEN THE ENORMITY OF WHAT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS REPRESENTS TO
OUR STATE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR TO DO THE
ASK AYE VOTE ON THIS TRAILER
BILL. THANK YOU MR MELINDA'S
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE. IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY FIVE THE PUBLIC RESOURCES
TRAILER BILL. AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR SPEAKER RENDON PRO TEM
ATKINS CHAIR TANK. ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR THE
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS WILDFIRES AND EXTREME
HEAT IMPACTS THIS YEAR
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE MORE
THAN. SEVEN THOUSAND FIRE
INCIDENTS SCORCHING MORE THAN.
A ONE POINT INE MILLION ACRES
ACROSS THE STATE. THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED THIS BILL HELPS
ENSURE THAT THE STATE CAN
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
MITIGATION. EFFORTS TO RESPOND
HE- IMPACTS OUR RESPECT US
PRIVATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MISS REAVIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ON SB ONE
FIFTY FIVE THE RESOURCES BILL.
AS CHAIR OF NATURAL RESOURCES I
WANT TO THANK- BUDGET CHAIR
PHIL TAKING. AND BUDGET SUB
THREE CHAIR RICHARD BLUM AND OF
COURSE ALL OF THE BUDGET STAFF
THAT WORKED SO HARD. TO PUT
TOGETHER THIS BILL- ALL THE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS BILL ARE
CRITICAL- TO CALIFORNIA.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THE APPROPRIATIONS THAT ARE IN
THIS BILL TO MITIGATE EXTREME
HEAT- SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH OTHERS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA TAKES THE
LEAD. ON THIS ISSUE BUT ALONG
WITH THAT OF COURSE SEA LEVEL
RISE. COASTAL PROTECTION AND
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. OF YOU TO
WHERE THE GLOBAL LEADER
CALIFORNIA IS THE GLOBAL LEADER
IN DEVELOPING CLIMATE POLICY
AND REDUCING OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT. ON AND I'M
COMMITTED. TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE REMAIN ON TOP. WITH THESE
PRIORITIES THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER SMITH
DAVIES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM.
SPEAKER A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU FOR THE
OBJECTION AS SOMEONE WHO'S NOT
IN THE BUT COMMITTEE COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THE RATIONALITY TO
INCLUDE PAY RAISES FOR THE CPUC
COMMISSIONERS. IN A BILL
DEALING WITH COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WELFARE PENSIONS
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
DIRECTED US IN OUR IN YOUR
CLOTHES. YOU ALSO BACK TO THE-
NUMBER ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE.
THANK YOU. MYSTERIES ARE YOU
CAN. CONCLUDED MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN
BY. SAYING THANK YOU FOR
GETTING THIS CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION- INTO THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF. THE SB NINE A
ONE DEAL THAT WAS REACHED A FEW
YEARS BACK AND GIVES ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS. OF CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION TO ORDER MILLION
DOLLARS OUT OF THE CAP AND
TRADE G. G. R. F. FUND. TO FUND
WILDFIRE PREVENTION PROJECTS. I
SAID AND BUDGET INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. I'M NOT SURE WHO TO
THANK FOR THAT. YOU KNOW I'M
NOT AND I GUESS THAT'S MAYBE
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS I MEAN. SO
MUCH OF THE STUFF WERE LEFT OUT
OF THESE DISCUSSIONS. WE TALK
ABOUT IT. WE BRING IT UP WE
WRITE LETTERS- YOU CERTAINLY
HEARD FOR ME A LOT ABOUT THIS
THIS YEAR I DON'T KNOW WHY IT
WAS SO HARD. TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
THAT'S ALWAYS SAID ALL YEAR
LONG. IN A DIFFERENT BUDGET
BILLS WE'D GET OKAY HERE'S A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IT
pACTUALLY A REDUCTION. IN
FUNDING. THAT'S A PROBLEM- BUT
I KNOW THAT OTHERS BEEN WORKING
ON THIS VERY HARD AND I'M
THANKFUL THAT THOSE VOICES ONE
OUT IN THESE NEGOTIATIONS AND
WE HAVE THAT CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION COMMITMENT. WHAT
WE ALSO NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THOUGH THAT THAT THAT'S REALLY
JUST A BASELINE. THAT'S A
BASELINE WE'VE HAD THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR AT LEAST
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. AND LAST
YEAR THAT MONEY WAS ACTUALLY
CUT BECAUSE THE CAP ND TRADE
FUND DIDN'T PRODUCE ENOUGH
REVENUE. AND THAT'S ANOTHER
PROBLEM. SO WE NEED TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT THIS MONEY IS GOING
TO GET SPENT AND GET DOWN TO
PROJECTS. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
EVEN WITH THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR. LAST YEAR WITH
THE THIRTY FIVE STREAMLINED
PROJECTS WE ONLY DID ELEVEN
THOUSAND ACRES THAT'S THE FACT.
WHEN WE NEED TO BE DOING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT THE EXPERTS SAY WE
NEED TO DO TO GET ON TOP OF
THIS ISSUE. AND WE NEED TO
TREAT THIS WITH THE URGENCY
THAT'S NECESSARY. SCIENTISTS
TELL US THE SCIENCE TELLS US
THAT EVEN WITH EVERYTHING WE'RE
DOING IT WOULD BE DECADES.
BEFORE YOU REVERTED THE CLIMATE
BACK. TO WHAT WE'RE USED TO. SO
ALL THE MORE REASON THAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING THINGS LIKE
THIS LIKE FUEL REDUCTION ARE
FOREST DOUBLING DOWN ON IT LIKE
HAVING EARLIER ACTION. AERIAL
FIRES SO THEY DON'T GET BIG
GETTING WHEN THEY'RE SMALL. I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO. THIS IS
ABOUT CLIMATE ADAPTATION THIS
IS A CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY JUST LIKE C. RISES
JUST LIKE INCREASING BEACHES
BEACH FRONT AND BRINGING AND
SAND. THIS IS CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND YOU NEED TO
TREAT IT WITH THE URGENCY
THAT'S NECESSARY. TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IS JUST A BASS LINE IF
WE THINK THAT THAT'S IT. AND WE
SAY HEY WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING
AND WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE NOW
WE'RE TRULY ON TOP OF THIS
ISSUE YOU'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION. WE ONLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND ACRES LAST YEAR. WITH
THIRTY FIVE STREAMLINED
PROJECTS EQUAL STREAMLINED
PROJECTS WE DON'T HAVE THAT IN
THIS BILL. WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
TO DO SEEK A STREAMLINING. IN
THIS BILL FOR NOT FOR WILDFIRE
REDUCTION. WE DO IT FOR NATIVE
FISH POPULATIONS WE KNOW THAT
WE CAN DO IT. BECAUSE WE'RE
DOING IT FOR NATIVE FISH.
RESTORATION PROJECTS SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FULL EXEMPTION. WE'RE
DOING IT TO TAKE DOWN THEIR
ARMS I MEAN THINK ABOUT THAT
FOR A SECOND. WE'RE IN A
DROUGHT. WE NEED MORE WATER
STORAGE AND WE'RE WE'RE
STREAMLINING THE SECRET PROCESS
TO TAKE DOWNS DOWN. IT A LITTLE
BIT MORE INFO ON THAT YOU KNOW
WHO OWNS THOSE DAMS. WARREN
BUFFETT. YOU KNOW WHO'S ON THE
HOOK FOR LIABILITY IF THERE'S
ISSUES WERE TAKEN DOWN THOSE
DAMS THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER. SO WE'RE
DOING A SEQUEL STREAMLINING
THIRTY SETTING DOWN DAMS FOR
WARREN BUFFETT. LET THAT SAID
INTERESTED SECOND. AND I GUESS
I'M JUST TIRED OF ALWAYS HAVING
THIS HOBSON'S CHOICE. ON OUR
SIDE ANYWAY WE DON'T GET
INCLUDED NOBODY TALKS TO US WE
GET A BILL AT THE END THERE'S
SOME STUFF WE LIKE AND THERE'S
A WHOLE LOT OF STUFF THAT WE
DON'T LIKE RAISES FOR PC
COMMISSIONERS. REALLY THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THEIR JOB OVERSEEING
PG&E. YOU WANT ME TO VOTE FOR
THAT. NO ME TO VOTE TO TAKE
DOWN THEIR ARMS. IN A DROUGHT
NO ME TO VOTE FOR SEQUEL
EXEMPTION TWENTY WON'T DO IT
FOR A WHILE FOR PREVENTION THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE IN THE
STATE'S GOING TO ADMINISTER
GALLAGHER. WE ALL RECOGNIZE IT
BUT WE SHOULD SHOW. MIRED IN A.
DR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR- ARE BUDGET CHAIRS
FROM BOTH HOUSES ARE LEADERSHIP.
YOU KNOW BUDGETS- THERE'S
ALWAYS THINGS IN BUDGETS THAT
THAT WE DON'T LIKE OR WE THINK
SHOULD BE BETTER. THERE SHOULD
BE MORE OF THIS AND LESS OF
THAT THAT IS THE CHOICE THAT WE
ALL HAVE. ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE ARE THERE THINGS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEEN IN THIS IN
SOME OF THESE BUDGET BILLS.
THAT THAT WOULD BENEFIT MY
COMMUNITIES MORE ABSOLUTELY I
GOT A COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW
COUPLE COMMUNITIES THEY'RE
HAVING TO HAVE WATER TRUCK TO
THEM IT'S A TWO HOUR DRIVE.
THIS IS DRINKING WATER THIS IS
FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY. BUT
THERE'S NO MONEY IN THE BUDGET
FOR THAT THEY'RE HAVING TO
APPLY FOR A GRANT. AND HOPE
THAT THEY'RE GONNA GET THAT
GRANT BUT IN THE MEANTIME IT'S
GOING TO BE A MILLION OR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO TRUCK WATER
FOR DRINKING WATER IN PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT WE DIDN'T GET THAT.
IN THE BUDGET. AND THAT'S AND
I'LL KEEP FIGHTING FOR MY
COMMUNITIES DESERVE THAT. THE
WILDFIRE ISSUE YOU KNOW- WE
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR THAT FOR
A LONG TIME. NOW SENATOR DOLLY
AND MYSELF IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE CALL THAT THE DOLLYWOOD PLAN
A BI PARTISAN EFFORT THEY GOT
AS ONE BILLION DOLLARS OVER
FIVE YEARS FROM GIGI R. F. AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF NAY SAYERS
ESSAY YOU'LL NEVER GET MONEY
FROM G. G. R. AFTER THAT. BUT I
WANT TO CREDIT GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN. FOR HIS FORESIGHT IN
UNDERSTANDING AND SEEING. THAT
THESE WILDFIRES EMIT HUGE
AMOUNTS OF CARBON INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE. THEREBY REDUCING
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS HE RECOGNIZE THAT. AND
WENT ALONG WITH THIS AND IT
GAVE ADDITIONAL MONEY- AFTER
AFTER CONVERSATION THAT'S A BIG
DEAL TO GET THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR THE AFTER
HAN FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS. IS
HUGE. THAT'S WHAT THE L. A. O.
RECOMMENDED INTEL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE DIDN'T GET IT.
BUT WE GOT IT NOW. AND YES IS
NOT ENOUGH I WOULD AGREE THE L.
A. O. SAID IT SHOULD BE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
BUT WHICH IS A LONG LONG LONG
WAY. DOWN THE ROAD IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION AND WE NEED
TO CELEBRATE THAT AND I HOPE
IT'S NOT MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE AISLE. CAN RECOGNIZE THAT.
MY COMMUNITY WAS RAVAGED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. FIFTY FOUR
HUNDRED HOMES GONE. I RECOGNIZE
THAT MIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
BUT WHEREVER THAT IN IN BUTTE
COUNTY. I'M SORRY INDICUS IN
EAST NICHOLAS I BELIEVE- MY
APOLOGIES. I RECOGNIZE THAT HIS
COMMUNITIES WERE RAVAGED I
RECOGNIZE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
FROM FROM BEAVERS COMMUNITIES
WERE RAVAGED AS WELL WE ALL
SUFFERED FROM NOW. THIS IS A
HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I HOPE THAT MAYBE YOU
DON'T LIKE EVERYTHING IN THE
BUDGET THAT MAY BE BECAUSE OF
THIS IT MIGHT BE ABLE TO PUSH
THE GREEN BUTTON. IT'S A BIG
DEAL IT'S A BIG BIG DEAL FOR
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT MONEY
THAT WAS BEING SPENT ISN'T JUST
ABOUT THOSE THIRTY FIVE PROJECT
THAT'S MONIES GOING OUT INTO
COMMUNITIES. TO THE PER
PROJECTS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
YOU'LL HEAR A BILL LATER THAT I
HOPE. WE'LL CREATE MORE OF AN
URGENCY AROUND THESE PROJECTS
TO HAVE YEAR ROUND FIRE FOR
FIRE PREVENTION REWS WORKING
THAT ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN AWAY
DURING FIRE SEASON. TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON A REGIONAL BASIS TO
MAKE SURE THE MONEY IS SPENT IN
THE MOST APPROPRIATE WAY. FOR
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WHERE
THESE PEOPLE LIVE. SO YEAH
BUDGETS ARE PERFECT. THERE'S
THINGS I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
SEEN IN THESE AND SOME IS
BUDGETS. I GOT CANNABIS GROWS
BETTER THAT EXPLODED IN MY
DISTRICT ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROWS
SINCE LEGALIZATION AND I WANTED
MONEY TO CLEAN UP SOME OF THOSE
AND I DIDN'T GET THAT. BUT I'M
GONNA KEEP FIGHTING FOR IT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO YOU
KEEP FIGHTING FOR THE THINGS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US. AND I HOPE
THAT- AT THE END OF THE DAY
SOME OF YOU CAN SOME OF YOU
ACROSS I'LL CONCEDE THE POINT.
MAYBE PUSH THE GREEN BUTTON
HELP US MOVE FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU DR WOOD MISTER CAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY FIVE
AND I THINK I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE. A FEW THINGS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAT ON THE
FLOOR TODAY ONE IS. THE VALUE
AND IMPORTANCE OF THE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION MONEY WE SEE HER
TODAY I REPRESENT THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE. AND WILDFIRES
ARE A KEEP ME UP AT NIGHT THE
RISKS THAT PROVIDE THAT IT.
TEACHER OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
LIFE. AND IN OUR HOMES AND IN
THE WAY WE LIVE THAT EVERY DAY
WE WAKE UP KNOWING IS THE WIND
GOING TO BE TOO MUCH TONIGHT IS
THIS THE DAY WHEN WE'RE REALLY.
GOING TO LOSE THE COMMUNITY AND
WE KNOW THAT SOME MEMBERS HAVE
ALREADY SEEN THAT LOSS IN
GREATER WAYS THAN ANY OF US
WOULD HAVE LIKED. AND CRIME IT.
THE CLIMATE CRISIS COULDN'T BE
MORE RAL TODAY BOTH FOR THE
WILD FIRES AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND
SO PUTTING OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS AND MAKING SURE WE'RE
SPENDING TO PREVENT AND
MITIGATE TO MOVE CLEAN ENERGY
FORWARD TO DO THE IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT THIS BUDGET BILL
WILL DO TODAY BUT I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T ECHO ONE OF
THE SENTIMENTS ON THE FLOOR
WHEN I SAW THIS BUDGET BILL AND
I SAW THE RAISES. FOR THE P.
YOU SEE THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
BILLS I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT THIS YEAR WE HAVE
HAD TO LEGISLATE INTEL THE P.
YOU SEE TO DO THEIR JOBS. THEY
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOBS. AND I
PERSONALLY CARRIED A BILL THAT
WAS TELLING THEM TO DO THEIR
JOB. WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO
THAT MEMBERS. THEY SHOULD BE
DOING THEIR JOB. I SHOULDN'T
WAKE UP MONTH AFTER MONTH
SEEING THE P. JEANNIE HASN'T
BECAUSE YET ANOTHER. FIRE THAT
IS DESTROYING OUR STATE. THAT
IS EXACERBATING CLIMATE CHANGE
AND YET HERE WE ARE GIVING
REYES TO THE VIEWS THE
COMMISSIONERS. THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND SO I JUST
NEEDED TO RAISE MY MIKE AND SAY
THAT IT IS OUR JOB TO CONTINUE
TO ENSURE THE P. YOU SEE IS
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES.
MOVING CLEAN ENERGY FORDING
GETTING OUR STATE TO WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE. AND I DON'T SEE
THAT AS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT WE HAVE MORE WORK
TO DO IN THAT REGARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BACK A HAND SAY NO
ADDITIONAL. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MISTER CHANG YOU MAY
CLOSE EGGMAN SPEAKERJUST WANT
TO GET BACK TO MY COLLEAGUE
REGARDING HER QUESTION FROM THE
GOOD. THE GOOD AND THE GAL. ON
THE- RESOURCES TRAILER BUILT
OFF OF THE ENERGY TRAILER BILL
SO ALL THE ENERGY RELATED ITEMS
WHICH- THE PC DOES COVER ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT- THE- REQUEST
FOR RAISES CAME THROUGH FROM
THE MINISTRATION. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
BE COMPETITIVE WITH SALARIES
AND SO. THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
WAS AGREED UPON. WITH THAT WHAT
I WOULD FOCUS ON IS AGAIN THE-
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
WILDFIRES TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT.
BEGAN ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NICHOLS ECHOED. BUT THIS IS
VERY MUCH BEEN A BI PARTISAN
EFFORT BECAUSE- SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY SUPPLEMENT THE
STATE'S NO LONGER. ANY ONE
COMMUNITY THAT'S IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRES IT IS EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY. UP AND DOWN THE
STATE WHETHER YOU'RE ALL THE
WAY. IN YOUR VEHICLE ALL THE
WAY TO SAN DIEGO. SO WE SEE
THIS IMPACT IS NO LONGER LOCAL
TO. A FEW COMMUNITIES A FEW
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE LARGEST
IMPACT. THIS NOW HAS IMPACTED
EVERY SINGLE. PART OF OUR STATE
AND I THINK IT'S INVESTMENT
HIGHLIGHTS. HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS. TO SAY THAT WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN IT THIS YEAR. AND
NEXT YEAR BUT GOING ALL THE WAY
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY AT TWENTY
TWENTY NINE. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE. VOTE
FOR SB ONE FIFTY FIVE. THANK
YOU CHANG AND WITHOUT CLLR WILL
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE KNOWS SEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM. ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
SENATE BILL. ONE SIXTY TWO.
CORRECT SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACCOLADE
TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE STICK
AFFECT ME DEEPLY PRIVILEGED TO
THE BUDGET MISTER KING YOU MAY
GET OPEN. THANK WITH SPEAKER S.
B. SB ONE SIXTY TWO IS OUR
LABOR TRAILER BILL THE PROPOSAL
PROVIDES GUIDELINES FOR THE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
PROGRAM WHICH WERE APPROVED
EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE UTILIZE
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT REALLY ENSURES THAT
WE ARE HELPING PEOPLE AS
THEY'VE GRAPPLED WITH- POST
CODE VISIT AS WELL AS- THE
EFFECTS OF OUR CLEAN AND GREEN
ECONOMY AS THOSE WE HELP
TRANSITION THEM. THE HIGH BEING
HIGH PAYING SUSTAINABLE JOBS-
THESE GUIDELINES WILL ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDS ARE GOING TO
TARGET THE REGIONS THAT HAVE
REALLY BEEN HIT THE HARDEST BY
THIS PANDEMIC WELL WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MONEYIS
GETTING TO THE COMMUNITIES OF
REALLY NEED TO THE MOST WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB ONE SIXTY TWO.
THANK TANG MISTER FONG YOUR- I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ONE SIXTY
TWO. AS A STATE IS STILL
EMERGING FROM THE PANDEMIC WE
NEED TO ENCOURAGE JOB GROWTH
AND ECONOMIC. RECOVERY NOT AN
EXPANSION OF GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS THAT FAILED IN
PROVIDING RESULTS. THE EDT AS
WE ALL KNOW HAS NOT SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS IT IS NOT
EQUIPPED. TO MANAGE A PROGRAM
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO LEAD OUR
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE WHEN THEY
CAN HARDLY MANAGE THEIR CURRENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SPENT TO REPAY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DEBT WE
OWE TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OR POSSIBLY REINSTATE THE TAX
CREDITS AND DEDUCTIONS. THAT
WERE TAKEN AWAY LAST YEAR TO
ENSURE THE VIAILITY OF OUR-
SMALL BUSINESSES AND BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT THEY CAN
STAY OPEN AND HIRE EMPLOYEES.
OR LOCAL BUSINESSES NEED THE
FREEDOM AND INCENTIVES TO
CONTINUE TO GROW FROM THE
GROUND UP BY MAXIMIZING
INNOVATION CREATIVITY AND YOU
AN INGENUITY. INSTEAD THIS BILL
CREATES ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM WITH QUESTIONABLE
CRITERIA AND METRICS I REGION
ABOUT. THANK OF US FALL SAY NO.
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS ITEM. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. ZERO
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I FIFTY NINE
THOSE THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE OUT OF ONE SIXTY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY FIVE.
COOKERY SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW WHEN ACTUALLY
INTO STATE EMPLOYMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER K. THANK
MISTER SPEAKER SB ONE SIXTY
FIVE IS ONE OF OUR M. O. U.
TRAILER BILLS BUT IF I THE MO
YOU AND ALL AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. IN
UNIT EIGHT CALIFORNIA
APPROPRIATE FUNDS NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THE FINALIZED SALARY
SURVEY FOR BARGAINING UNIFIED
WHICH IS C. H. P. IN THE JUDGES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
FOR. SB ONE SIXTY FIVE. AND MR
FONG. I THINK IT IS BIGGER- AS
WE NOW WAS WE ALL KNOW SPURRED
BY DANGEROUS DRY CONDITIONS
FOURTEEN ACTIVE WHILE BARS
OCCURRING THE RAGING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION ACRES
BURNED LAST YEAR AND THOUSANDS
OF FIRES OF FIRE FIGHTERS
BATTLED THE FOR THE FIRES WHILE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HELPED
EVACUATE RESIDENTS. THE VALUE
AT WORK THE OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OVER THE
PAST YEAR IS ACTUALLY DESERVING
OF THE GRIEVANCE IN THIS BILL
WE ARE ALL INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE DETERMINATION AND
SACRIFICES OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. I REGION ABOUT.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I REPRESENTED ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. THAT HAS. GIANT
SECTIONS THAT ARE COVERED BY
CAL FIRE FOR PROTECTION. AND NO
LOCAL AGENCY COVERING THOSE
SECTIONS. AND I'VE TALKED TO
THE CALIFORNIA. PERSONNEL TO DO
THOSE JOBS. AND THEY'RE HARD
JOBS AND WE ALL KNOW THAT AND
WHAT THEY TELL ME IS THEY HAVE
TROUBLE COMPETING WITH THE
LOCAL AGENCY SOME SOME OF THOSE
LOCAL AGENCIES. ARE PAYING
TWENTY OR 30% MORE. FOR A
COMPARABLE POSITION THE CALPERS
ABLE TO PAY. WE NEED TO CLOSE
THAT GAP. AND THIS IS A GOOD
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE DO THAT BECAUSE WE
ARE LOSING CAL FIRE PERSONNEL
TO THOSE LOCAL AGENCIES AND
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT JOBS TO.
DON'T GET ME WRONG IF YOUR
HOUSE ON FIRE YOU WANT TO HAVE
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL COME PUT
THAT FIRE OUT. AND SAVE YOUR
HOUSE. BUT WE ALSO NEED PEOPLE
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE GIANT.
BRUSH FIRES IN THESE GIANT
FOREST FIRES IN THE OTHER FIRES
THE CALIFORNIA IS FIGHTING ON
THE FRONT LINES. SO I WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER AN AYE VOTE ON THIS. I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP.
IN CLOSING THAT GAP IN MAKING
SURE. THAT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
HAVE THE FUNDS THEY NEED THANK
YOU. MR SAY ARE TELL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE. FROM THE
COAST- FOR SPEAKING OUT. I
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THIS IN
THE BUDGET THIS IS IMPORTANT-
THE FIREFIGHTERS FOR CALIFORNIA
SPECIALLY. HAVE BEEN UNDERPAID
FOR YEARS- DAY THEIR WORKING
CONDITIONS- THEY THEIR THEIR
SCHEDULE KEEP THEM AWAY FROM
THEIR FAMILIES FOR WEEKS AT A
TIME. AND IT'S YOU KNOW THIS
YEAR IS ESPECIALLY BAD. THEY'RE
UNDERMANNED THEY CAN'T COMPETE
AND THIS REALLY WILL YOU KNOW
THIS IS A STEP TOWARDS HELPING
THEM. BE MORE COMPETITIVE AND
FULFILL THE DREAMS OF ALL OF
THEM AND ALL OF US TO HAVE A
FIRES FORCE. THAT CAN COMPETE-
CAN- AT TO HELP MITIGATE THESE
DANGEROUS WILDFIRES SO AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING IN THE
BUDGET. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
THINK. THANK YOU MR SAY AIRTEL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THERE A
LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY SIX.
CALGARY SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AN APPLE INTO
CANNABIS MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED BUDGET
MISTER CHECK THANK YOU MEMBERS
SO WHEN. CALIFORNIANS PASSED
THE BALLOT MEASURE TO LEGALIZE
CANNABIS WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE BENEFITS THAT
THAT LEGALIZATION WOULD COME TO
EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY. SHE
THOSE COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN HIT
HARDEST BY THE WAR ON DRUGS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A STATE WIDE
DEFINITION FOR EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN GET ACCESS
TO FEE WAIVERS AND DEFERRALS.
IF WE DON'T PASS THIS BILL ONLY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE FEE WAIVERS OR
DEFERRALS FOR THESE PROPER
CONSENT LICENSEES WILL CONTAIN
THE BENEFIT. WITH THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
PART OF THE STATE ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN MOST HARMED
BY THE WAR ON DRUGS ACTUALLY
GETS SOME OF THIS MINISTER
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US FOR
ALL YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB ONE
SIXTY SIX. FENGXIANG MISTER
FONG ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE SIXTY SIX
WHICH ATTEMPTS TO ALLOW THE
CANNABIS MARKET TO MATURE AND
CONTINUE TO MODIFY SAY
REGULATIONS. THESE CHANGES
THESE CHANGES THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS ARE NEEDED I HEARD
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS FONG
SAYING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. RESERVE THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM. ONE SIXTY
THREE F. FIVE ONE SIXTY THREE
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
AND THE CORPORATION SENATE BILL
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE INTO
CHILDCARE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PAYER RELATE
TO THE BUDGET MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT ENSURE THAT ALL
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR BOTH THE PANDEMIC
RELIEF PACKAGE IN THE CHILD
CARE EXPANSION PACKAGE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
MR FONG BUT HE WAS A SPEAKER
FOSTER YOU FACE MANY CHALLENGES
LIKE NEGLECT AND INSTABILITY IS
ENCOURAGING TO SEE CONSISTENT
PROGRESS TOWARD SHIFTING CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
SERVICES THIS BILL GUARANTEES
TO FOSTER YOUTH WILL GO A LONG
WAY. I REGION ABOUT. THANK YOU
MR FONG SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB
RURAL. DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT I SEVENTY
FIVE DOWN ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY FOUR. SB ONE SIXTY NINE
COOKERY SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AN APPLE IN A
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION AFFORDS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PRIVILEGE OF
THE BUDGET MISTER TECH THANK
RICHEST PROGRESS BE ONE SIXTY
NINE AS A HEADER EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL EITHER TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN MAKING SURE THAT
OUR FEES HAVE NOT BEEN GOING OR
RISING AT AN EXORBITANT RATE AS
HAS HAPPENED IN YEARS PAST.
HOWEVER WHAT HAS BEEN RISING IS
ARE SKYROCKETING COST OF LIVING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA PROBABLY THE
HIGHEST COST TO ANY STUDENT
APPLYING TO COLLEGE TODAY IS
THE COST OF HOUSING THIS IS A
TWO BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
OVER THREE YEARS FOR AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING AS WELL AS
CAMPUS EXPANSION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S GREATER ACCESS FOR
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIANS TO GO
TO UC'S CSU AND- TORE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE THAT THE COMMUTER
COLLEGES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES REMAIN VERY.
AFFORDABLE IF YOU WANT TO
ACTUALLY GO TO A CERTAIN
COMMUNICABLE IT'S THAT'S NOT
NEXT TO YOUR HOME YOU WANT TO
LIVE THERE THEY'RE VERY VERY
FEW HOUSING OPTIONS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALSO CAN PARTICIPATE IN HAVING
GREATER ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WHO
DON'T LIVE NEAR THAT.
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
THIS BILL ALSO MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO OUR MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AND CAL GRANT
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB ONE SIXTY NINE.
MR FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER CALLER SAVINGS ACCOUNT
ARE A KEDAI EDUCATION OPENING
COUNTLESS DORSET SUCCESSFUL
FUTURE AND OUR STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOL STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME ACCESS TO THIS ASSISTANCE
AMONG THE TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO
CONSUMING TO APPROVE THE
STATE'S HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
THE KIDS SAVINGS PROGRAM
EXTENSION TO STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS IS A NEEDED CHANGE
HOWEVER I WOULD ONLY LAND A
WORD OF CAUTION AGAINST IS
BILL'S PROHIBITION ON PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS TO BUILD
STUDENT HOUSING THE PRIVATE
SECTOR HAS THE FLEXIBILITY AND
INNOVATION TO OFFER COST
SAVINGS AND QUICK DELIVERY ON
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. AND
SHOULD BE LEVERAGED TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD HOUSING FOR STUDENTS.
THE IRISH ABOUT. MISS CLARK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE SIXTY NINE BE. N. F. ED ARE
UP I AM REALLY EXCITED TO
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENTS AND NOT ONLY
HOUSING BUT PARTICULARLY FOR
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
MY DISTRICT HOSTS THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE STATE
FULLER TEN AND CYPRESS AND
RIGHT NOW CYPRESS COLLEGE IS
WORKING ON A COMMUNITY STUDENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HOUSING. THIS
TYPE OF FUNDING WILL NOT ONLY
SPEED UP THIS EFFORT BUT IF
APPROVED AND IF THESE FUNDS ARE
ACCESSED IT WOULD ALLOW THREE
HUNDRED UNITS OF STUDENT
HOUSING RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
WITH AS WAS NOTED WITH
PARTNERSHIPS FROM PUBLIC
PRIVATE. AND COUNTY LAND VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOT ONLY OUR
STUDENTS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE SAW ON THE PANDEMIC IS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
REALLY SUFFERED THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC IN OUR ROOM ENROLLMENT
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WAS
REDUCE WE WANT TO SEE THE
STUDENTS NOT ONLY ATTAIN
COLLEGE BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE OFFERING PLACES FOR THEM
TO LIVE. AS YOU KNOW ORANGE
COUNTY IS EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
TO LIVE IN SECONDLY THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP I'VE BEEN
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS IN THE
PAST AND I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT
IT AGAIN THIS MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP SHOWS AND SAYS TO
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
EVERYBODY'S PART OF OUR BUDGET
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING FOR ALL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB ONE SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA.
SAYING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. OUR CLUB THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRABLE. WELL CLOTHES ARE
ALL TIED AT I. SEVENTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. AND
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
SIXTY SIX. SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY ONE. CORPORATE SENATE
BILL ONE SEVENTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN APPLICANT TO HEALTH
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TO
RELATE TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
TECH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB ONE SEVENTY ONE IS OUR
HEALTH THE TRAILER BILL. THIS
BILL HELPS THE STATE
IMPLEMENTED HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES SPENDING PLAN.
FOR WHICH THE STATE IS
RECEIVING THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN FEDERAL FUNDING.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES DH CS
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TO EVALUATE THE MEDICARE.
MANAGED CARE NETWORK WITH
ADEQUATELY PROVIDING HOUSING
SUPPORT SERVICES. FINALLY THE
BILL EXTENDS A SUNSET ON TIME
AND DISTANCE STANDARDS FOR
MEDICAL MANAGED CARE SERVICES.
THAT ARE ACROSS FROM AYE VOTE
ON SB ONE SEVENTY ONE. MR FONG.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES ARE
NEEDED AND I REGION ABOUT.
THANK THIS FALL SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF A ON
THE ITEM- CABALLERO. YOU
DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLE CHINA THAT I SEVENTY SIX
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMETAL. ON THOSE BUDGET
ITEMS TO THE SENATE. MICHELLE
THE MEDIA TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE. GRANTED. NOT SURE I
COULD DO THAT BUT GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE.
TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE. WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
A FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE.
THIS IS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE SENATE BILL. SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. AND A CORPORATE
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LEYVA AND ACCLIMATE
TO IMPLEMENT MS GONZALEZ THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN AIMS TO PREVENT
WAGE THEFT WITHIN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THE BILL REQUIRES
JOINT LIABILITY OF DIRECT AND
SUBCONTRACTORS FOR LOOK
PENALTIES AND LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES DUE TO WAGE THAT BY
SUBCONTRACTORS CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BILLS ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A KEY DRIVER
THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND HAS
PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF HOUSING UNITS ANNUALLY. THE
INDUSTRY HAS HISTORICALLY
PROVIDED A PATHWAY TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS WITH FAIR WAGES
AND BENEFITS BUT FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS THOSE STANDARDS
HAVE BEEN GRADUALLY WORN DOWN
TODAY OVER HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
FAMILIES ARE CURRENTLY LOW
INCOME IN OVER ONE THIRD OF ALL
THESE FAMILIES EARN LESS THAN
50% OF THE MEDIAN FAMILY
INCOME. CONSTRUCTION WAGES HAVE
GONE DOWN BUT WAIT STAFF AND
CASH PAYMENTS HAVE INCREASED
CALIFORNIA LOSES BETWEEN THREE
TO FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE PER YEAR DUE TO
UNREPORTED UNDERGROUND
CONSTRUCTION WAGES PROVIDING A
SUBSIDY TO THE CONTRACTORS WHO
STEAL FROM THESE WORKERS.
UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS HAVE
AN ILLEGAL AND UNFAIR ADVANTAGE
SINCE THE UNDERMINE WAGES AND
WORKING CONDITIONS THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY EVEN THOUGH
PASSED LEGISLATION IS MADE SOME
DIFFERENCES IT'S NOT DONE
ENOUGH SOME CONTRACTOR STILL
CONSIDER WAGE THEFT AND THE
EXPENSE OF PAYING FOR THEIR
SUBCONTRACTORS JUST PART OF
DOING BUSINESS SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY
CONTRACTOR DO ANYTHING THEY'RE
NOT ALREADY SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING A GENERAL CONTRACTOR
SIMPLY NEED TO REVIEW THE
RECORDS OF THEIR
SUBCONTRACTORS. LEGALLY
REQUIRED PAYROLL RECORDS IF
THEY DON'T GET THEM OR IF THEY
DON'T LOOK RIGHT THEY CAN STOP
PAYMENT TILL THINGS ARE FIXED
AND THEY WILL NOT BE LIABLE FOR
ANY PENALTIES. IF THEY DON'T
AND JUST LOOK THE OTHER WAY AS
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING FOR YEARS
THEN I'LL SHARE IN THE
LIABILITY FOR THOSE PENALTIES
MEMBER IT'S TIME WE TREAT WAGE
THEFT SERIOUSLY WE HAVE GOT TO
STOP THIS PRACTICE WE CAN'T
CONTINUE PLAY BLACK THEM ALL
FROM THE STATE. IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
CONTRACTORS SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ. MR SANTIAGO THANK
YOU- I RISE THAT IS SUPPORT THE
BILL AND ASK OUR COLLEAGUES TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF IT. MANY OF
YOU KNEW THAT I ONCE WORKED AT
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. AND
ONE OF THE JOBS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES I HAD WAS TO
RUN UNDERGROUND ECONOMY TASK
FORCE. AND WHAT WE FOUND OUT.
VERY QUICKLY AS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THIS DOES
A CAR. NOT MANY OF US CAN DRIVE
BY SITES AND- MAYBE NOT NOTICE
IT BUT OFTENTIMES YOU DO HAVE
BAD ACTORS I'M NOT GONNA SILVA
BACK IS A GOOD ACTORS TOO WE
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE THAT. THE BY
FAR WHICH THAT DOES OCCUR IN
THIS INDUSTRY. AT RATES THAT
ARE ALARMING. AND IT HAPPENS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS YOU SEE IT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHAT WE SEE IS
YOU YOU PICK UP PEOPLE ON THE
CORNER SOMETIMES FOLKS
UNDOCUMENTED. SOMETIMES FOLKS
DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO
WORK. AND THEY TAKE HIM TO WORK
AND YOU CAN SEE THIS IN THIS MY
JOB WAS TO GO OUT THERE AND
CRACK DOWN ON THIS STUFF. AND
WHAT WE OFTEN SAW AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS ONES
NOT THE NORMAL BUT MOST AGREE
JUST. WHERE YOU PICK UP YOUNG
MEN. AND IN SOME CASES
UNDOCUMENTED. THANK YOU IF YOU
SEE THOSE BIG TRASH TRUCKS WHAT
THEY WOULD DO WITH IT OPEN IN
IN THOSE TOUCH YOU WOULD PULL
OUT COURTS AND IN THESE CARDS
THERE WAS DIFFERENT SORTS OF
TOOL FOR DIFFERENT SORTS OF
WORK SO THEY WERE BEING
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AT ONE POINT
IN TIME. THEY WOULD BE PAINTERS
AND APPOINT TIME IN ANOTHER
TIME THAT WOULD PUT UP THEY
WOULD PUT UP THE WALLS AND IS
ANOTHER OR PLUMBERS. AND IT
OFTEN WORK TWELVE HOURS A DAY.
NOW WHEN WE WHEN WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THESE MULTI AGENCY TASK
FORCE SWEEPS. AND THEY WERE
DONE WITH CAL OSHA E. DE DIR
AND A NUMBER OF FTV BEALE WE A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES WHAT WE
WOULD FIND OUT IS THAT THE
BOOKS OFTENTIMES SHOWED. THE
PERSON FOR FORTY HOURS A WEEK.
THOSE ARE THE COOKBOOKS THE
ACTUAL DATA WHICH SHOW THAT
THEY WORK TWELVE HOUR TWELVE
HOURS A DAY AND THE ACTUAL
PAYMENT WILL SHOW FOR TWENTY
HOURS A DAY. SO THIS DOES OCCUR
EVEN IF A BOOK SHOW THAT TOOK.
WHAT WE ALSO FOUND OUT IS IF
THERE'S NO TEETH DOES NOT
LIABILITY THEY WILL COMPLY WITH
THE LAW NOW THOSE IN THE MOST
EGREGIOUS OF ACTS AND IT
HAPPENED EVERYWHERE. RIGHT
SMACK CENTER DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES I REPRESENT BUT ALSO ON
THE L. A. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD THAT I WORKED AT WHERE
THEY DID HAVE WITH THE DID HELP
RULES REGULATIONS FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
THIS HAPPENS AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE OR
LIABILITY. YOU CAN'T STOP IT.
AND I EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THAT
THIS WASN'T JUST A ONE TIME
THING. THIS HAPPENED OVER AND
OVER. SO THIS BILL IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T HOLD SOMEBODY
ACCOUNTABLE WON'T HAPPEN HELLO
BY AND FOR. BLAME FOR THE BEST
CASE SCENARIO THAT THIS BILL IS
NOT NEEDED BECAUSE FOLKS ARE
FOLLOWING WHAT THE LAW WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. SO IF
YOU'RE A GOOD CONTRACTOR YOU
HAVE NOTHING TO FIGHT ON THIS.
IF YOUR BED CONTRACTOR YEAH YOU
COULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE IT WILL HOLD YOU LIABLE
TO FOLLOW THE LAW WHICH IS
BASICALLY. WHICH BASICALLY SAYS
THAT YOU PAY SOMEBODY FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY DID. AND IF YOU
DON'T STEAL IT. AND WE ACTUALLY
SAW THIS WE WOULD SEE PEOPLE
WHO WOULD WORK. FOR TWO WEEKS
OR FOUR MONTHS WHATEVER THE
CONTRACT WAS. THEY GET PAID ON
A VERY SMALL PORTION OF THAT
WEIGHT. AND THEN THEY'D BE
FIRED IF THEY COMPLAINED. SO WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO GET THIS
DONE BECAUSE WAIT STAFF IS A
REAL ISSUE AND PEOPLE HAVE TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE THE ONLY
WAY TO PAY. IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THOSE IN THE CHAIN I
HELD LIABLE FOR THAT WAIT
STAFF. I CAN'T I CAN'T. SPEAK
ABOUT THIS OR NOT BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY DID THIS WORK FOR SOME
TIME. IT WE WOULD INTERVIEW
PEOPLE OVER AND OVER AND OVER.
WHO WOULD BE TERRIFIED TO LOSE
THEIR JOB WHETHER WORKING
TWELVE HOURS A DAY. THE BOOK
SHOW THAT THEY WERE PAID FOR
TWENTY TO FORTY HOURS THAT WEEK.
AND THE PAYMENT PLAN REALLY WAS
FOR TWENTY HOURS THAT WEEK.
THIS DOES OCCUR IT'S REAL AND
IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
BECAUSE WHAT'S AT STAKE IT'S
PEOPLE WORKING AND HAVING THE
WAGES STOLEN. I RESPECTFULLY
WOULD ASK FOR DIVERT. THANK YOU
MISS SANTIAGO MS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE. TO
URGE OUR MEMBERS TO VOTE I ON
THIS SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
ATTACHED THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. IVEL FOR PENALTIES OR
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES IF THE
SUBCONTRACTORS THEY HIRE FAIRLY
FAILED TO PAY THEIR WORKERS.
CENTRAL LABOR HAS ACCEPTED
CONTRACTOR AMENDMENTS THAT
RELIEVE THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR
IF AND ADDED LIVE OF ANY LYLE
ADDED LIABILITIES IF THEY TAKE
THE REQUIRED ACTIONS. THOSE
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE STANDARD
PROCEDURES IN THE FORMAL
CONSTRUCTION ECONOMY HAVE MOVED
ALMOST ALL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATIONS FROM OPPOSED TO
NEUTRAL. JOINT AND SEVERAL
LIABILITY DOES NOT LET THE
SUBCONTRACTORS OFF THE HOOK FOR
VIOLATIONS IT MAKES IT LESS
LIKELY THEY WILL VIOLATE THE
LAW IN THE FIRST PLACE. BECAUSE
THE GENERAL CONTRACTORS ARE
JOINTLY LIABLE THEY WILL PAY
MORE I PAY MORE ATTENTION TO
THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS BEHAVIOR
ON THE JOB. THAT WILL HELP
WORKERS IT WILL HELP HONEST
CONTRACTORS IT WILL HELP THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS REYES. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. MS GONZALEZ YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NAME AND-
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS. IT IS OUT OF THOSE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
CLARK
WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE. HIGHS FORTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND MS RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND IT JOINT TO RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET.
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
TO HEAR AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
KALRA. ON FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
TENTH. AT NINE THIRTY AM IN
ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB SEVENTY
FOUR GONZALEZ DURING THE LUNCH
BREAK TODAY IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION. I
REQUEST IS GRANTED. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO THE
TOP OF THE CONCURRENCE FILES.
WE ARE GOING TO CONCURRENCE
ITEMS AT THIS TIME. BEGINNING
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER. ONE WE
ARE THE CURRENT FILE MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FIVE
TWENTY THREE KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS ARIAN
AND ACT LEADING TO THE ELDERLY.
THE SERVICE AREA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. AB FIVE TWENTY
THREE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THIS MEASURE SIMPLY MAKES
PERMANENT THE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT HAVE ALLOWED FOR PEACE
ORGANIZATIONS TO RESPOND TO
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS AND AT
THE SAME TIME PROVIDE CARE TO
MORE PARTICIPANTS AND ALSO.
PROVIDE COST SAVINGS INTO THE
FUTURE OF THE PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR AZAR
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL THE- CLOSE ARE ALL
TIED UP HIGHS SEVENTY. NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN. THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN ELEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
ON INSURANCE AN ACCOLADE INTO
INSURANCE MR DALY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
MEASURE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THERE WERE SENATE AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE MINOR IN NATURE AND
WE'RE SPONSORED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DALY.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CARCLUB THE ROLE. IT IS OUT OF
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT
CLERK WILL. HIS CLOSER ROLE
TIED ABOUT I. SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS AB TWENTY SEVEN
CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS
RIVAS AND OTHERS MEDICALLY THE
HOMELESS CHILDREN USE ANA
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTHS IN THE
CAREERS OF THE OPTIC A
COMPLETELY. MYSTERY US. THANK
YOU MISTER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SEVEN CONNECTS HOMELESS
STUDENTS IS TO SERVICES- IT'S A
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY AND IT'S BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
REVERSING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. PRESENT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF IS AT
ABOUT. WELL CLOSER TIDE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS AB TWO
EIGHTEEN CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD AND OTHERS BACK WAITING TO
VITAL RECORDS MR WARD EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
EIGHTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCY MEMBERS TAKE IT IN
THE SENATE WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO PETITION FOR A
NAME OR GENDER CHANGE IN THE
JURISDICTION THEIR CERTIFICATE
WAS ISSUED. REGARDLESS OF THE
CURRENT RESIDENCE ADDRESS
CHATTERING OUT ISSUES AND I
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER WARD C.
NOTICED. OR DEBATE CLUB OF THE
ROLE. THAT OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRABLE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS
ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FIVE IS
AB THREE OH NINE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS BACK LETTING PEOPLE
HEALTH. MR GABRIEL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THREE OH NINE
IS A RARE GABRIEL O'DONNELL
BILL THAT RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE BACK ON
CONCURRENCE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL. SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLICK LIBERAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF HER DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT ICE SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIX AB THREE ONE THREE.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND ACTIVATED
TO STATE EMPLOYMENT MISS GARCIA.
THANK YOU THE AMENDMENTS TAKING
IN THE SENATE ARE A RESULT OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH CALLIE CHAR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS GARCIA SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONSIDERED IN.
MEMBERS AND
FOLLOWERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN. AB THREE FIFTEEN COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE ACCLIMATE
TO FISH AND WILDLIFE MR STONE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE. CLEAR UP SOME
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD I ASK FOR
YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SENTIMENT
AMENDMENT. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CALDERON. THIS ARTICLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOTHES ARE OUTSIDE
OF THAT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT. THIS IS. FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT MR MEDINA THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT A. B.
THREE TWENTY. YEAH HOUSE. WHICH
MANY WANNA PASS TEMPORARILY ON
THAT. THAT MAY BE MY ERROR OR
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
EIGHT. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB THREE TWENTY SIX
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS RIVAS AND ACCLIMATE TO
HEALTH CARE MYSTERY OF US THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
THREE TWENTY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RIVAS SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSER
ROLE TALLY THOUGH HIGHS FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WORKING CURTAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
THREE FIFTY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHEN AND
OTHERS BACK LETTING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. DOCTOR CHEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THREE FIVE
SIX IS BACK ON THE CURRENTS
WITH TACKLE MINUTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLARK LIBERAL. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS AT
ABOUT. WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED BUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN
COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAYES AND OTHER SNACK LEADING
TO UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. AND.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
THREE SIX SEVEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND OTHERS BACK LETTING
THE MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. MISTER
SEA. THANK YOU SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDICTS ARE FINALLY
SEPARATE DETAILS FOR
IMPLEMENTING A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TO. ENSURE
WE HAVE MORE ACCESS TO MR
PRODUCTS IN OUR EDUCATIONAL
SETTINGS. THANK YOU MISTER CSC
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE IS PART OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB THREE NINETY SEVEN. OPERATE
SYMBOL THREE NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND
OTHERS BACK LEADING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE MISTER
MASON MAILBOX. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB THREE NINETY SEVEN
BACK FROM THE SENATE
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE REFLECT INPUT FROM THE
MINISTRATION AND AGENCY
STAKEHOLDERS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK IMAGE MESS SAY
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. FOR
CLUB MORAL. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ROLL TIED UP I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT WE ARE JUMPING
TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN IS AB SIX ONE NINE I
MISS CALDERON KERKORIAN. THE
BILL SIX NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON AND OTHERS BACK
LATE IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB SIX ONE NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL. IS THAT OF A ALL MEMBERS
OF THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN THIS FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB SIX NINETY ONE
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHILD ACCORDING TO HEALING ARTS
DECLARE THE URGENCY THERE ARE
PARTICULAR COMMITTEE LEAD
MISTER CHAP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL AND
ADDRESS CHATTERING OUT ISSUES
WITHIN THE BILL I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLARK LIBERAL. IT IS OUT
OF A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN.
HIS FILE ITEM SIXTEEN. AB EIGHT
NINE OH ONE COOKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE OH ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON ACTUALLY
RELATED TO RENTAL PASSENGER
VEHICLE TRANSACTIONS THIS
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB NINE OH ONE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REESTABLISH A TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR PRICE CAP ON
OPTIONAL DAMAGE WAIVERS WITH
THE ABILITY TO INCREASE THE CAP
ANNUALLY. BY THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX IN ADDITION AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSED OPPOSITION CONCERNS
ABOUT ADDITIONAL DRIVER FEES
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
ALL OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLARK LIBERAL. THE SENATE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB NINE THIRTY NINE
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES AND OTHER FACULTY TO
EVIDENCE THE SERVER TEST THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
NINE THREE NINE FOR BILLS A
PROMISE OF DENIM DAY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR NEARBY
PROHIBITING THE SURVIVORS
MANNER DRIVES FROM SERVING AS
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT IN SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES. CENTER FOR
MEMONS ADD CO AUTHORS AND I
DOUBLE JOIN TEAM LANGUAGE TO
AVOID CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AS WELL AS A LEGISLATIVE
LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN MY JOINT
AUTHORS FROM ORINDA AND SAN
DIEGO FOR JOINING ME ON AB.
NINE THREE NINE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BONTA. CA NO DISCUSSION OF A-
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL. CULTURAL TIE THE I.
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
AND MS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. ITEM ONE ONE
FIVE SB THREE SIXTEEN EGGMAN
AND ITEM ONE SIXTEEN SB FOUR
TWENTY TWO PM. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. I REQUEST IS GRANTED
MISTER BLOOM SEEMS READY. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN AB ONE
THOUSAND NINE COOKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM ACTUALLY
TACKLE CULTURE MR BELOW THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER READY AS
ALWAYS AB TEN OH NINE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS RENAME THE PROGRAM
UPDATED NUMBER OF DEFINITIONS
UPDATE THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
STRUCTURE SIMPLIFY THE TO GRANT
PHASES IN THE BILL ALONG WITH
OTHER TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK RESPOND
SAYING NO DISCUSSION FOR DEBATE
ON THE OUTCOME OF THE ROLE.
ADEGOKE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT
A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
EYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TEN
THIRTY THREE SEPARATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
AND OTHER SNAPPED RIGHT INTO
EMPLOYMENT MISTER K. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I PRESENT
AB TEN THIRTY THREE AN
IMPORTANT PROTECTION FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND WORKERS
CONCURRENCE AND SEND AMENDMENTS
MAKE THE BILL BETTER AND
ADDRESSES CHAPTER ISSUES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK RESPECT THEY HAVE. SENIOR
RECESSION DEBATE CLUB CLUB THE
ROLE. SIDE OF IT ALL MEMBERS OF.
IT IS ACTIVE OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY. PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY TWO. AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO CORPORATE
SYMBOL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES MR GABRIEL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
WHICH ENSURES THAT OUR
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE HEROES
HAVE A VOICE IN THE PATIENT
SAFETY PROCESS. SENATE
AMENDMENTS I INCORPORATE
FEEDBACK FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND C. H. A. IS
NOW NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK REYES GABRIEL SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I FIFTY FOUR KNOWS TWELVE
SENTIMENTS ARE TO CURTAIN MR
GABRIEL YOU HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ITEM THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS BACK LEADING TO LEGAL
ASSISTANCE MYSTERY REAL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY AND STRENGTHEN
PROGRAMMING CALIFORNIA'S RURAL
COUNTIES RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK IMAGE
GABRIEL. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
FOR DEBATE ON THE ITEMS
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. WE DECIDED VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL- CLOSER ROLE IN
TELEVISED FIFTY THREE KNOWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN. PASS RETAIN OF
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR. SHE SAYS
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ILLEGAL FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BY THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AND ACCORDING TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. MISTER STARR THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MEMBERS
THIS IS THE ANNUAL CIVIL LAW
OMNIBUS BILL FULL OF LOTS OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE NON
CONTROVERSIAL. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING AND PROVIDE TAPPING
OUT AMENDMENTS I ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MICHELLE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. THAT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. RESERVE OUT. WELL
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARKIN CURTIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX AB THIRTY NINE
CORKERY. SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AN
APPLICANT TO CLIMATE CHANGE MR
SCHELL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB THIRTY NINE IS BACK
FULL CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS ELEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
SAYS FILE I'M TWENTY SEVEN MISS
FRIEDMAN A. FORTY THREE CORRECT.
SUMITRO FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS BACK
LETTING THE TRAFFIC SAFETY MISS
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FORTY THREE
HAS BEEN A BI PARTISAN LY
SUPPORTED BILL HAVING TO- HELP
GIVE OUR LOCALITIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THEY SET
SPEED LIMITS NOT MEMBERS MY-
TRANSAFRICA'S TOO MUCH TIME ON
THEIR HANDS AND THEY WROTE OF
TALKING POINTS FILLED WITH
PUNS. BUT I PUT A FULL STOP TO
THAT ARE NOT GOING TO YIELD TO
THEM BECAUSE I DON'T WANT ANY
SPEED BUMPS ALONG THE WAY- I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
FRIEDMAN. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEVERAL ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VERY DESIRABLE. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE KNOWS
FOR SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE BREAKING. FOR LUNCH.
REPUBLICANS WILL BE PICKING UP
THEIR LUNCHES IN THE WILLIE
BROWN ROOM DEMOCRATS WILL BE
PICKING UP THEIR LUNCHES IN THE
LOUNGE THE MEMBERS LOUNGE
MEMBERS THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE. WE
HEARING AB SEVENTY FOUR
GONZALEZ DURING THE LUNCH BREAK
IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN IF
YOU WERE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE. YOU ARE
MEETING. RIGHT NOW AND ROOM FOR
THIRTY SEVEN. J. HERE MS
CONSOLS MEASURE MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR PROMPTLY AT
ONE PM WE ARE RESUMING BUSINESS
PROMPTLY AT ONE PM. WE ARE IN
RECESS.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN
OF THE FLOOR WE ARE RESUMING
BUSINESS. PLEASE RETURN OF
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN OF
THE FLOOR. WE'LL BE TAKING UP
ITEMS MOMENTARILY.
MEMBERS
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR WE
ARE TAKING UP CONCURRENCE ITEMS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE. BOUNCING
AROUND A LITTLE BIT ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING UP. A
FEW CONCURRED CONCUR.
CONCURRENT SENTENCE. PEOPLE.
THESE ARE CAN KERN CAN KERR.
CAN CURRENT TIMES. THAT'S JUST
FINE TO SAY- THIS IS GONNA BE
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN. AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY. KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
BY SOME OF OUR HAIR NATURALLY
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THIS
PARA QUE HAN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND THOSE
OF YOU THAT ARE SO TIMELY TO BE
HERE I APPRECIATE IT I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
WHICH IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE I AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY REQUIRES CASH TRANSFER
SERVICES TO HAVE A CUSTOMER
HELP PHONE NUMBER THE LEAST YOU
CAN EXPECT FROM SOMEONE WHO
HOLDS YOUR MONEY AND
MAINTENANCE IN THE SENATE AT A
REQUIREMENT FOR THE LINE TO BE
LIVE STAFF FOR TEN HOURS AND
PROPERLY POSTED ON WEBSITES
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ALL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THAT. THANK YOU IS BETTER
CARE. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL. OUT OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
BOUNCING AROUND A LITTLE BIT IN
THE FILE WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
SOME CONCURRED CONCUR ITEMS WE
ARE LOOKING TO TAKE UP. FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE IS AB TWO SIXTY BY
MR STONE. AND THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
IMMACULATE IN THE GUARDIANSHIP
MISTER STARR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWO SIXTY IS
TO TRY TO PROVIDE SUPPORTS FOR
FAMILIES WHO GET KIND OF STUCK
BETWEEN THE PROBATE. AND THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEMS
UNFORTUNATELY SENATE AMENDMENTS
REMOVE THE CAN GAP PORTION
BECAUSE OF BUDGET REASONS THAT
IS SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WORK ON NEXT YEAR BUT I
ASKED FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR
STYLE. SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. THE
SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
FIVE AND THIRTY FOUR IS AB
THREE OH FOUR BY DR QUIRK AND
THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH FOUR BIASED MEMBER
KIRK AND OTHERS BACK LIVING IN
CONTAMINATED SITES. DR COURT
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SENATE AMENDMENTS DAY BE THREE
OH FOUR IN CORPORATE ID-
TECHNICAL FEEDBACK FOR STATE
WATER BOARD D. T. S. C. AND
MADE THE REQUIREMENTS EASIER
FOR LOCAL. HEALTH OFFICERS
SHOULD HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR WORK. SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE IDACORP LIBERAL.
THESE ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ADAM. CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ALL THE TIME BUT I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
WORKING CURTIN WE ARE TAKING UP
A FEW CAN KERR CAN KERR ITEMS
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT.
FILE IEM THIRTY EIGHT A. B.
EIGHT ELEVEN BY MS RIVAS AND
THE CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT ELEVEN BY SOME RELEASE
REVOLVES AND OTHER SNACK LEVINE
TRANSPORTATION MISERY OF THIS
APP THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB EIGHT ELEVEN. IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFY LA METRO'S AWARDING OF
CONTRACTS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EYEBALLS. THANK YOU MS REVERSI
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
FIRMS ARTICLE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUTI.
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
AND THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY ONE
AB NINE SEVEN SEVEN BY MR
GABRIEL AND THE CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS BACK LIVING HOMES MR
GABRIEL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER EIGHTY NINE SEVEN SEVEN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCORPORATE FEEDBACK
FROM THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
FINANCING COUNCIL AND OTHER
STATE AGENCIES RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THINGS GET
REAL MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND AS MANY
OF US ARE AWARE. RECENT AUDIT
REPORT FOUND THAT OUR STATE
DOES NOT TRACK THE FUNDING IT
PROVIDES TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS
WHICH IS OF COURSE INCORRECT
INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC. AND
THIS BILL INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY WITH DATA DRIVEN
FAX BY TRACKING THE FUNDING TO
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS AND I WANT
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
ENCINO FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
WORK ON THIS ISSUE THANK. THANK
YOU AS WELL- SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WHICH GAVE
EARLY YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. YEAH I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAN I JUST WANT TO THANK OUR
CALLING FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO BRING
MORE TRANSPARENCY TO THE WAY
THAT THE STATE SPENDS MONEY ON
HOMELESSNESS FOR SOME TIME NOW.
THIS WAS A AN EFFORT THAT WAS
STARTED LAST YEAR WE FINALLY
REACHED A GOOD PLACE. I THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT AS WE ARE
PUSHING MONEY TO ADDRESS OUR
STATE'S HOMELESS CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE VERY VERY CLEAR TRIP.
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW THAT
MONEY IS BEING SPENT THAT WE
HAVE DATA THAT WE CAN USE TO
INFORM OUR POLICY MAKING IT SO
WE CAN MAKE. THE BEST DECISIONS
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AND ALSO
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE USING
TAXPAYER MONEY IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER
WITHOUT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK MISS
GABRIEL. WITH THAT CLERK LOCAL
THE ROLE. IS THAT OF- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS SHOULD DECIDE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLE TITLE BUT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS WORKING CURTAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK.
WHERE WE WERE BEFORE LUNCH ON
THE CONCURRENT FILE. AND WE
LEFT OFF AT FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE. I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON MISERY THIS
MEASURE WE WILL GO TO MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY IS MEASURE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY EIGHT.
FIVE AND TWENTY EIGHT MEMBERS
AB FORTY FIVE. AND THE
CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE FORTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS
MCALEESE WINDOWS WERE HELPING
TO CLEAR THE AGENCY DROPPED THE
COMMUNITY IS THERE A CURRENT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FORTY FIVE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. DESPITE PERSONAL
ATTACKS IN MIS
CHARACTERIZATIONS FROM SOME OF
THE OPPONENTS THE MADE PROGRESS
DIFFICULT I WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM AND THE HEALTH
COMMITTEES FROM EACH HOUSE FOR
HELPING TO CREATE A ROBUST
REGULATORY STRUCTURE THE
LEGALIZATION OF NON INTOXICANT
HEMP CBD PRODUCTS WILL HELP
PROTECT CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
FROM THE ILLEGAL PRODUCTS BEING
SOLD TODAY. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
THE SENATE CLARIFY THE
DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF THC SO
THAT NO KIND OF AVOID THAT CDP
CDP H. DETERMINES CAN CAUSE
INTOXICATION CAN BE SOLD. STATE%
THAT THIS STATE THAT CAN HELP
AVAILABLE PRODUCTS MAY BE
MANUFACTURED FOR SALE IN OTHER
STATES BUT TO PROHIBIT SALES IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT FURTHER
LEGISLATION BY THE LEGISLATURE.
HANDILY PROVISIONS CREATING A
HAMPERED RESEARCH PROGRAM I
ASKED HER AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL THE
CLOSER ROLE IN TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY SIX KNOWS THREE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
AB FORTY SIX. ACCORDING
ASSEMBLY GO FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US AND
OTHERS BACK WAITING TO USE.
MYSTERY OF US THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FORTY
SIX IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
COMMISSIONERS FROM TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTEEN. AND HAVE
COMMISSIONERS UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN BE ACCOMPANIED BY A
PARENT OR GUARDIAN WHILE ON
OFFICIAL BUSINESS OF THE
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK REYES
RIVAS SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AND VOTE. ALL MEMBERS LETTERS
OUT OF A. WELL. CLOSER ALL THE
TIME BUT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS WORKING
CURTAIN. THIS IS MR HOLDEN FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE. AB ONE OH FIVE
CLERK WILL READ A SIMPLE ONE OH
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
AND OTHERS DIRECTLY TO HUMAN
RESOURCES MR HOLDEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ONE
OH FIVE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS CALL FOR
STATE AGENCIES TO COLLECT AND
REPORT DEMOGRAPHIC DATA USING
MORE NUANCED CATEGORIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS OF AFRICAN
DESCENT. SIMILAR TO THE DATA
COLLECTED FOR CALIFORNIANS OF
ASIAN DESCENT. THIS DATA IS
CRITICAL TO ACCURATELY
REPORTING WHO AMONG
CALIFORNIANS OF AFRICAN DESCENT
IS EXPERIENCING BARRIERS TO
UPWARD MOBILITY. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL NOW GIVES THE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE MORE
ACCURATE DATA TO UTILIZE IN ITS
DELIBERATIONS AND FINALLY THE
AMENDMENTS AT A SEVERABILITY
CLAUSE TO THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
HOLDEN SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESERVE THAT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ADEBAYO. WELL. CLOSE ROLLTIDE
EYES FORTY EIGHT MINUTES TEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AB. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FOUR
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY
THREE BY A MINERAL THE RENDON
SALAS AND OTHERS BACK LIVING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR. MISS GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU- MA'AM IT'S TAKEN AND
THE SENATE WOULD PHASE IN.
IMPLEMENTATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BIPARTISAN MEASURE
WITH A CO AUTHOR WHO LOOKS LIKE
HE'S GOING TO SPEAK. FAGUNDEZ
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'LL BE I'LL BE
QUICK BUT WHEN THE MOST
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS WE CAN
MAKE IS IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
CHILDREN AND UNDER THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA FOR THE FIRST TIME
WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER NEW
PARENTS THREE MONTHS OF PAID
LEAVE WHEN THEY HAVE A NEWBORN
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN ACROSS THE
WORLD. IN EUROPE IN OTHER
STATES THAT THE FIRST THREE
MONTHS IS CRITICAL FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CHILD. AND
ALSO CRITICAL TO REDUCE RATES
OF POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION. THIS
IS A GREAT BILL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT. IN OUR
NEWBORNS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK MISS CUNNINGHAM SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE. CORPORAL. DESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
WHAT I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEMS THIRTY THREE AND THIRTY
FOUR THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE. AB FOUR NINETY BY MR
GIVES INCORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AND OTHERS
TACKLING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY POLICIES. MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY IS BACK ON-CONCURRENT THE SENATE A MEMBERS
ARE TECHNICAL. AND WERE TAKEN
TO SUBJECT OUR SINCE THE
GESTEDE BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
STRENGTHEN AND TO. DEFINE THE
POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA TO REDUCE
POTENTIAL BECAUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE ON
AB FOR NINETY. THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CARCLUB RURAL. ESERVER
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADEBAYO.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIE THAT ICE
FIFTY KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS WORKING CURTAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX SB
SIX THIRTY FOUR CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FOUR
BY SOME MIRACLE RIO AN ACCIDENT
HOUSING MYSTERY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AB SIX
THREE FOUR IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENT TO DRESS CODE
CONFLICTS TO AVOID ANY CHAP
DURING ISSUES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WE
DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CORRECT. WELL
CLOSER ROLE AND TALENT THAT ICE
FORTY NINE KNOWS EIGHTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR
CORKERY. ASSEMBLE SEVEN NINETY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
AND OTHER RESPECTFULLY TO AIR
POLLUTION. MYSTERY ARE YOU MAY
GET OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS EIGHTY SEVEN I'M
FORCED BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ADDRESS ISSUES
OF STREAMLINING AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROLE. THAT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED AS FIFTY
WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE AB EIGHT TO NINE
FIVE MR LEVINE FOR CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY TWENTY NINE BY SOME
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
AND OTHERS BACK ON THE FOSTER
CHILDREN. MICHELLE THE- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE WILL SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE BY
ENSURING THEY RECEIVE THE
IMMIGRATION RELIEF AND
REPRESENTATION THAT THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO UNDER LAW BEFORE
EXITING CARE THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THINKVISION
LEVINE SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE-
CORPORAL. SENATE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF. WELL
CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS.
HARKET CURTAIN. SAYS FILE ITEM
FORTY AB EIGHT NINETY SIX
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLY REPEATED
AND OTHERS NATURALLY THE OIL
AND GAS WELLS MISTER BENNETT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB EIGHT NINETY SIX IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM THE
SENATE THE BILL ADDRESSES
OVERSIGHT OF VITAL WELLS THE
BILL WAS AMENDED US IN THE
SENATE TO EXPAND LEAN AUTHORITY
OF CAL JAM'S INSTEAD OF
CREATING A NEW LEAN AUTHORITY
AND ADDRESS CHAPTER RING ISSUES
WITH SB EIGHT. EIGHTY FOR THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
PASSED THE HOUSE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK IS BETTER SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE BURKE WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. HELLO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT IS FIFTY EIGHT NO SIX
SENATE AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED
IN WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE THIS IS MISTER
FLORA FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB
TEN TWENTY THREE COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN TWENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY ROOM FLOOR AND ACT
WITHIN THE CONTRACT WHICH MR
FLOOR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB TEN TWENTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE OF SENATE MEMBERS
OF THE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
SIERRA STATURE TODAY CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE IS THAT A VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS WORKING CURTAINS
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM FORTY THREE. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BROUGHT
LEVIN EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS TACKLING
TO MEDICAL INFORMATION. MISTER
CHILL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR DRESSES PATIENT PRIVACY-
THE SENTIMENTS AND A CO AUTHOR
AND ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS
RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS IN WITH
THAT RESPECT THE ASPIRIN I VOTE.
THANK YOU ISSUE C. NOTICE
KASHER DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE- WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS FOURTEEN.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN HIS FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
TWELVE TWENTY ONE FOR FREE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE TWENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY WERE FLOOR AND
ACTED IN THE CONSUMER
WARRANTIES. MISTER FLORES. THE
US FIGURE AB TWELVE TWENTY ONE
IS BACK INCIDENT. OCCURRENCES
IN THE WOMEN'S RESPECT LESS
RIVAL. THANKS FOR SENIOR
DISCUSSION. ON THE ADAM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE SENATE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. ON THE RESERVES ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
THE TIME BUT I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX AB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT. DOCKERY SYMBOL TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
REVERTING AND OTHERS TACKLING
TO PEDESTRIANS MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MAYBE TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT LEGALIZES SAFE STREET
CROSSING IS BACK ON CURRENTS
SENATE AMENDS GREATER SEVEN
YOUR SUNSET AND ADDED A
REPORTING PROVISIONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FEDERAL. THEY
WERE STAYING SAY NO DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM CORPORAL.
WHAT IS THERE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF A-
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALTERNATIVE
AS FIFTY THREE NO SIXTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WE'RE GOING TO. ASCERTAIN A
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX CORPORATE SYMBOL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY SOME
MIRACLE RIO AND OTHERS
BACKLINKS SOLID WASTE. THIS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE IS A
SUPER AWESOME BILL THAT STOPS
OUR USE OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC
WHERE THAT POLLUTES OUR OCEAN
AND- OF REALLY ENSURES THE
FUTURE OF OUR PLANET THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE CLARIFYING AND
DRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNS WHO
ARE NON NEUTRAL AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO.
C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE. OUR
CLUB NARAL. SEVEN ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CAR WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY THREE KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY NINE AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY A SIMILAR BILLION
ACKLINS RESTORATION. THIS
RELEASE THANK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AT IN
DISTRICT TRANSIT IN MY DISTRICT
RESPECT LAST ARRIVE A- I. THINK
INITIALLY SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CORPORAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX BY A SUMMER BERMAN AND
OTHERS BACK WAY TO AIR
POLLUTION MR BERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL BACK
ON CONCURRENCE SENTIMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THEY WHISPER MISTER MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. THIS BILL THEY RUBBER
STAMP FOR CARP TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH REGULATIONS THAT WILL HAVE
SEVERE CONSEQUENCES. FOR THE
BUSINESSES THAT USE THIS
EQUIPMENT WITHOUT PROVIDING
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT REBATE
PROGRAMS NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THIS TRANSITION. MANY OF THESE
BUSINESSES ARE SMALL AND
MINORITY OWNED AND ARE
PROMINENT PROFESSIONS FOR
LATINO COMMUNITIES INVOLVING
LANDSCAPE TREE CARE AND
CONSTRUCTION ACCORDING TO CARVE
THEMSELVES. THERE'S NEARLY
THIRTEEN MILLION PIECES. OF S.
O. R. E. EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
LAWN MOWERS TRIMMERS GENERATORS
CHAINSAWS AND MORE THAT WILL
NEED TO BE REPLACED. THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL HAVE
INJURED STAKEHOLDERS. THAT A
ROBUST REBATE PROGRAM IN
FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
EASE THIS TRANSITION. HOWEVER
MEMBERS TO DATE. ONLY THIRTY
MILLION HAS BEEN APPROPRIATED
THAT WOULD EQUAL APPROXIMATELY
A TWO DOLLAR REBATE. PER PIECE
OF EQUIPMENT. THAT HARDLY
ADEQUATE IT'S THE WHAT ELECTRIC
RIDER MOWER. COST AROUND.
TWENTY THOUSAND. THE REALITY IS
THAT THIS PROGRAM NEEDS A
REBATE PROGRAM WITH HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IT IS JUST
SIMPLY NOT THERE. WE CANNOT
PUSH AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
WITHOUT AN ADEQUATE FUNDING OR
AT LEAST EXPLORE FURTHER IDEAS
THAT I'M IN THIS LEGISLATION TO
EASE THIS BURDEN. ON OUR SMALL
MINORITY OWNED COMPANIES. FOR
THESE REASONS MEMBERS I MUST
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
AND I URGE ALL OF YOU TO DO THE
SAME UNTIL WE CAN COME BACK AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDE CARE IT. TO
HELP INCENTIVIZE. THESE
IMMIGRANT. COMPANY OWNERS TO
MOVE THIS DIRECTION INSTEAD OF
GIVING THEM A CHEAP TWO DOLLAR
REBATE THANK YOU. ST NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MR BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE
MEASURE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. WHAT IS THERE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY FIVE KNOWS
TWENTY SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE AB FORTINO THREE
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO THREE BY ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE ACTUALLY
TO EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
CLARITY OF CEDAR OF SECULAR
COMMITTEE LEE NATIONAL RATE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FORTINO THREE
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR TO
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DUE TO A DE ENERGIZE ATION OF
AND- BY INCLUDING THESE EVENTS
WITHIN THE DEFINITION OF
CONDITIONS THAT WEREN'T A STATE
OF EMERGENCY DECLARATION.
ADDING THE INTERNALIZATION AND
PS PS EVENTS TO THE DEFINITION
OF CONDITIONS THAT WEREN'T A
STATE OF EMERGENCY DECLARATION
WILL HELP THE STATE QUICKLY
ADDRESS HARMFUL IMPACTS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
CAUSED BY ONE OF THESE EVENTS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. C. NOTIFICATION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARPAL OF
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES. FIFTY FOUR. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO A. B. FIFTY
SEVEN CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY SEVEN BY A SIMILAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS BACK LOOK INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MR GABRIEL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB FIFTY
SEVEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA BETTER RESPOND TO
DOCUMENT AND- RESPAUT HIT
RESPOND TO HATE CRIMES. HI THIS
IS BILL WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
NOW FOR THREE YEARS SENATE
AMENDMENTS LOWER THE COST OF
THE BILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GABRIEL. MR ONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IS A STRONG
SUPPORT AS OPPOSED BY PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB FIFTY SEVEN TODAY
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FERNANDO VALLEY
WORKING TO ADDRESS THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES HATE CRIMES
HAVE RISEN SIGNIFICANT LAST
YEAR PARTICULAR AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICAN. COMMUNITY AND THIS
WILL HELP TRAIN POLICE OFFICERS
TO IDENTIFY COMBAT THESE HATE
CRIMES I ALSO INTRODUCED TO
BUILD THIS YEAR TO ADDRESS HATE
CRIMES AND FORGE AND THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
THIS YEAR BUT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER TO BRING FOR
MORE OF THESE BILLS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I VOTE
ON. AB FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ONE SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MR GABRIEL YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF
YOU WISH I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
FOR HER PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT
WANT TO THANK MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO WERE PART OF
THIS EFFORT AS I MENTIONED THIS
IS BEEN A MULTI YEAR EFFORT
FOLLOWING AN AUDIT BY THE STATE
AUDITOR IN TWO THOUSAND.
EIGHTEEN WHICH POINTED OUT REAL
DEFICIENCIES IN THE WAY THAT
CALIFORNIA ADDRESSES HATE
CRIMES AND BY PASSING THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY HAVING IT SIGNED INTO
LAW WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
MEANINGFUL STEP FORWARD IN
PROTECTING ALL OF OUR BONE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
THREATENED BY HATE WITH THAT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. ON AB FIFTY SEVEN.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL. OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT.
WELL AS A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS WORKING CURTAIN. IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
AB SIXTY ONE. CORKERY SYMBOL
SIXTY ONE BIASED MEMBER GABRIEL
AND OTHERS TACKLING THE
BUSINESS PANDEMIC RELIEF
DECLARE IN THE YEARS TO THEIR
OF THICK BACK IMMEDIATELY. MR
GABRIEL YOU MAY GET OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SIXTY ONE
IS A BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED REGULATORY RELIEF
TO ARE STRUGGLING NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS THIS PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN. REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
AN OUTDOOR DINING HAS BEEN A
LIFELINE I WANT TO THANK THE
FIFTEEN MEMBERS OF THIS BODY
THAT ARE CO AUTHORS OF THIS
BILL APPRECIATE THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE WHERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. ON AB SIXTY ONE.
THANKS GABRIEL. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THAT IS PRETTY CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF A I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
MEASURE SENATE AMENDMENTS. R.
CONCURRED IN.
EVERSION FILE
ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR AB SIXTY EIGHT CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY EIGHT BY
SUMMER RECORDS SILVA AND OTHERS
BACKLIT IN HOUSING MS CLARK
SILVA. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SIXTY EIGHT IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
THIS BILL UPDATES THE STATE
WIDE HOUSING PLAN BY EXPANDING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IN ORDER
TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS OUR
STATE'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESS CRISIS. AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND ARE AT
THE REQUEST OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
QUICK SILVA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. SO
IS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ROLE TYLER HIGHS
SIXTY FIVE NOES ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
TWO SIX TWO. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
WERE PATTERSON AND OTHER STAFF
RELATED TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
MISTER PATTERSON. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWO SIX
TWO SIMPLIFIES AND EXPEDITES
THE WRECKAGE OF RELIEF PROCESS
FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
CLARIFIED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE RESPONSIBILITIES
RELATED TO CLEARING THE ARREST
AND CONVICTION RECORD. OF HUMAN
pCLARIFIED THAT ALL AGENCIES
HAVE NINETY DAYS TO COMPLY WITH
A COURT ORDER THE BILL HAS HAD
NO OPPOSITION RECEIVE NO A
SINGLE NO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO
CONCUR. IN THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK
WELL OPEN WORLD. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF HIS OUT OF THE
PARK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. AND MR CHOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF SENATOR TO
AROUSAL PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ITEM ONE TWELVE SB SEVEN
HUNDRED AND ITEM ONE FORTY
THREE SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED MEMBERS BACK ON THE
FILE. PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX WEIRD FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN AB THREE SEVENTY NINE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AND ACCORDING TO
CONSERVATION MEASURE GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THREE SEVENTY NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS NARROWED THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL BUT THIS BILL
STILL- PROVIDES FOR. HEARING A
GRAVE OVERSIGHT THAT WILL NOW
ALLOW OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
STEWARDS OF CONSERVATION LANDS
IN THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU MISS
GALLAGHER SEEN NO DISCUSSION.
FOR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ESERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. WORK
WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS OR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE.
AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT. OPERATE
SOME PEOPLE SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY
SOMEWHERE OVER THE BORDER
GARCIA AND OTHER SNACK LIVING
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MR
GARCIA- MISTER SPEAKER COLLEGES
BILLS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. BURKE
CABALLERO. THE SENATE VOTE OF
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY.
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY THREE BY MISS
WALDRON CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON AND
ACTUALLY THE MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. MISS
WALDRON THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB SIX FIVE THREE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WITH TECHNICAL IN NATURE IT
ENJOYS NOT POSITION AND HAS HAD
NO NO VOTES AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK MISS
WALDRON SAYING NO DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WILL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF
A I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE.
MISTER NAZARIAN CV SEVEN FORTY
NINE. CORKERY A SYMBOL SEVEN
FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY EMAINS
AREA MACKELDEN HEALTH CITIES
MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES THIS
LAST YEAR LAST YEAR AND A HALF
OF TAUGHT US MUCH DURING THE
COPA PANDEMIC CHIEF AMONG THEM
IS HOW WE REGULATE OUR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES A. B. SEVEN
FORTY NINE- WOULD PROHIBIT A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY FROM
CONTRACTING WITH THE PERSON AS
A MEDICAL DIRECTOR. IF THE
PERSON IS NOT OR WILL NOT BE
WITHIN FIVE YEARS A CERTIFIED
MEDICAL DIRECTOR- I ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE ON THIS BILL AFTER
SOME MINOR TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
WERE MADE IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. SEVERAL OF THE- LETTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VETERANS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED INFILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO IS AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CORPORATE. SOME PEOPLE SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE
HOUSING ISSUE GABRIEL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SEVENTY
SEVEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THIS BILL WOULD HELP PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED AT WORK FORCE AND
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING AT THIS
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADD CO
AUTHORS INCORPORATE FEEDBACK
FROM DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CORPORAL. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE. AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN COVERAGE. ASSEMBLE A
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS BACK
LEADING THE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
MYSTERY OF US THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
LIMIT THE BILL'S AUTHORIZATION
TO ELEAZAR THAT SERVE FORTY
THOUSAND OR MORE STUDENTS
DURING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. FAMOUS RIVAS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLARK LOCAL. RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COULD
HURT IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY FOUR. AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
CORPORATE. SYMBOL EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS BACK LETTING
THE CHILD CARE MISS CLARK SILVA.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE AS
A WOMAN CAUCUS PRIORITY AND
THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE ACCESS
TO INVIOLABILITY OF CHILD CARE
AND CALIFORNIA AND IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. TAKING THIS OVER
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE IN CHINA
BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONVERTED. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN CORPORATE.
SYMBOL E. SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
RELIVING AND OTHERS NOT GOING
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MICHELLE
OF EIGHT. YEAH I THINK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST HAD A
DIFFERENT FILE BILL CONNECTIONS
WHILE I'LL SWITCH MY BILLS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE COURT FACILITIES THAT
PROCESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDERS TO
ALLOW PETITIONS TO BE FILED
ELECTRONICALLY DO DO WE NEED TO
RESTART THIS. DO YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SHOULD WE RESTART THIS
DID WITH THE BILL'S RIGHT. THIS
IS THE RIGHT BILL AND FILE
NUMBER. THIS IS THE CORRECT
OKAY GOOD THANK YOU AB EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN WOULD HELP VICTIMS
TO ESCAPE THE SOUNDS BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH A WAY TO
DISCREETLY FILE ONLINE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SENATE
WERE PER THE RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNSELORS
THAT THEY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DAVIS LEVINE SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHERE IS
THERE TO VOTE FOR WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS. ARE
CONCURRED IN AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX MR LEVINE AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY GO EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY ROOT LEVINE ANOTHER
SNORKELING SLAUGHTER ANIMALS
MISS LEVINE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PROMISES TO BE THE LAST
ONE FOR TODAY AT LEAST EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE
GREATER FLEXIBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS RANCHERS TO
PROVIDE FRESHLY LOCALLY GROWN
AND RAISED PRODUCTS AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE. WE'RE PER
THE RECOMMENDATION OF CDFA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DAVIS LEVINE C.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLARK
WELL OVER THE ROLE. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TYLER HI SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY SEVEN CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
GO NINE TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE MEDINA
AND OTHERS TACKLING THE PUBLIC
CORSICA'S CATION. THE SHOW
MEDINA. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND CLARIFY THE
REPORTING. AMONG THE UNIVERSITY
SEGMENTS AND THE MAXIMUM NUMBER
OF BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS. AB
NINE TWENTY SEVEN HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS HAD NO
NO VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
GOODNESS FOR DATA. FORMER. DR
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN YOUR
SPEAKER IN THE MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN THAT'S A PROBLEM LEAD
AUTHOR WITH MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
RIVERSIDE. FOR MANY ON
PROFESSIONS- THE OPTICAL
LAUREATE DEGREE ARE HAS BECOME
THE STANDARD THE FOR ENTRY INTO
THE WORKFORCE THIS MANAGER OLD
INCREASE ACCESS TO A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAMS
SO WHILE ALSO INCREASING THE-
EARNING POWER OF OUR GRADUATES.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT WORKFORCE
MANAGER ADOPT WILL PROVIDE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE-
MEANS- TO ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE
STATES A NEED FOR ONE EDUCATED
WORK WORKFORCE. AYE ELSEWHERE
AYE VOTE. I SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE IS OUT ABOUT CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE AT I. SIXTY NO
ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHT CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
WERE BERMAN AND OTHERS TACKLING
THE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION MR
BERMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES- THIS
BILL HAS MUCH MORE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE LAST BILL I
INTRODUCED. AB NINE TWENTY IT
WOULD IMPROVE AND REIMAGINE THE
TRANSFER PROCESS FROM THE
STUDENT PERSPECTIVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE COST OF
THE BILL ADDING THAT AT ANOTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT TO
THE INTERSEGMENT ALL
IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEE AND
STRENGTHEN FACULTY'S ROLE. IN
THE CREATION CREATION OF THE
SINGULAR GENERAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY THE STUDENT CENTERED
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON CURRENT AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK
GOODNESS BERMAN SCENE NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CABALLERO. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. THE CLERK WILL. FEDERAL TIED
UP I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT. AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE AB
ONE THOUSAND THREE SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TOTAL THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS TACKLING THE GRAND
THEFT THIS GONZALEZ THIS IS A
GREAT BILL WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT EVEN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
RIGHT HERE IS VERY NICE I HOPE
YOU WILL TOO. THANK YOU MISS
CONSEILLERS SANDO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. A CORPORAL. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT THIRTY
WILL CLOSER ALL. ANTI VOTE I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING TO THE SENATE.
THIRD READING FILE. MOMENTARILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
OUT THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE. FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
BY THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION AND ACTUALLY THE
HORSE RACING MISS BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB EIGHT TWENTY IS THE
SENATE GEO COMMITTEE BILL THAT
MAKES MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES
TO THE WAY BEAR SUPPORT THEIR
TOTAL GROSS RECEIPTS ARE
ADJUSTED GROSS RECEIPTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE SALES
OCCURRING ON A BEARISH
PROPERTY. THREE QUARTERS OF 1%
OF THOSE TOTAL SALES ARE THEN
REDISTRIBUTED TO FARES THE BILL
SIMPLY ENSURES ACCURATE
ACCOUNTING OF THESE RECEIPTS
AND TIMELIER DEGREE
DISTRIBUTION TO THE STATE'S
DESIGNATED BEARS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS BURKE SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THERE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS. OF THE- ALL VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL NOW TAKE A FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE SB THREE
ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE ELEVEN BY
CENTER HUESO AND OTHER STAFF OF
THE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER
THANK YOU HAVE A SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON SENATE BILL S.
AT THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSIONATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS ACT OR RYAN'S LAW.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
HOSPITALS AND CERTAIN TYPES OF
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS TO
ACCESS MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR
TREATMENT. OF PAIN IN HER PAIN
RELIEF SB THREE ELEVEN HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY HEALTH SENATE HEALTH
AND ON THE SENATE FLOOR THE
HOUSE ALSO PASSED THIS HOUSE
ALSO PASSED A SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WITH THE UNANIMOUS VOTE. SB
THREE ELEVEN WILL PROVIDE
RELIEF COMPASSION AND DIGNITY
TO TERMINALLY ILL CALIFORNIANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF
THE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING HER I FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
TWO S. B. TWO SEVENTY THE
BURGLARY SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY BY SENATOR ALSO AND
OTHER RESPECT WHETHER THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MISTER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB TWO
SEVENTY PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
LAST WEEK WITH FIFTY VOTES. WE
NEED TO BE RECALL FOR
COMPROMISE. ONCE AGAIN-COLLEAGUES SB TWO SEVENTY
CLOSER PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE ACCURATE
AND TIMELY BARGAINING UNIT
INFORMATION REGARDING ENTITLED
TO BY LAW LET ME HAVE THE
EXCUSE ME SO THE MIDDLE FILTER
LEGAL REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES
AND MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
BARGAINING UNITS AS A WHOLE.
AGAIN THIS MEASURE CHRIS KNOW
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IS SIMPLY INCENTIVIZE
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY TO
EMPLOYERS SO THEY MAY NEED.
THEIR CURRENT LEGAL OBLIGATIONS
ARE THE FIFTH RIVAL IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. CALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR. ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD
OF A. ARMORIES THIRTY THIRD OF
BOTH. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY NINERS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEDINA FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE SB EIGHT
HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT HUNDRED BY
CENTER ARCHULETA AND OTHERS
BACK TO THE REAL ESTATE HELLO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MASSACRE AND
COLLEAGUES SB EIGHT HUNDRED IS
THE SENSE THAT BILL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE IN
THE BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LOW. SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. CALL MEMBERS VOTED
THIRTY. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A
THIRD OF IT. ALL RIGHT
RESERVED- CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
TWO ONE TWO TWO THREE TWO BILLS.
THE PROJECT WILL.
WILL MOVE TO
VIOLATE ONE FIFTY FOUR SB FIVE
TEN THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL FIVE TEN BY SERVER PANOPLY
THE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. IS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB FIVE TEN REQUIRES HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS TO COVER
COVERT NINETEEN TESTING. AND
VACCINATION WITHOUT COST
SHARING FOR PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FROM BOTH IN NETWORKING OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS DURING THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
CAUSED BY COCA NINETEEN. THESE
PROTECTIONS REMAIN FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED BY IN MY- IN IN
NETWORK PROVIDERS FOLLOWING THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. THIS
BILL ALSO PROHIBITS BALANCE
BILLING BY PROVIDERS FOR PROFIT
NINETEEN TESTING AND
IMMUNIZATIONS EVEN AFTER THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY EXPIRES.
THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM THIS
PANDEMIC HAVE LED TO A
FRAMEWORK THAT THIS BILL PUTS
IN PLACE THAT WOULD ALLOW
FEDERALLY APPROVED TESTING
IMMUNIZATIONS WITH NO COST
SHARING FOR FUTURE PANDEMIC. SB
FIVE TEN IS A MUCH NEEDED BILL
BECAUSE FEDERAL AND STATE
AGENCIES HAVE SENT OUT EVOLVING
AND SOMETIMES CONFLICTING
GUIDANCE WHICH JUST MADE IT
CONFUSING FOR PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS TO KNOW WHEN THEY
WILL BE CHARGED. THE SCIENCE IS
CLEAR TESTING IS SYMPTOMATIC
AND ASYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALS ALONG WITH THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED. TO OUT
OF POCKET COSTS THIS IS WHY SB
FIVE TEN IS NEEDED NOW THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONSISTENT LAWS
REGARDING KOPEN NINETEEN
TESTING AND THE SHOTS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- MEMBERS VOTED TO
THIRD OF. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
ESERVER. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOW IT ABOUT ICE
FORTY SIX NO SIXTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
FIVE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX SB
EIGHT SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENEGALESE SIXTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS NOT GOING TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES MR RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SENATE
BILL EIGHT SIXTEEN AS
AUTHORIZED BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AND HAS PROGRESS
ON CONSENT. SB EIGHT SIXTEEN
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
CAL- YES TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN TRIBES TO LEARN MUTUAL
AID DURING DECLARED DISASTERS
AND EMERGENCIES. EARLY STATE
LAW ONLY AUTHORIZES HELLO YES
TO ENTER AGREEMENTS WITH THE
STATE'S VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES AND VARIOUS POLITICAL
SUBDIVISIONS OF THE STATE.
TRIBES ARE NOT POLITICAL
SUBDIVISIONS OF THE STATE. NONE
THE LESS CALIFORNIA TRIBES PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN THE INTEGRAL
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S EMERGING
RESPONSE STRUCTURE DURING
DISASTERS NEVER BEEN SO FOR
MANY DECADES I RESPECT OUT
FARRAGO. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
ERICA. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING VOTE I SEVENTY
TWO NEW ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK UP.
TO NEAR THE TOP OF THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE TO FILE ITEM
ONE ELEVEN. SB THREE TWENTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY THREE
BY SILICON VALE AND OTHER BACK
INTO LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS RIVAS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB THREE TWENTY THREE
WHICH WOULD CREATE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR CLAIMS AGAINST
WATER. AND SEWER AGENCY RATE
SETTINGS WATER AND SEWER
UTILITY BUDGETS ARE FUNDED BY
REVENUE COLLECTED THROUGH
SERVICE RATES THESE RATES
PROVIDE THE FUNDING NECESSARY
TO SUPPLY SAFE DRINKING WATER
UPGRADE AND IMPROVE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MISS RIVAS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
END OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
VOTED ARTICLE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOW IT AYE SIXTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE TWELVE HAS BEEN
MOVED TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FOURTEEN. SB THREE TWENTY
REVERBERATE. SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY BY CENTER EGGMAN AND
OTHERS NOT RELATED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. MAYES RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TO THEM PRESENTING SB THREE
TWENTY WHICH SEEKS TO BETTER
PROTECT SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE FROM GUN VIOLENCE EVERY
YEAR MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
AMERICAN WOMEN ARE SHOT TO
DEATH BY INTIMATE PARTNERS.
ROUGHLY ONE DEATH EVERY
FOURTEEN HOURS IN NEARLY TWO
THIRDS OF CASES IN WHICH A GUN
WAS PRESIDENT OR THE ABUSE OF
PARTNER VICTIM LIVE TOGETHER
THE ABUSIVE PARTNER USED A
FIREARM AGAINST THE VICTIMS
USUALLY THREATENING TO INJURE
OR KILL HER. SB THREE TWENTY
CODIFIES CALIFORNIA'S ROLE CORD
FIVE POINT FOUR NINE FIVE WHICH
CREATES A JUDICIAL OVERSIGHT
PROCESS TO ENSURE FARMS TO
BECOME PROHIBITED AS A RESULT
OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER OR ACTUALLY
RELINQUISHED AT THE EARLIEST
MOMENTS. THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THE COURT
COMMUNICATE WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT FAILURE TO
RELINQUISH THE THESE WEAPONS
WHICH WILL ASSIST IN PREVENTING
POTENTIALLY DEADLY ESCALATIONS
OF GUN VIOLENCE IN ALREADY
VOLATILE SITUATIONS. WE KNOW
THAT BY THE PRESENCE OF A
FIREARM IN THE HOME DURING AN
INCIDENT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCREASES THE RISK OF HOMICIDE
BY AT LEAST 5100% BECAUSE THE
RULE OF COURT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO CODIFY IS NOT
MANDATORY OVERSIGHT OF FIREARM
RELINQUISHMENT IN THE CIVIL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CONTEXT OF
INCONSISTENT ACROSS IS.
INCONSISTENT ACROSS THE STATE
BETWEEN 6290% OF FAMILY LAW
LITIGANTS OURSELVES REPRESENTED
AND HAVE TO NAVIGATE THE DO THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM BY THEMSELVES
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWLEDGE-OF THIS FACT AND MAKES CLEAR
THAT THE BEST ENTITY TO STEP IN
AND MAKE SURE FARMS ARE LEGAL
RELINQUISHED AT THE EARLIEST
MOMENT POSSIBLE IS THE COURT.
SB THREE TWENTY HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RUBY C.
HEARING FURTHER DELAY ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A THIRD OF THE. MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I SIXTY SEVEN NEWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. BILITIS
ONE FIFTEEN ONE SIXTEEN HAVE
BEEN MOVED TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE.
WE NEED TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FOR TWENTY EIGHT BY CENTER HER
TADO AND OTHERS NOT GOING TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. MR GRAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT REQUIRES COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE PROVIDERS TO COVER
THE COST OF SCREENING PATIENTS
FOR ACES. WHICH IS ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER GRAY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE NEWS HERE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THE MEDIA FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTEEN SB FOUR EIGHTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FORTY THREE BY CENTER
ALLEN ACCORDING TO RECENT SING
MISTER BRIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TO PRESENT SB FORTY THREE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR BEN ALLEN. IN
RECENT YEARS WE'VE ENACTED A
NUMBER OF LOS CLOSELY KNOWN AS
THE RISE ACTS IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS
THEY'VE EFFECTIVELY. REPEAL
SENATE FINANCE. WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS.
AND WHAT DOES BILLS DID AS THEY
SHOW THE DISPARITIES BETWEEN
BLACK BROWN PORN BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES AND THEY SHOW THE
MONEY WE WERE WASTING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BY ADDING ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS ON THE PEOPLE
SENTENCES. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IT ALL YEAH THIS LEGISLATORS
WELL WHAT WE DIDN'T DO WE PASS
THOSE ACTS. WAS CONSIDER THE
RETROACTIVITY OF. PEOPLE THAT
WERE INCARCERATED BEFORE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. ARE NOT BENEFITING
FROM LEGISLATION WE'VE ALREADY
PATH WE'VE MADE THE SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS ILLEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY CAN'T BE USED
ANYMORE AND SIMULTANEOUSLY WE
HAVE ALMOST EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE INCARCERATED. UNDER
SOLELY THE FINANCING HAS.
THAT'S ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT
WE'RE SPENDING INCARCERATING
PEOPLE FOR SOMETHING WE ALREADY
DECIDED IN THIS BODY YOU CAN'T
BE INCARCERATED FOR. WHAT THIS
BILL DOES THAT RIGHTS THAT.
PROVIDES EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK ME
I'LL VOTE IT'S TIME TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A MASSACRE BY
THE SUPPORT OF SB FORTY THREE
AS MENTIONED LEGISLATURE
ALREADY REPEALED. THE SENTENCE
MASTERS BECAUSE THERE'S
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE TO SHOW
THEIR IN A FACTOR PREVENTING
CRIME INTERNET ENHANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY. I'M AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- UNDER SB FORTY
THREE PROVIDES RETROACTIVE
SENTENCES BASED UPON WHAT WE
KNOW TODAY. WILL NOT GRANT
AUTOMATIC RELEASE THOSE WERE
ELIGIBLE GO BEFORE A JUDGE FOR
RESENTENCING HEARING. IF THE
COURT FINDS THAT REDUCING THEIR
SENTENCE WOULD ENDANGER PUBLIC
SAFETY IT CAN REQUIRE THE
PERSON TO SERVE THEIR ORIGINAL
SENTENCE RIGHT. SO YOU STILL
HAVE JUDICIAL REVIEW PRIOR TO
ANYONE GETTING RELEASED OR
HAVING AND HAS BEEN STRICKEN
THIS BILL IS A COMMONSENSE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THE-
ADDRESS INEQUITIES WITHIN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. RESPECTFULLY
URGE I ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
RYAN YOU MAY CLOSE. ONE THING
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE BAY FOR
POINTING THAT OUT. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED FOR SOMETHING THIS
BODY IN THE STATE IS ALREADY
RULED IS ILLEGAL. AND NOT A WAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PRACTICE
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY GET TO
BE AUTOMATICALLY RELEASED THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S MOVE TO
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A RIGHT TO
RESENTENCING HEARINGS. AND IF
THERE'S CLEAR CONVINCING
EVIDENCE BUT JUDGE. AT RELEASE.
CAN THAT WOULD LEAVE BE STALL.
THEY ARE SAFEGUARDS IN THIS.
BUT THOSE SAFEGUARDS. COMMITTEE
IT'S NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF
MOVING JUSTICE FORWARD.
RETROACTIVITY ONE. THANK YOU
CAN SAID IT WAS AN INCIDENT HAS
WITH. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
AGAIN FROM THE BAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. SIDE OF THE- HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE BOTH AS FAR AS
FORTY ONE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED
ABOUT THIS CAR'S.
FORTY ONE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERT ABOUT
THIS FIRST.
FORTY ONE. THIS
REMOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS MOVING
TO THE NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN S. B.
FIVE TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FIVE TWELVE MONTHS
AND THE MEN AND OTHERS BACK
WITHIN A PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB FIVE TWELVE IS A
BILL WE CAN ALL RALLY BEHIND
FOSTER YOUTH FACE SEVERAL
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING HIGHER
EDUCATION SB FIVE TWELVE WOULD
REMOVE THESE BARRIERS AND
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR PRIOR
FOR PRIORITY ENROLLMENT A
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
ON BEHALF OF CENTER MAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF
THE. ON NUMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WE. OUR MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY ABOUT I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MESURE
PASSES WIENER FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SB FIVE THIRTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY THREE BY SEVEN
STERN ACCORDING TO A LECTURE
CITY. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB FIVE THREE THREE ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR STERN THIS IS A BILL
THAT REQUIRES THE STATE'S
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS TO IDENTIFY
ENERGY CIRCUITS THAT HAVE
FREQUENTLY BEEN DE ENERGIZED
DURING PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFFS. THEY ALSO PLAN FOR HOW I
ARE USED TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
AN IMPACT FUTURE D.
INTERNALIZATION OF THOSE
CIRCUITS. PS PS OUTAGES REMAIN
A TOOL OF LAST RESORT TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM THE
RISK OF WILDFIRE. HOWEVER LAST
YEAR PARTS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE MORE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
THEN EXPERIENCE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. MANY OF THESE EVENTS
RESULTED IN LOSS OF POWER TO
CUSTOMER FOR BETWEEN THREE AND
FIVE DAYS AT A TIME OFTEN ON
THE SAME ENERGY CIRCUIT AND
MULTIPLE TIMES IN A SINGLE
MONTH. THIS BILL ADDS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BY REQUIRING THE I'LL USE TO
UPDATE THEIR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS WITH DETAILS
ABOUT POWER SHUT OFF BROWN
ENERGY CIRCUITS. AND HOW THEY
PLAN TO REDUCE SHUT OFFS AND
IMPACT ON CUSTOMERS WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GALE MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. YEAH I THINK HE
MEANT SPEAKER MEMBERS BRIEFLY I
JUST WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- AS- COMING FROM A
DISTRICT WHERE MANY OF THESE P.
S. P. S. OFFENSIVE. HAVE
OCCURRED AND I THINK THIS WOULD
BE A VERY USEFUL TOOL IN
HELPING US TO- ULTIMATELY
ESTABLISH. NO BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO HELP AVOID
THE DURATION AND THE IMPACT OF
THESE EVENTS ON OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
ZERO THE LIKE TO CLOSE. JAI
MISTER GALLAGHER SUPPORT ON THE
BELL RESPECT WE ARE FROM ABOUT
THIRTY WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VERY
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS GO TO IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE WERE HELLO THEIR ROLE AND
THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE SB
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT SENATE BILL
570% OF ACCOUNTS KINETICALLY
THE VEHICLES. WE'RE BACK TO YOU
MISTER BERMAN. THANK YOU.
MATHIS BIGGER. SB FIVE SEVENTY
WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA'S
VEHICLE CODE EQUIPMENT LIST
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
ACCOUNTING FOR ELECTRIC AND
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU MR BERMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. YOU DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU GO TO I. SIXTY WHO
KNOWS YOUR THE MEASURE PASSES
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE SB
SIX EIGHTY SIX CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL 686% OF LASER AND
OTHER SNACK LIVING TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MR BERMAN
AGAIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M FEELING A
LITTLE A LITTLE PICKED ON SB
SIX EIGHTY SIX SIX TO PROVIDE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE FOR LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES THAT MAKE
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS AND
EXPENDITURES. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION
EXAMINATION OF LLCS FOUND THAT
IT WAS RELATIVELY EASY TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT ANALYSIS TYPE
OF BUSINESS IT'S ADDRESS IT IS
AGENT FOR SERVICE OF PROCESS.
HOWEVER IT WAS VERY TO
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT AND IN MANY
CASES IMPOSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY
AND LLCS OWNERS OR THE TRUE
SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR ITS
POLITICAL EXPENDITURES SB SIX
EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES L. SEES
THAT MAKE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS AND EXPENDITURES
TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE SPECIFIED
MEMBERS OF THE L. C. SO THAT
VOTERS HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TRUE SOURCE OF FUNDS USED
BY ALL SEASON STATE ELECTIONS.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO KNOW
WHO IS TRYING TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS IN THE SIMPLE YET
MEANINGFUL APPROACH AIMS TO
PROVIDE THAT CLARITY THAT'S WHY
MY PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE
SENSIBLE BILL THAT IS SPONSORED
BY THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION IT HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN. SEEING AND HEARING
THERE FOR THE AND I THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR ALL. MEMBERS
THIRD OF A- HOME VOTE DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE AT
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT
THIS REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR. OUR
MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. YEAH.
MR
BERMAN WAS A COP.
THIS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM.
SEVENTY ONE EIGHTY ONE ONE ONE
ZERO ROBERT RIVAS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO THE CONCURRENT
FILE. TAKE UP SOME OF OUR
ASSEMBLY BILL WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB TEN THIRTY
SIX MEMBERS WE WILL THEN BE
WORKING IN FILE ORDER SO PLEASE
BE READY FOR BILLS COMING. BY
THEN SEVENTY AB TEN THIRTY SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TEND THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS NOT GOING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR CIGARETTES. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES THE
AMENDMENTS. MADE IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WERE TECHNICAL
AND CALIFORNIA NATURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VERY THIRD- CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CAN
CURTAIN WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE MOVING
FILE ITEM SEVEN TO AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN THIRTY WILL READ SOME-APPROVAL LEVIN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND I GO
TO THE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON.
H. I PROMISE NOT COLLEGE. AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN CREATE A COMMON
DURING CAL COMMUTE COLLEGES
MANY COMPARABLE COURSES WERE OF
THE SAME COURSE NUMBER IT'S AN
AWESOME BILL SENTIMENTS EXTEND
THE IMPLEMENTATION DAY IN A
LINE THE BILL TO BUDGET
LANGUAGE WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR BERMAN
SEEING HER IN THERE FOR THE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER PARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF IT.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THAT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN AND
NOW WE CAN MOVE ON FROM MR
BERMAN. AND GO TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE A QUICK READ. SOME GIRL
LIVING EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AND OTHERS
NATURALLY THE SUIT FINANCIALLY
CLEARLY WAS INTERRUPTED FACT
IMMEDIATELY CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS IN RESPONSE TO
THE DISRUPTIONS AND DELAYS
CAUSED BY THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
WILL HELP PRESERVE THE CAL
GRANT ELIGIBILITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS BY PROVIDING THEMAN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO MEET STATE
REQUIREMENTS AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES IN A DRESS CHAPTER IN
OUT ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU. TEST
IN HERE NO FOR DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TWO THIRDS VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT
AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
LIVING A FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR
AB TWELVE FORTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE TWELVE
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO AND OTHERS
TACKLING THE PROTECTIVE ORDERS
THIS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWO TWELVE FORTY
THREE WHICH STRENGTHENS UP-
PROTECTIONS FOR ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT TWO PROTECTIVE
ORDERS IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE
RECEIVING UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU MISS RUBIO
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS BOTH THE
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THIRD VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT VOTE
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONVERTED MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AB
TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME RULE TWELVE SIXTY ONE
BY US AND WE WERE BURKE AND
OTHERS NECKLACE IN THE
GREENHOUSE GASES BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE
SIMPLY CODIFIES RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE STATE AUDITOR AFTER
CONFERRING WITH CARD WE AGREED
ON AMENDMENTS THAT SPECIFIED
CARP SHOULD PARTNER WITH UC AND
CSU TO PUBLISH ITS WORK. THIS
BILLS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND
ENJOYED BY PARTISAN RISK
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IRAQ MY GOD
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
DON'T THINK YOU MISSED BURKE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER.
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE- HOME MEMBERS THIRTY TO
THIRTY VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOWEVER I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN A FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SIXTY B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWELVE NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
MACINNES CHILD CARE THE CLEARLY
YEARS EITHER OF TAKE BACK
IMMEDIATELY AFTER PARK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN MY DESK- THANK
YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL.
A. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR WORK SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THEM OUT OF
THE PARK WILL OPEN THE- MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN NINETY BY A SUMMER
BOERNER HORVATH CONNECTED AND
STATE LANDS WITH BERNARD BACK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. YES THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY WILL PROVIDE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION WITH
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO GENERATE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES FOR RETIRED
TEACHERS AND FACILITATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT ON
SCHOOL AND THROUGH THE
MANAGEMENT SCHOOL AND SALES AND
ACQUISITIONS. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION TO FILE A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ANNUALLY ON ALL
TRANSACTIONS RELATED SCHOOL
LANDS AND MAKES TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES THIS WILL
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU MISS
BURN OVER AT SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THIRD WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO MOVE.
ALL MEMBERS TO THE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. CLERK
WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN LUNA FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE
AB THREE THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY FIVE BY SUMMER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS
NEVER PRIVACY FOR HER BACK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE THREE
FIVE OF THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
BILL. THAT WILL ALLOW
MANUFACTURERS OF RECREATIONAL
BOATS THE MARINE ENGINES TO
RECEIVE AND RETAIN SPECIFIC
CONTACT CUSTOMER INFORMATION
FOR LIMITED AND EXCLUSIVE USE
OF CONDUCTING PRODUCT SAFETY
RECALLS AND WARRANTY
VERIFICATION THE SENATE MEMBERS
TO JUST DROP DURING OUR
COMMITMENT THE BILL HAS SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES ESPECIALLY AFTER
I VOTE FOR IT. THANK YOU MISS
BERNARD VACCINE HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE. ON THE MATTER
WELL OPEN THE ROLE. THE THIRD.
HOME MEMBERS IS OUR VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE TWO THIRDS VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE AND
HOW IT I SO. KNOWS SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHER STAFF HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB THREE FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DR
AREA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF
THEM. LONG MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESIRED OF THE- BURKE WILL LOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY BUT I FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE INCURRED IN. MR BERMAN IS
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON SB
SIX EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
A. MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT
THIS REQUIRES. FIFTY FOUR. WORK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE HIGHS FIFTY FOUR NEW
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER RYAN IS PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON SB FOUR EIGHTY
THREE THE COLOURFUL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY ONE
NEWS TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK ON TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYONE
PAYING ATTENTION IF THEY'RE
WORKING- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE SB
SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SIXTY FIVE BY
SERVICE SCANNER AND OTHERS NOT
MEAN TO MATERNAL CARE AND
SERVICES MISS BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB SIXTY FIVE
THE CALIFORNIA MOM ABOUT THE
ACT WHICH TAKES A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR BIRTHING PARENTS AND BABIES
PARTICULARLY FOR BREEDING
PARENTS OF BABIES OF COLOR.
MATERNAL DEATH IN THE U. S. IS
HIGHER THAN THAN COUNTRIES WITH
THE SAME WEALTH BLACK WOMEN AND
INFANTS ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BLACK MOTHERS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
EDUCATION HAVE MORE PRE AND
POSTPARTUM HEALTH COMPLICATIONS
AND DEATH THAN WHITE MOTHERS
AND BLACK INFANTS HAVE TWICE AS
HIGH OF INFANT MORTALITY. SB
SIXTY FIVE WORKS TO IMPROVE
VOTING OUTCOMES BY ESTABLISHING
THE PREGNANCY ASSOCIATION
MORTALITY REVIEW BOARD
REQUIRING THAT THOSE WHO SERVE
ON THE BOARD HAVE EXPERIENCE
MATERNAL CARE ESTABLISHING A
STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUP TO AID IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
MEDIC HOW DO THE BENEFITS FOR
BRAVING MOTHERS. THAT WAS
PASSED IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
AND ESTABLISH A FUND FROM
MIDWIFE TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
PRIORITIZE TRAINING UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS AND NATIONAL
COALITION HAS COME TOGETHER FOR
THE MOM THE BEST ACT FOCUSING
ON SECURING BETTER OTHER HAVE
COME OUTCOMES FOR BABIES AND
PARENTS OF COLOR. AT THE STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVEL LET'S DO OUR
PART TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
PARENTS AND INFANTS HAVE
BIRTHING EXPERIENCES THAT ARE
BEAUTIFUL AND SAFE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT
BILL. THEY YOU MISTER. SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER WELL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS VOTE THIRD OF THE- HOME
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR VOTE.
CLERK WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOOD
FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY. SB
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SEVENTY THREE
BY SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS
MEDICAL INFORMATION YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WIENER IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR PRESENT SENATE BILL
SEVENTY THREE WHICH WILL REPEAL
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES FOR
PEOPLE CONVICTED OF SPECIFIC
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES AND
PROVIDES JUDGES. THE DISCRETION
TO GRANT PERMISSION ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS UNDER CURRENT LAW
CALIFORNIA PROHIBITS JUDGES
FROM USING THEIR BEST DOCUMENT
TO ORDER PROBATION IN CASES
INVOLVING NON VIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES WE ARE TRYING WE ARE
TYING THE HANDS OF JUDGES BY
REQUIRING EVERY SINGLE CASE
THEY SEE RESULT IN
INCARCERATION EVEN WHEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE
CLEARLY INDICATE THAT THE
PERSON WOULD BE BETTER
REHABILITATED WITH SUPERVISED
PROBATION. IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY. NOTHING IN SB
SEVENTY THREE LOWERS HER
CHANGES. THE EXISTING UPPER
PENALTIES FOR THESE OFFENSES OR
PROHIBITS COURTS FROM
SENTENCING SOMEONE TO JAIL. OR
PRISON IT'S SIMPLY EXPANDS. THE
RANGE OF SENTENCING OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO JUDGES BASED ON
THE FACTS. OF THE CASE. SB
SEVENTY THREE WILL SIMPLY ALLOW
JUDGES TO WEIGH THE FACTS OF
THE CASE AND DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. IF THEY PRISON OR
JAIL SENTENCE IS APPROPRIATE
AND ALSO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
ABILITY TO ORDER PROBATION IF
IT IS. IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
JUSTICE WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TWO THIRDS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER THIS
REQUIRES. FORTY ONE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERTA SCORES.
FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO START
ABOUT THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE.
IT'S CREAM OF THE CROP. WHERE
IS MR.
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE
BACK TO YOUR. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO THE
CONCURRENCE FILE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE. AND PASADENA VIOLATE
EIGHTY THREE MOVING A FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX FORTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
SIX FORTY TWO BY A SUMMARY
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS THAT ARE
THE WILD FIRES. THE THREE MEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
WAS THE BILL THAT HELPS TO
EXPAND PRESCRIBED A CULTURAL
BIRDS IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP
WITH OUR WILDFIRE CRISIS. THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCORPORATE
CALIFORNIA OR SUGGESTIONS AND
DEAL WITH TRAPPING ISSUES AND I
WOULD URGE MY VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THERE HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
OUR MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE IS FIFTY
NINE NEWS ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE WILL MOVE BACK
UP TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE FOR
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS NATURALLY THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS HOW ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTEEN THE DEFORESTATION FREE
PROCUREMENT ACT. IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE TO CONFIRM
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE THE
BOREAL FORESTS. AND CLARIFY
DEFINITIONS. HE'S A MEMBERS
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM
CANADIAN PROVINCES OF ALBERTA.
BRITISH COLUMBIA AND QUEBEC.
AND MY BIRTHPLACE OF ONTARIO
CANADA. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
MOVED. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. OUR MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE A. THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY TWO NO SEVENTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WILL MOVE BACK DOWN TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB SIX NINETY
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE SIX NINETY BY THE SUMMER
ARAMBULA INACTIVE IN THE
HEALING ARTS. DR EMILY WERE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT EIGHTY SIX NINETY WHICH
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU STRANMILLIS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH
USER TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VOTE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX
AB SEVEN OH ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE SEVEN OH ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS NOT GOING
TO IMPLEMENT GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- MEMBERS THIS BILL IS
BACK ON. CURRENTS WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
RESPOND TO THEIR MAJOR CONCERNS
ON THE BILL IT MADE AMENDMENTS
AND SENATE WHICH REMOVES THE
BILL'S STATUS AS EIGHT
CALCHAMBER JOB KILLER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE
THIS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERTED THE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A- CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT
ICE FORTY FOUR NEWS FIFTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN- TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT THE
KERKORIAN. SOME EMOJIS NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE AND
OTHERS BATTLING THE CRIMINAL
RECORDS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IS AB
EIGHT NINE EIGHT IS BACK UP AND
CURRENT SOMEONE SURE THAT
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION
ABOUT A PERSON'S FROM RECORD IS
ACCURATE WHEN A PROBATION IS
TRANSFERRED. AB EIGHT NINE
EIGHT WAS ON CONSENT TO THE
POLICY COMMITTEES PASS THIRTY
TO ZERO IN THE SENATE AND HAS
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES OR
SICKLY AFTER I'VE OF. THANK YOU
MISTER LEE'S. MISTER COOPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU BILLS BIGGER. CUSHION
FOR THE AUTHOR. WITH THIS BILL
I SUPERIOR COURT TO PROVIDE
RECORDS THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES RECOGNITION
IS BEEN DISMISSED. I WILL
ANSWER MY CALLS OKAY BECAUSE
THIS BILL IS NOT ALLOW CTC THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHER
CREDENTIALING COMMISSION AND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES TO
REVIEW CRIMINAL RECORDS OF
INDIVIDUALS APPLIED RITUAL TURN
I CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR KIDS THAT
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING A FULL ACCESS TO
COURT RECORDS IN ORDER TO KEEP
OUR CHILDREN SAFE. MY FEELING
IS LEGAL MANDATE TO EVALUATE
PROSPECTIVE OR CURRENT
EDUCATORS DETERMINE IF THEY ARE
FIT TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER MISTER LEE MAKERS
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERNED BUT THE CDC WHICH WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH HAS A
PROBLEM WITH EXISTING LAW. AND
WE ARE WORKING TO SEE ANOTHER
EDUCATION GROUPS TO. TALK ABOUT
THE ISSUE BUT IS NOT GERMANE TO
THIS EXISTS EXISTING OR THIS
BILL WHICH ABOUT COURT
TRANSFERS SO CLASS ARRIVAL.
BURKE WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
NUMBER THIRTY THIRD OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
OUR MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A
REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. OUR
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE. YEAH.
OUR MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARTIFICE BUYERS.
FORTY ONE. REMOVE THE CAR.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE BACK UP
TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE ZERO
TO THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FIVE OH TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE THESE AN AGGREGATE A
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS IF
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU-
I RISE TO PRESENT EIGHTY FIVE
UP TO WHICH IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
SENATE ADDED INCREASE NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOAS TO USE
VOTE BY ACCLAMATION EVENT. AND
THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVED OFF
FROM OPPOSITION THIS BILL
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN THE
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU. SEEING AND HEARING THERE
FOR THE DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESERT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WILL MOVE BACK TO
FILE ORDER WHICH WAS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY NINE AB NINE FORTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE NINE FORTY ONE BY A
SUMMER BENNETT AND OTHERS
TACKLING THE FARMERS MR MANY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
EIGHTY NINE FORTY ONE PROVIDES
GRANTS TO CREATE FARMWORKER
RESOURCE CENTERS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS SO FAR
RECEIVED NO NO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THIRD OF THOSE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY
FOOT. OUR MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING A FILE
ITEM NINETY AB NINE SIXTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE NINE SIXTY TWO BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHERS NOT REALLY THIS ALL THE
WAYS THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB NINE SIXTY
TWO IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE FROM
THE SENATE. THE BLL CLARIFIES
CAL CYCLES REGULATORY AUTHORITY
IN ADOPTING REGULATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL. IT ALSO
ROAD THE BILL ALSO REPLACES THE
TERM READ RETURNABLE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS WITH REUSABLE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER AND LIMITS
THE BILL'S APPLICATION TO CLASS
I REQUEST RISK. BACK FULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR COME LONGER. THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEN HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED USER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE THE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THEIR ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING A FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE AB ELEVEN THIRTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
LIVE IN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AND OTHERS NAPOLI
THE PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THE MAN SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I PRESENTED SOMEBODY
BILL LEVIN THIRTEEN WHICH IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE SIMPLY ADDRESS
CHAPTER NOW DISUSED THE BILL
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES IN THE
COMMITTEES AND IN THE SENATE. I
RESPECTFULLY YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MR MEDINA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS BOTH THIRTY
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED EITHER
TO GO. THE BEAUTIFUL SONG THAT
WAS PLAYING IN THE CHAMBERS ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE-
GLUCOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAHAM ACTUALLY
IN THE PARK PROPERTY MR GRAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER- AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX LET'S SEE MODESTO
TO ACQUIRE A REPLACEMENT
PROPERTY FOR A PART THAT THEY
ARE DISPOSING OF THE PROPERTY-
SENATE MEMBERSHIP RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
GRY SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN. LIEU TO FILE ITEM
NINETY FOUR AB FIFTEEN FORTY
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTEEN FORTY BY SOME
RIVETING ANOTHER SNAP IN THE
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE MISTER KING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THINK ABOUT
THE GRAVY FIFTY FOUR IS BACK ON
THE CURRENT SENTIMENTS FOR
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING CHANGES
ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS. ELIGIBLE
FOR RESENTENCING HAVE A REMOTE
HEARING SPECIFIED PORT
DEADLINES AND ADDRESSES
CHOPPING ISSUES. THE BILL
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
FOR JUDGES AND STRENGTHENS DUE
PROCESS WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR
RESTAURANT. THANK YOU MISTER
KING SINGING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
BOTH THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FORTY ONE NEWS NINETEEN THAT
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN. MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE THE
CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT ACTUALLY THE RIVER
CLASSIFICATION MISTER CAR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU HAVE
A SUPERVISORS AND EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE LIVER
COMMITTEE BUILT BACK IN THE
SENATE- IT'S BEEN ON CONSENT TO
THE ASSEMBLY HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
CLUB CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SAN AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY SIX
EIGHTY FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOR THE
CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN THE ECONOMY AND
ACTED IN THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
LEVERAGING STATE PROCUREMENT
FOR INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IS A
BILL AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TAKING ON THE
SENATE ALTER DEFINITIONS AND
MAKE OTHER. CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE
CONCERNS AND SEVEN AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MYSTERONS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER. DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. YOU DESERVE THE- HOME
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SAN AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY HAVE
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION AND ACKLINS
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION MISTER DONNA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FORTY
SIX IS THE ANNUAL EDUCATION
OMNIBUS BILL WHICH MAKES
TECHNICAL AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
REVISIONS TO THE EDUCATION
CODE. SENATE MEMBERS WERE COLOR
VYING NATURE AND RESOLVE
CHAPTER OUT ISSUES I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DONALD STAYING IN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF A.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO START OF
IT. OUR MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF
THE. WORK WILL LOSE THE ROLE
AND TALENTED I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN. IN THE FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK ENACTED A
HAZARDOUS WASTE AFTER BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO MY DESK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS.
AB SEVEN OH SEVEN. WILL REWRITE
THE PROGRAM FOR COLLECTING AND
RECYCLING MERCURY THERMOSTATS
THE ONE THING BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES AND
BUSINESS COULD AGREE ON WAS
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM WASN'T
WORKING. THAT THEY WERE GETTING
ALL THE THERMOSTATS BACK. AND
THAT IT NEED TO BE IMPROVED.
THEY INDUSTRY AGREED TO SPEND A
LOT MORE MONEY TO IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT CONCURRENT THE
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS MADE IN
THE SENATE. REQUIRE THERMOSTAT
MANUFACTURERS TO FULLY FUND DTS
SHE'S REGULATORY COSTS. REQUIRE
THERMOSTAT MANUFACTURERS TO
FULLY FUND ALL PROGRAM COSTS TO
COLLECT TRANSPORT AND RECYCLE
MERCURY THERMOSTATS REQUIRE
THERMOSTAT MANUFACTURERS
PROVIDE NO LESS THAN NINE POINT
ONE MILLION OVER THE SEVEN YEAR
PROGRAM FOR A ROBUST EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH PROGRAM. REQUIRE
THERMOSTAT MANUFACTURERS TO
CONTRACT WITH QUALIFIED THIRD
PARTY THAT MEET SPECIFIED
CRITERIA IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM
STATEWIDE REQUIRED DGSE TO
REVIEW AND APPROVE THE PLAN FOR
THE PROGRAM. REQUIRE THE
PROVISIONS OF A THIRTY DOLLAR
INCENTIVE TO CONSUMERS TO TURN
IN MERCURY THERMOSTATS FOR
RECYCLING. REQUIRE COLLECTION
LOCATIONS TO BE CONVENIENT AND
ACCESSIBLE STATE WHY INCLUDING
IN RURAL DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ANDREQUIRE
DGSE TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE EFFORT
EFFICACY OF THE PROGRAM BEFORE
IT SUNSETS IN TWENTY THIRTY.
AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK MY
STAFF WHO WORKED. HER ROAD
POLICE TO GET THIS AGREEMENT
BETWEEN INDUSTRY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION R. AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVISTS AND THE
INDUSTRY FOR COMING TOGETHER ON
THIS. THERE IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVE OF.
THANK YOU DR PERKS BEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED EITHER
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THIRD OF THE. OUR MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THE ARTICLE. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
LIEU TO FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE AB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME EMPLOYEES
SEVENTY TWO BY US AND WE WERE
WOOD MACKLIN IN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE FISCAL CONCERNS BY
THE ADMINISTRATION. THEY WILL
PROTECT CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
FROM A FINANCIAL STRAIN IF THEY
BECOME INJURED ON THE JOB I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIRD
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
ALREADY VOTED. OUR MEMBERS THE
MAJORITY VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN- TO
FILE ITEM WANTED TO AB TEN
NINETY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TO NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO
IMMIGRATION. THREE OF US YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TEN
NINETY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE INCORPORATE
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. FOR PURPOSES OF
IMPLEMENTATION. TO RESOLVE
CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES AND ADD
CO AUTHORS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED STRONG BY THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DAVIS SEEING HEARING I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WANT TO
COMPLIMENT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. FOR
MOVING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE OUT WHICH IS SO
ESSENTIAL TO RECOGNIZING THE
DIGNITY AND WORTH OF ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE LANGUAGE WE
USE IS DEEPLY IMPORTANT THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT CHANGE
AND I ENCOURAGE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE AYE ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL MYSTERY OF US YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
MADAM SPEAKER AND AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I'M I'M
PROUD TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION. WHICH IS- A
PRIORITY FOR CAUCUS YEAH I'M
GONNA THINK ARE CALLING FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR.
HER WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THE
TERM ALIEN IS. A D.
DEHUMANIZING TERM. IT'S A STORY
WE'VE BEEN USED. TO DID
DISCRIMINATE- AND DENIGRATE OUR
ARE UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S IT AND
IT'S A TERM THAT BELONGS
NOWHERE IN CALIFORNIA LAW. IT'S
ON BEHALF OF- THE LATINO UNLESS
THEY'VE CAUCUS RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MR S. NOW
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISS RIVAS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND FROM
HOLLISTER AND EVERYONE ELSE
THAT. WAS HELPFUL AND JOIN ME
IN GETTING THIS BILL THROUGH-
LIKE THEY SAID WORDS MATTER AND
IT'S TIME THAT CALIFORNIA GETS
RID OF THE WORD ALIEN WHEN
REFERRING TO NON CITIZENS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE THIRD OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH WHO
DESERTED THE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A. THE CLERK
WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FIFTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. HAVE TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE OH THREE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR AB
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM ACTUALLY THE HOUSING.
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL AB EIGHT. THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MY
LAST BILL IN YEAR ONE OF OUR
TWO YEAR SESSION THANK YOU
MISTER LAMB. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE THIRD OF A- LONG
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY
THREE NO SEVENTEEN SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE OF FIVE AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THE
CORPORATE RATE SYMBOL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS BATTLING WHO
MIGHT ACTUALLY. SEVENTEEN A YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX IS BACK ON BIRDS AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX AND CHAPTER
IN AMENDMENTS TO AVOID CONFLICT
WITH THE BUDGET TRAILER. ALSO
ADDED WAS CLEAN UP LANGUAGE AND
INTENT LANGUAGE TO SOLIDIFY.
THE COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH
OTHER UNIVERSITY PARTNERS AND
ENACTING THE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN HIS HAD NO NO VOTES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WE WILL NOW MOVE UP TO FILE
ITEM EACH. AB THREE TWENTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
THREE TWENTY BY CUSTOMER MEDINA
AND ACTUALLY THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING MISREADING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE TWENTY
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THREE
TWENTY WAS ON CONSENT
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND IS BACK IN THE
ASSEMBLY DUE TO DOUBLE JOINING
LANGUAGE AND CHAPTER IN
AMENDMENT I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA SINGING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BOTH. PAUL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD BOTH
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS.
RIGHT. MEMBERS. WITH THE TIME
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO OUR PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. IS JUST A BREAK IN OUR
REGULAR PROGRAMMING. THAT WE'RE
GONNA USE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
LOOK SO M. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PERMISSION
TO SPEAK AND I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION. MISTER DONNA. MISTER
DONNA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN MEMORIES. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO A JUROR
IN THE MEMORY OF A FORMER
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE BETTY
CARNAC A GREAT PERSON A GREAT
LADY. BUT HE WAS CERTAINLY A
GOOD PERSON A GOOD FRIEND AND
LOVED BY MANY AND THE
SEVENTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
ACTUALLY THE CAPITAL. CAPITAL
STAFF MANY OF THEM HAVE FOND
MEMORIES. OF BETTY CARNAC.
BETTY KERN AT PASSED AWAY
YESTERDAY IN LONG BEACH JUST
DAYS BEFORE HER NINETY EIGHTH
BIRTHDAY. SHE REPRESENTED HER
BELOVED LONG BEACH COMMUNITY IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THEIR EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES AND IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX SHE WAS
ELECTED TO THE STATE SENATE
WHERE SHE SERVED FOR EIGHT
YEARS. BANBURY RETURN TO THE
ASSEMBLY WHERE SHE SERVED
ANOTHER FOUR YEARS COMPLETING A
REMARKABLE PUBLIC SERVICE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. BETTY
WAS BORN AND PADUCAH KENTUCKY
AND IF YOU HEARD OR TALK YOU
PROBABLY KNEW SHE WAS FROM
KENTUCKY. IF YOU LOOK AT HER
VOTING RECORD YOU KNEW SHE WAS
A WORKING CLASS DEMOCRATS. THAT
CARED ABOUT PEOPLE. SHE AND HER
HUSBAND DICK SETTLED IN LONG
BEACH. AND BETTY AND I SHARED A
LOVE OF EDUCATION. MANY SPENT
HER CAREER TEACHING IN THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN SOUTH GATE.
MANY CURRENT AT CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT PEOPLE HER VALUES WERE
RIGHT ON POINT. SHE WAS ALWAYS
UP FOR A GOOD FIGHT A GOOD TIME
AND MAKE LONG BEACH AND
CALIFORNIA. A BETTER PLACE SHE
WAS FUN. I CANNOT SAY ENOUGH
ABOUT HOW MUCH I LEARNED FROM
BUDDY AND WHAT AN HONOR IT IS
TO REPRESENT OUR BELOVED
COMMUNITIES. BETTY NEVER REALLY
STOP SERVING OUR DISTRICT. IN
FACT SHE WOULD REGULARLY CHECK
IN WITH MY STAFF TO WEIGH IN ON
VARIOUS EDUCATIONAL ISSUES.
YOU'RE ALWAYS TELL ANYONE WHO
ANSWERED THE PHONE HOW
IMPORTANT THEY WERE. THEY WERE
HOW IMPORTANT THEY WERE TO
PROVIDING GOOD PUBLIC SERVICE
SHAVUOT CALL AND TALK TO THE
STAFF MEMBERS BETTY WAS ABOVE
NOBODY. SHE WAS JUST A GREAT
PERSON. SHE LED AND LEAVES A
LEGACY. SHE WILL BE MISSED AND
WARMLY REMEMBERED BY COUNTLESS
FRIENDS IN THIS BUILDING AND
HER ADOPTED HOMETOWN OF LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA. MADAM SPEAKER
I ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
SENATOR. BETTY CARNAC. THANK
YOU MISTER DONNA MR MAYS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THINK ABOUT A SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN OF THE MEMORY.
OF DARREN BOUGHTON. DARREN WAS
A FRIEND- TO SO MANY OF US IN
THE ROOM. AND FOR THOSE OF US
WORKING IN ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENT SPACE WE KNEW HIM
AS- A RESPECTED SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT. GRADUATING **** LAUDE
IN ECONOMICS FROM SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY DARREN WENT ON TO
ATTAIN HIS MASTER'S DEGREE IN
ENERGY. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY FROM UNIVERSITY OF
DELAWARE. LATER APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
TO SERVE AS DEPUTY CABINET
SECRETARY. DAN WAS INVOLVED IN
A MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCES POLICY
DEBATES. ON A PERSONAL LEVEL
DARREN'S REPUTATION AS A
RESPECTED AND THOUGHTFUL LEADER
CREATED LONG LASTING
FRIENDSHIPS INSIDE THE BUILDING
AND OUTSIDE AS WELL. DARREN'S
GREATEST JOY WAS SPENDING TIME
WITH HIS FAMILY. HIS WIFE OF
TEN YEARS SARAH. AND TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN JAKE EIGHT YEARS OLD
AND LILY SEVEN. I WAS JUST A
TELLING SOME FOLKS A FEW WEEKS
AGO ONE OF MY GREATEST JOYS
BEING HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
IS NOT NECESSARY ON THE POLICY
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE BUT THE
PEOPLE- THE HUNDRED TWENTY
CALLED COLLEAGUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SERVE WITH PAST.
AND PRESENT. JUST THE PERSON
THAT YOU MEET AND IN THE LOBBY
FOR JUST A FEW SECONDS AND
THOSE OTHER FOLKS THAT WERE
ABLE TO MEET TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH. THAT WORD WITH. IS SORT
OF INTERESTING RIGHT BECAUSE
WHEN YOU SPEND TIME WITH.
SOMEONE IT BUILDS BONDS IT
BUILDS. A TRUST. AND IT BUILDS.
LASTING FRIENDSHIPS. AND WHEN
SOMEBODY PASSES THE SORROW
COMES. WHEN WE REALIZE. THAT WE
CAN'T SPEND THAT TIME WITH THAT
PERSON. ANY LONGER. THE FOR ME
I'M GONNA MISS IT DOWN I KNOW
THAT SO MANY OF US THAT ARE
HERE ARE GOING TO MISS HIM AS
WELL BECAUSE WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO SPEND TIME WITH HIM BUT WE
ARE CERTAINLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THAT THE LIFE THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SHARE. WITH HIM.
MEDICITY GRASS THE WEED DURING
HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES MISTER FLOOR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I TO RISE- TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF OUR DEAR FRIEND THERE AND-
FOR A LOT OF US- POLITICS WAS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO WHO WAS
IN THE CAREER PATH THAT WE HAD.
BUT I WAS A FRIEND OF A FORMER
SENATOR AND I WAS JUST KIND OF
BODY THAT ALWAYS HUNG AROUND
AND I GOT TO KNOW DARREN. AND
HIS LOVELY WIFE SIR- PRIOR TO
BEING ELECTED. AND THAT
RELATIONSHIP ONLY GREW. AND
THERE ARE VERY FEW PEOPLE IN
THIS INDUSTRY. THERE WERE MORE
SINCERE MORE PASSIONATE ABOUT
WHATEVER THEY WERE DOING THE
DARREN DALTON WAS. AS A FRIEND
I THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT THEIR
AND THE PASSION THAT HE HAD FOR
LIFE. I JUST I ADMIRE HIM.
THERE'S A TV SHOW THAT A LOT OF
US HAVE PROBABLY WATCH THAT
TALKS ABOUT. BEING A GOLDFISH
GOLDFISH HAVE REALLY SHORT
MEMORIES. LAST YEAR'S BEEN
REALLY HARD ON THE BALLOT
FAMILY. BUT THROUGH EVERYTHING
THAT WAS GOING ON DARREN WAS A
GOLDFISH HE HAD A REALLY SHORT
MEMBER HE GET BAD NEWS AND YOU
FORGET ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE HAD
PASSION FOR LIFE. HE FOUGHT
HARD. WE'RE GOING MISTER BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING MISSING NEARLY
AS BAD. AS HIS WIFE. AND HIS
TWO KIDS. AND IS CANCERS TAKEN
ANOTHER FRIEND FROM US. I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE SURVIVORS FOR
JUST A SECOND BECAUSE THERE ARE
TWO THREE SURVIVORS AND THAT
FAMILY NOW. THAT ARE NOT GOING
TO SURVIVE THE FUTURE WITHOUT
THEIR FATHER. AND WITHOUT THEIR
HUSBAND AND THAT BREAKS MY
HEART. THE FRIENDS I ASKED WE
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF OUR DEAR
FRIEND. THEY'RE INVOLVED. THANK
YOU MR FOR A. CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS. FORMER CITY OF IRVINE
MAYOR AND A COUNCIL MEMBER OF
BEETLE A DELICIOUS- DEDICATED A
MUCH OVER USED TO LIVE THE
PUBLIC SERVICE IN IRVINE AND
ORANGE COUNTY PASSED AWAY. LAST
SEPTEMBER FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. BILL BY DOING THIS
SERVED ON IRVINE CITY COUNCIL
FROM. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND THEN
THE FROM. NINETEEN NINETY TO
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND- AS SO
IRVINE MAYOR FROM. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. HE ALSO SERVED ON
THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. THE
ORANGE COUNTY LAND DO YOU IS SO
COMMISSION AND THE DIRECTOR OF
D. R. TONY'S SANITATION
DISTRICTS SO OF WHAT ORANGE
COUNTY. IN ADDITION HE HELD THE
MANY LEADERSHIP ROLES SO IN THE
COMMUNITY INCLUDING PRESIDENT
OF THE- IRVINE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. HE HAS A VERY LONG
HISTORY IS SERVING OUR GREAT
TONY. MUCH OVER HIS ALIVE FOR
SO FOCUSED ON TRANSPORTATION.
AS OF PUBLIC LATER AND AS WELL
AS A AS AN ARTIST AND ENGINEER
ALSO AS HE ACTIVELY- PROMOTED
THE VISION OR THE PLANS SO FULL
PULL ROADS AND- ACTIVELY
PURSUED THE NEW WAYS OF
IMPROVING TRAFFIC IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AREAS SO. WHEN MY PERSONAL TO
HE ALSO SUCH ON NUYS SO FRIEND
AND- ALUMNUS ALL OF WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PITTSBURGH MY
AMADA AND- HE ACCOMPANIED ME
NOT TO THE UNIVERSITY L. WHEN I
RECEIVED THE ALUMNI
RECOGNITION- FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF PITTSBURGH. BILL
LEVEL IS SAYS SO SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE OF THEIR BROUGH
DUELISTS- HE WAS A STRONG
LEADER IN OUR COMMUNITY AND THE
OR DO YOU MISTER BY- SO MANY
FRIENDS AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I ASKED ABOUT THAT WE ARE JOHN-
THIS ASSEMBLY SESSION IN HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR TRY. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
WHO ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE CITY-
MINIMUM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ADMINISTRATOR AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE TO CHURN IN
THE MEMORY OF FORMER CITY OF
IRVINE MAYOR AND COUNCILMEMBER
BELL PARCELAS. BELL WAS A
LIFELONG PUBLIC SERVANTS AND HE
SERVED OUR ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS HE WAS THE MAYOR OF IRVINE
IN THE LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
HE ALSO HELD THE POST OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE IRVINE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. DIRECTOR AT THE
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND SERVED ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY AIRPORT LAND USE
COMMISSION AND TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TRAINED AS AN
ENGINEER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PITTSBURGH WAS PARTICULARLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT IMPROVING
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN ORANGE COUNTY. BILL
RITUALIST HAS RECEIVED NUMEROUS
AWARDS FOR HIS SERVICE MOST
NOTABLE THE IRVINE CITIZEN OF
THE YEAR PRESENTED BY THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE
VISIONARY AWARD PRESENTED BY
THE TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCY FIRST TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING. I
ALONG WITH ALL OF MY ORANGE
COUNTY COLLEAGUES REALLY ARE
GRATEFUL FOR HIS YEARS OF
SERVICE AND FOR HIS DEDICATION
TO ORANGE COUNTY I COLLEAGUES I
ASK THAT TODAY WE ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK U.
S. BETWEEN OUR S. MISTER JONES
SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM. SPOKESMAN SPEAKER. TODAY
I RISE IN TO ADJOURN ON BEHALF
OF THE U. S. C. FAMILY TO HONOR
OUR IN MEMORY OF OUR FELLOW
TROJAN SAMUEL LEWIS CUNNINGHAM
JUNIOR ALSO KNOWN AS SAM BAM
CUNNINGHAM WHOSE PERFORMANCE IN
USC'S NINETEEN SEVENTY WIN OVER
ALABAMA PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE IN
INTEGRATING FOOTBALL PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE SOUTH. BAM
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF HIS BRUISING
GOLDLINE DIVES BROUGH CAME HIS
NICKNAME AS LYNN SWANN ONCE
SAID NO ONE COULD STOP HIM.
BORN ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY IN SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA GO SANTA BARBARA SAM
STARTED OUT AS A STAR ATHLETE
AS SANTA BARBARA HIGH SCHOOL HE
WOULD LATER BREAK INTO THE
STARTING LINEUP AT USC IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY AS A
SOPHOMORE. AT A TIME WHEN
COLLEGE FOOTBALL CONTINUE TO
CLING ON TO SEGREGATION AND THE
EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES SAM
COMING CUNNINGHAM PAVE THE WAY
FOR YOUNG BLACK MEN FOR YEARS
TO COME. THAT LEGENDARY FIRST
GAME AGAINST AN ALL WHITE
ALABAMA UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA
TEAM WAS ONLY THE START OF A
LONG FRUITFUL CAREER IN FACT S.
C. ONE FORTY TWO TO TWENTY ONE.
AS ONE OF BRIAN'S ASSISTANT
COACHES ONCE SAID. SAM
CUNNINGHAM DID MORE TO
INTEGRATE ALABAMA IN SIXTIES
SIXTY MINUTES THEN M. OKAY DID
IN TWENTY YEARS. IF ALL IF. SAM
WOULD GO ON TO EARN ALL
AMERICAN HONORS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AS A NINETY SEVENTY TWO
AS A FULL BACK IN THE GREAT
TRADITION OF USC RUNNING BACKS.
WHEN HE CAPTAINED THE TROJANS
TO A NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP. AND
AN UNDEFEATED SEASON. IF ALL
ALL AMERICAN IF ALL AMERICAN.
AND A MAJOR CHAMPIONSHIP RUN
ENOUGH IN THAT SAME YEAR SAM
EARNED MVP HONORS AT THE AT THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE ROSE
BOWL WHEN HE LED USC WITH FOUR
TOUCHDOWNS. ALL OF THEM WITH
HIS TRADEMARK GOAL LINE DIVES.
AS HE WON A GAME OVER. OHIO
STATE FORTY TWO TO SEVENTEEN.
UPON GRADUATION FROM USC SAM
WAS SELECTED NUMBER ELEVEN
OVERALL IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE NFL
DRAFT BY THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS. HE WOULD PLAY. NINE
SEASONS IN THE NFL MAKING THE
ALL PRO TEAM IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AND LATER RETIRED
AS A FRANCHISE ALL TIME LEADING
RUSHER A DISTINCTION HE STILL
HOLDS TO THIS DAY. A U. S. C.
IN FOOTBALL GREAT SAM WOULD
LATER BE INDUCTED INTO THE ROSE
BOWL HALL OF FAME. THE USC
ATHLETICS HALL OF FAME THE
COLLEGE FOOTBALL HALL OF FAME
THE NEW WILLIAM PATRIOTS HALL
OF FAME. BEYOND HIS OUTSTANDING
FOOTBALL CAREER SAM WAS FIRST.
AND FOREMOST AS ANYONE WILL
TELL YOU A GREAT GUY. HE WILL
ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED FOR BEING
UNSOCIABLE. AND EVEN WITH ALL
THOSE HONORS HE WAS EXTREMELY
HUMBLE AND HONEST. IF ANY OF
THE TEAMMATES WOULD TELL YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY SAN PASSED AWAY
ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN INGLEWOOD. HE IS
SURVIVED BY TWO MEMBERS OF THE
SACRAMENTO FAMILY OF THIS
INSTITUTION HIS WIFE SEEN
IVORY. WHO WRAPPED UP HER
EIGHTEEN YEAR LONG CAREER IN
THE LEGISLATURE AT THE CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR THE HONORABLE SENATOR
RODRICK RIGHT. HIS DAUGHTER.
SHE MANDI WHO WHO RECENTLY
ROUNDED OFF HER TENURE LONG
CAREER WITH THE LEGISLATURE AT
THE DISTRICT'S DAPPER IN THE
SIXTY SECOND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
HISTORY BROTHERS ATHLETE BRUCE
AND RANDALL AND A HOST OF
FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS. SAM
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED LEAVING
BEHIND A LEGACY THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO LIVE ON IN IN IN
THE CHANGE HE AND HIS TEAMMATES
STARTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY.
DURING THAT FATEFUL GAME AND
ALABAMA. BEN SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST WITH
GERMAN IN HONOR. OF SAM BAM
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER
TRANSFORMS BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
AMERICAN THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE- IN ASKING THAT WE
TURN TO THE IN THE MEMORY OF
THE LEGENDARY USC FOOTBALL
PLAYER SAM BAM CUNNINGHAM. AS
MENTIONED BEFORE MISTER
CUNNINGHAM IS OFTEN CREDITED
WITH HELPING INTEGRATE SOUTHERN
COLLEGE FOOTBALL WITH HIS
PERFORMANCE AGAINST ALABAMA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY HE WAS JUST AS
FALL SOPHOMORE. WHEN USC TOOK
THE ALL WHITE ALABAMA TEAM ON
THE ROAD THE GAME MARKED A
TURNING POINT IN THE
INTEGRATION OF SOUTHERN COLLEGE
FOOTBALL. MARTIN LUTHER KING
ONCE SAID OUR LIVES BEGIN TO
END THE DAY WE BECOME SILENT
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT MATTER.
AND COLLEAGUES IF YOU ASK
ANYONE WHO KNEW MR CUNNINGHAM
THEY WOULD TELL YOU HE WOULD BE
THE FIRST TO STAND UP AND SPEAK
OUT ABOUT THE THINGS HE CARED
ABOUT. MISTER SAM BAM
CUNNINGHAM WAS A BELOVED FATHER
COMMUNITY LEADER AND HUSBAND
WHO WAS ACTIVE IN GIVING BACK
TO HIS COMMUNITY THROUGH THE
CHAMBER. AND COMMUNITY EVENTS
IN THE CITY OF GARDENA AND
INGLEWOOD. HE WAS SOMEONE WHO I
HAD THE HONOR OF MEETING SINCE
HE WAS THE FATHER OF SAMADHI
CUNNINGHAM A FORMER MEMBER OF
TEAM BURKE. SHE WAS WITH US FOR
ALMOST SEVEN YEARS. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE SEEN. SOME MONDAY AS WELL
AS HER BROTHERS RANDALL BRUCE
IN ANTHONY. MISTER SAM BAM
CUNNINGHAM WAS A PROUD RESIDENT
OF THE SIXTY SECOND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND I'M IT MAY I SAY
WAS EQUALLY PRUD TO REPRESENT
HIM HERE IN SACRAMENTO. OUR
COMMUNITY AND CITY WILL SORELY
MISS HIM FOR MANY MANY YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED AND-
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAME SUGGESTS WE
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS. TO JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
IT SHOULD BE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER I
MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN WOOD DURING THE
DINNER BREAK THIS EVENING IN
ROOM. FOUR THIRTY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. AB SEVENTY FOUR WAS
HEARD BY THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYS COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY
AND IS NOW AT THE DESK. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ TO TAKE
UP THE BILL TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. WITH OUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS I HAVE SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR YOU ALL I
THINK YOU'RE PAYING MORE
ATTENTION AT THIS MOMENT THEN
YOU HAVE ALL DAY- WE WILL TAKE
A BREAK AND TELL FIVE THIRTY
THE ONE HOUR. DINNER WILL BE
SERVED AT FIVE O'CLOCK.
REPUBLICAN DINNER WILL BE
SERVED IN THE WAY BROWN ROOM
DEMOCRATIC DINNERS WILL BE
SERVED IN THE MEMBER LOUNGE
AGAIN THEY WILL BE BOX TO TAKE
BACK TO YOUR INDIVIDUAL
OFFICES. BUT THOSE MEMBERS WHO
SIT ON THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE
PRIVACY WILL BEGIN BEATING
RIGHT NOW. IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY. MEMBER THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE PLEASE GO TO
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AND I WILL
SEE THE REST OF YOU BACK HERE.
FED AT.
FIVE THIRTY. MEMBERS
ARE RECESSED IS CONCLUDED AT
FIVE THIRTY I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE FIVE MEMBERS. WELL SIX IF
YOU INCLUDE ME BETTER HERE
PROMPTLY AT.
FIVE THIRTY.
MEMBERS YOU CAN BE LUCKY NUMBER
THIRTEEN IF YOU JOIN US ON THE
FLOOR RIGHT NOW. ALL.
THIS
RUBIO FOR WHAT PURPOSE THE RISE.
SEND UP OF MAY MAKE A
SUGGESTION THAT THOSE OF US
THAT ARE ALREADY HERE WE CAN
START HEARING OUR BILLS FIRST.
I MAKE A MOTION THAT WE HEAR
THE BILL THAT OF THE MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT. I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT IS THE PROPER MOTION
BECAUSE I'M NOT EVEN SURE MAYES
RUBIO. LET ME KICK CAN WE WILL
OFFER YOU A BILL FROM THE FILE
CAN WE CHECK WITH THE- CLERK.
NOTE IT MAY TAKE A BIT CHIEF
CLERK TO SEE. YOUR MOTION IS
OUT OF ORDER- I WAS IMPROPERLY
MADE ACCORDING TO OUR- CHIEF.
FOR YOU PLEASE MR AREA.
WE CAN
ENTERTAIN VIRGINIA THIS TIME.
IS THE DESK READY. IF THEY'RE
WE WILL WAIT ON THE DESK. OKAY
VERY GOOD MISTER BIGELOW FOR A
CHANGE THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER-
FILE ONE FIVE EIGHT SB ONE SIX
TWO I DUNNO. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGULAR- SENATE
BILL ONE SIXTY TWO I TO KNOW.
MISS BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR VOTE CHANGE FILE NUMBER
NINETEEN AB TEN THIRTY THREE. I
TO ABSTAIN. I TAT NOT VOTING
AND VOTE CHANGE MONTH AMAZON TO
ONE OF THE TIME INSERTED OKAY
CHANGES ON THE RIVER BONTA.
SOME PEOPLE TEN THIRTY THREE I
TO NOT VOTING. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERBONTA FILE
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE AB THREE
THIRTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING.
BURKE CHANGE BONTA ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY FIVE- TO NOT
VOTING. MR DAILY FOR A CHANGE
THANK YOU YES MY VOTE CHANGES
ITEM NINETY FOUR. AB FIFTEEN
FORTY BY MR TANG CHANGE FROM
YES TO NOT VOTING. CAN YOU
REPEAT THE BILL NUMBER MISTER
DALY. AB. ONE FIVE FOUR ZERO.
FROM CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN FORTY-
TO NOT VOTING. THANK YOU. THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY PROVIDE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
OUR PHONE NUMBER FIFTY A FIFTY
FIVE ZERO BILL ONE THREE FOUR
SIX BERMAN FROM I CANNOT VOTING.
BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY SOME LEGAL
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX I TO NOT
VOTING.
MISTER GRAYSON PREVENT
CHANGE YES GRAYSON. AB SEVEN
ZERO ONE FROM I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON A SINGLE SEVEN A ONE-
TO NOT VOTING. THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
MEMBERS WHO JOINED US ON THE
FLOOR TO RE COMMENCE BUSINESS.
YOUR PROMPTNESS IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED BY THE HOUSE.
MEMBERS MISTER COOPER IS
PREPARED TO TAKE UP HIS
CONCURRENCE ITEM AND YOU'RE ALL
HERE TO HEAR HIS PRESENTATION
SO THANK YOU. FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIX AB THREE FIFTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
THREE FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AND
OTHERS MAC LEVINE HEALING ARTS
THE CLEARING YEARS EITHER
AFFECT THE COMMUNITY MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB
THREE FIVE NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IT WILL INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF INDIES PRACTICING
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL ALSO SPENT
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
CURRICULUM TO ENSURE THAT
PHYSICIANS ARE EDUCATED ABOUT
THE LATEST MEDICAL PRACTICE
TECHNIQUES. THERE OVER TWENTY
TWO MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING
THE BILL THE MEDICAL BOARD IS
REMOVED APPOSITION AND THERE
ARE NO. AND NOCTURNAL. ON THE
BILL. THERE'S BEEN NO NO VOTES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER. THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE ANY MORE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON YOUR ITEM. SO THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO START OF
THE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE
A. MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE BOTH
HIS FIRST. FIFTY FOUR. THIS IS.
FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
VOTE. AND TO BE CLEAR FOR
MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT YET ON THE
FLOOR. WE CAN NOW SEE THAT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A STRESS.
FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE
THIS IS FIFTY FOUR AND WE ARE
AT FIFTY ONE.
WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY BUT I FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS NOW THE
WAY MORE PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR IF
YOU HAVE A VOTE CHANGE WE CAN
ENTERTAIN THOSE AT. THIS TIME
YOU CAN RAISE YOUR MIKE.
HEY
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. TO SUSPEND THE RULES
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ATTAINED. TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET RELATED BILLS
FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. AB ONE SIX THREE.
AB ONE SIX SEVEN. AB ONE SEVEN
TWO AB ONE SEVEN THREE. AB ONE
SEVEN FOUR. AB ONE SEVEN FIVE
AB ONE SEVEN SIX AND FINALLY AB
ONE SEVEN SEVEN. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR THE MISTER SPEAKER
WE REJECTED I WOULD HOLD
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AS A ROLL
CALL VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING. MISTER AND SHALL
LOOSE. AND MR TANG SECONDS. ALL
THE ROLE SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
CARCLUB THE ROLE MR CHALLENGE
ASKING FOR IT HI VOTE AND MR
FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MISTER CHOW IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND MR FLOORS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. TAKES. FORTY
ONE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIED UP I FORTY THREE KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED MISTER CHOW YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE SEND
THE ACTION WAR BY ON SEPTEMBER
ONE SB FIVE ALL FOUR BECKER WAS
READ AT THIRD TIME AND PASSED
TO THE SENATE AND FURTHER ADDS
TO THE BILL BE REMOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BASE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TWO S. B. TWO SIX TWO
HERTZBERG. TO THE INACTIVE FILE
AND AT THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ITEM ONE FIVE NINE S. B.
ONE SIX THREE ITEM ONE SIX TWO
SB ONE SIX SEVEN AND FINALLY
ITEM ONE SIX SEVEN S. B. ONE
SEVEN TWO. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT REQUEST IS GRANTED.
FINALLY MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY TO
TAKE UP A B. FOURTEEN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CUP CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
REQUEST IS GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING UP A
NUMBER OF BUDGET ITEMS FOR
CONCURRENCE. THESE ARE BUDGET
ITEMS. FOUR CONCURRENCE. WE ARE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH. AB. ONE
SIXTY THREE. WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE THIS IS AB ONE SIXTY
THREE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SIXTY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET NATURALLY INTO STATE
GOVERNMENT MAKING A PROVISION
OR FORTY TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TO RELATE TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER TECH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE SIXTY
THREE OF OUR GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL THE BILL ENSURES
THAT ARE ANTI API HE PACKAGE.
PRIORITIZE A SERVICEMAN'S
FUNDING TO VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS IN VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WITH HIGH.
RECRUITING LEVELS OF HATE
INCIDENTS THE FOCUS OF THE
GRANT ON VICTIMS OF CRIMES HAVE
HISTORICALLY FACED BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING. APPROPRIATE CARE AND
SERVICES. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE SIX THREE. MR FONG. I
THINK IT WAS A SPEAKER THIS
BILL PROVIDES LICENSE FEE
REFUNDS AND SUPPORTS COURT
REPORTERS AND I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT TODAY. I URGE TO VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. MARKWELL CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE OF I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
THIS IS AB. ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
BURGLARY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SIXTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET MACALIN EDUCATION
FINANCE MAKING APPROPRIATION OF
FORCE TAKE AFFECT IMMEDIATELY
RELATE TO THE BUDGET MISTER
TECH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB ONE SIX SEVEN IS R. T. K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL AS STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND STAFF ALL RETURN
TO OPEN CLASSROOMS ACROSS OUR
STATE THIS BILL IS A CLEAN UP
BILL THE BILL EXTENDS THE
AMOUNT OF TIME SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS CONSERVING THE SAME
ASSIGNMENT TO SIXTY DAYS FOR
THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR IT ALSO
EXTENDS DEADLINES FOR COVERT
RELATED PEOPLE GREAT CHANGES TO
OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TO ALLOW STUDENTS IN
QUARANTINE TO BE AN INDEPENDENT
STUDY THE BILL REQUIRES SCHOOLS
TO PROVIDE INDEPENDENT STUDY IN
ORDER TO CLAIM FUNDING FOR
COVERT RELATED TO TENANTS LOSS
OR CLOSURES NOW STUDENTS IN
QUARANTINE TO BE IMMEDIATELY
ADMITTED INTO INDEPENDENT STUDY
ALLOWS THAT FUNDING TO START ON
DAY ONE SB ONE SIX SEVEN
AUTHORIZES MODEL CURRICULA
DEVELOPMENT SHIFTED BY MANY OF
THIS CHAMBER THROUGH. THE
CALIFORNIA STORE HISTORY SOCIAL
SCIENCE PROJECT FOR AMONG
HISTORY AND CULTURAL STUDIES
THE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE IN NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDIES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE. VOTE
ON AB ONE SIX SEVEN. MR FONG
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS PANDEMIC HAS HAD A
HORRIBLE IMPACT ON STUDENTS
FROM LEARNING LOST TO THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH GUARDRAILS THAT
WERE PLACED ON INDEPENDENT
STUDY EARLIER THIS SUMMER. NEED
MORE FLEXIBILITY AND THIS BILL
WILL HELP GET FUNDING TO
SCHOOLS FOR STUDENTS AND
INDEPENDENT STUDY WE HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE CONTINUITY IN
INSTRUCTION SO STUDENTS DON'T
FALL EVEN FURTHER BEHIND.
SCHOOLS TO CONTINUE TO GET
THEIR NEEDED APPORTIONMENT BY
EXTENDING SUBSTITUTE
INSTRUCTION CLASSIFYING COURSE
BASED INDEPENDENT STUDY AS
SAYING CORNEAS INSTRUCTION AND
DIRECTING A PORTION OF BACK TO
DISTRICTS WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT FLEXIBILITIES IN
SCHOOLS. AS YOU PREPARE FOR THE
REST OF THE SCHOOL YEAR I URGE
AND ABOUT. THANK YOU MR FONG
MISSED WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX SEVEN.
AB ONE SIX SEVEN INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR MODEL CURRICULUM
FOR MANY COMMUNITIES. I WANT TO
START BY EXPRESSING MY
GRATITUDE AND APPRECIATION. TO
THE SPEAKER HIS STAFF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LONG BEACH SAN
JOSE AND HIGHLAND AND THEIR
STAFF IT HAS BEEN A LONG AND
EXHAUSTING JOURNEY THIS YEAR TO
TRY TO GET THIS RIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL AT ODD
HOURS M. AND ALSO HAVE YOUR
STAFF WORK DAYS IN. AND OUT ON
THIS BILL. AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
IS A CONTINUOUS JOURNEY OF S.
B. EIGHT NINE FIVE. I STARTED
THIS JOURNEY TO ADOPT A MODEL
CURRICULUM ON THE SOUTHEAST
ASIAN AMERICAN REFUGEES
EXPERIENCE. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN I WAS IN
THE SENATE. WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN JOSE AS A JOINT
AUTHORS. SB. EIGHT NINE FIVE.
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR
BOTH HOUSES. IT ALSO REQUIRE
THE DEVELOPMENT A MODEL
CURRICULUM RELATIVE TO THE
REFUGEE EXPERIENCE SPECIFICALLY
STORIES OF ENEMIES AMERICAN
REFUGEES BELIEVE ME AS BOTH
PEOPLE AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM ARMED
FORCES IF. WAS IT FURTHER ADDED
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE WIDER
COLLECTION OF OTHER SOUTHEAST
ASIAN REFUGEE STORIES TO
INCLUDE MODEL CURRICULUMS FOR
THE STORIES OF THE KUBOTA
GENOCIDE AND THE MONTH IN
HISTORY AND CULTURAL STUDIES.
AS I CONTINUE ON WITH MY
COMMENTS I WAS SPECIFIC FOCUS
ON THE MODEL CURRICULUM FOR THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEES
EXPERIENCE SAYS IS THIS
SPECIFICALLY FOR MY DISTRICT.
MY HOME IN ORANGE COUNTY HAS
THE LARGEST VENOMOUS AMERICAN
COMMUNITY UNITED STATES. AND
CALIFORNIA IS NOW HOME TO OVER
ONE MILLION SOUTHEAST ASIAN
AMERICANS. IT ALSO HAS THE
LARGEST CONCENTRATED AREA
VIETNAMESE RESIDENTS OUTSIDE
VIETNAM. WE WANTED OUR CHILDREN
TO LEARN OUR STORIES. AND TO
LEARN HOW WE CAME HERE. FOR
FREEDOM. DURING THAT TIME MANY
COMMUNITY GROUPS FOR MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE STATE
CALIFORNIA CAME TOGETHER IN
SUPPORT OF CREATING THIS
CURRICULUM. MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE TRAVEL TO
SACRAMENTO TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT NINE FIVE
DOING THOSE VARIOUS COMMUNITY
HEARINGS IN MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND PETITIONS WERE SIGNED.
AND WERE SUBMITTED MOST OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS. WHO TRAVEL
TO THE CAPITAL HAVE NEVER BEEN
TO THE CAPITAL YET ALONE
SACRAMENTO SOME DROVE OVER TEN
HOURS JUST TO GET HERE. AB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN WILL FINISH WHAT WE
STARTED BY GIVING THE STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS ACCESS TO LEARNING.
AND EDUCATION MATERIALS CREATED
FOR THE STUDENTS TO LEARN THESE
HISTORIES. THIS CURRICULUM WILL
TEACH OUR CHILDREN THE STORIES
OF REFUGEES WHO FACE
OVERWHELMINGLY ODDS TO REGAIN
THEIR FREEDOM BY ESCAPING THE
CALMNESS REGENE LESSONS THAT
NEED TO BE TAUGHT IN OUR
SCHOOLS ENOUGH A GUN. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
INCREASE ASIAN AMERICAN
VISIBILITY AND CULTURE
AWARENESS IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES IT IS IMPORTANT NOW
MORE THAN EVER THAT OUSTER
STUDENTS LEARN THESE HISTORIES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB. ONE SIX SEVEN.
MISTER RAMOS WHO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I WANNA
THANK OF THE CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND- MY
COLLEAGUES WERE ALSO INCLUDED.
INTO THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME-
MONEY THAT WAS START TO BUILD A
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM AND
WORKING WITH EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. THERE SO MANY STUDENTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT STILL HAVE NOT SEEN A
TRADITIONAL SONG OF CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE UP. HERE WE'VE BEEN
HONORED AND BLESSED TO BE ABLE
TO SING TRADITIONAL SONGS TO
OPEN UP HERE IN THESE CHAMBERS
BUT YET THERE'S STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT THIS TO
HAVE NOT SEEN. THE FACTUAL
SIGHTS AND SOUNDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. OF
THIS BUDGET AND THE MONEY
THAT'S INCLUDED IN IT WILL BE
THE FIRST STEP IN MAKING SURE
THAT TRUE CURRICULUM
IDENTIFYING CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
IN THE AREA THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RICH CULTURE. HISTORY SUCH AS
THE SONGS WE SHARED IN THE
HISTORY AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR LOCAL AREA. THIS STARTS
TO MOVE THAT FORWARD- IN TAKING
A BIG FIRST STEP WANT TO THANK
THIS BODY I WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE I AND THOSE ARE TO
WORK HARD AND MY COLLEAGUES.
THAT SHOWS THE TRUE DIVERSITY
OFTHE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE NEED FOR FACTUAL EDUCATION
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS ROMMEL'S. MISCONDUCT
LESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU AND I WANT TO THINK- ARE
BUDGET CHAIR WHEN WE PASSED AB
ONE OH FOUR EARLIER THIS YEAR
WHICH ALLOWS STUDENTS TO
CONVERT GRADES THAT THEY
RECEIVED LAST YEAR TO PASS NO
PASS WE REALIZE A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- PUT A VERY TIGHT
TIME LINE ON THAT AND IN FACT
WAS DURING SUMMER WHEN KIDS
WERE IN SCHOOL AND THEY GAVE
HIM TWO WEEKS AND ALTHOUGH
THOUSANDS OF KIDS UTILIZE THAT
OPTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THERE ARE MANY MORE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO AND RAN OUT OF TIME
THIS BILL EXTENDS THAT DEADLINE
TO OCTOBER FIRST SAID THAT
THOSE STUDENTS WHO WEREN'T ABLE
TO PETITION TO CHANGE THEIR
GRADES TO PASS NO PASS STILL
CAN DO THAT THOSE WHO ARE JUST
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL SO THANK
YOU TO THE BUDGET CHAIR- FOR
PROVIDING THAT IN THIS THIS
EXTENSION IN THIS BILL AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
REALLY INFORM OUR STUDENTS THAT
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
BACK AND I. ENSURE THAT THEIR
GRADE POINT AVERAGE INDICATES
THE TYPE OF STUDENTS THAT THEY
REALLY ARE DESPITE THE PANDEMIC
I WOULD ASK FOR AN IBM. THANK
MISS GONZALEZ I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. MISTER CHANG YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH CORPORAL
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE AB. ONE SEVENTY TWO.
CORKERY SUMMIT ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVENTY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET MACALIN
HUMAN SERVICES MAKING
APPROPRIATION OR FORTY TAKE
AFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELAYED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER TECH.
THEY MIGHT SPEAKER AB ONE SEVEN
TWO IS OUR HUMAN SERVICES
TRAILER BILL THE BILL AMENDS
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
TO REFLECT VERY CLEAN UP IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES BILL STEP
WHICH IS THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM WHICH WILL
STABILIZE AND EXPAND THE ADULT.
RESIDENTIAL SENIOR CARE HOUSING
CAPACITY IN OUR STATE. CREATES
THE IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT JOB TRAINING AND-
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR CARE
PROVIDERS. AND FINALLY THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE ON AB ONE SEVEN TWO. A
MISTAKE MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THE COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM INCLUDED
IN THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
NEEDED SERVICES AND EXPANSIONS
AT RESIDENTIAL ADULT AND SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES TO HELP OFFER
QUALITY ASSISTANCE TO OUR
ELDERLY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
AS A SOCIETY TAKE CARE OF OUR
SENIORS. I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANKS FONG SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM FOR CLUB OF THE WORLD.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER
ALL TIED UP I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE THIS IS AB. ONE SEVENTY
THREE. QUACKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVENTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET BACK WITHIN
THE PUBLIC SAFETY MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY RELATE TO
THE BUDGET. MISTER TECH THANK
YOU AB ONE SEVEN THREES ARE
PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL
CLARIFIES THE PROCESS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER AT UC DAVIS- IN
ADDITION THE BILL INCLUDES
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IT
EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS. THE
IDENTIFICATION OF INDIVIDUALS
IN REPORTS OR OTHERWISE THE
DATA CANNOT BE TRANSFERRED.
REVEALED OR USED FOR PURPOSES
OTHER THAN RESEARCH AND
STATISTICS. THE STRONG
SAFEGUARDS PROTECT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF EVERY
INDIVIDUAL. FINALLYTHE BILL
ADDS THE ANNEX BUILDING LOCATED
AT TEN TWENTY ONE- STREET IN
SACRAMENTO. TO THE LIST OF
LOCATIONS WHERE PERSON CANNOT
ENTER OR POSSESS A FIREARM OR
OTHER DEADLY WEAPON MAKING IT A
MISDEMEANOR TO DO SO. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE SEVEN THREE. MR FONG.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
UNFORTUNATELY RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE SEVEN
THREE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ALREADY HAS A TROUBLING TRACK
RECORD A RECORD KEEPING AND ANY
EXPANSION OF THAT THIRTY COULD
LEAD TO PERSONAL SENSITIVE
INFORMATION BEING RELEASED AS
IT HAS HAPPENED BEFORE IF THE
DOJ DOJ CANNOT FULLY SECURED
INDIVIDUALS SENSITIVE DATA THAT
I'M CERTAINLY NOT CONVINCED
THAT RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
PROFESSORS OR COLLEGE STUDENTS
OR ANY MORE TRUSTWORTHY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
CALIFORNIA'S SECOND MEMORIZE
COMPROMISING THE PRIVACY OF
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS WITHOUT
FULL PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. DOES
NOT DESERVE SUPPORT I URGE A NO
VOTE. C. NOTATIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ADAM. THE CLUB OF THE
ROLE. WHAT IS THEIR VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY THREE NO
SEVENTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS. R.
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB ONE
SEVENTY FOUR SEPARATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY FOR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET NECKLACE IN
THE VEHICLES MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FORCE THAT
AFFECTED ME LIBERALLY TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER TECH. THE
COMMITTEE SPEAKER AB ONE SEVEN
FOURS ARE TRANSPORTATION
TRAILER BILL. THE BILL TO LEAVE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
COMPLETE TEXT OF THE VEHICLE
COULD BE PUBLISHED AND
DISTRIBUTED. REQUIRED THE DMV
TO HAVE A THUMBPRINT OR
FINGERPRINT ON FILE PRIOR TO
ISSUING A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
ID CARD. ALLOW THE DMV TO RENEW
A DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR PERSON
OVER THE AGE OF SEVENTY BY MAIL
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. ALLOWS FOR
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL LAW
WITH RESPECT TO COMMERCIAL AND
FLEET INSURANCE POLICIES.
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE ON AB ONE SEVEN FOUR. MR
FONG. I THINK IT WAS BIGGER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN
FOUR. THESE PROVISIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE DMV IT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF TAXPAYERS
TO ENCOURAGE COMMONSENSE
POLICIES TO PROTECT. THE HEALTH
OF ONE OF OUR POPULATIONS TO
CURB UP NINETEEN WHEN INTER
WITH THEM. I URGENT ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER. NOBODY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ADAM. CARCLUB THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. RESIDED VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
CORPORATE SOME PEOPLE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET NOT GOING TO HOUSING
AND MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY PER REALLY TO THE
BUDGET MISTER CHANG THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THE ONE SEVEN
FIVE- IS OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TRAILER BILL
INCLUDES TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS RELATED
TO PRIOR BILLS ADOPTED THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AREA
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
A TWO YEAR EXTENSION FOR THE%
METRO NORTH HOLLYWOOD JOINT
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT. ALLOWS
ACCOUNTABLE BOARD TO ENTER INTO
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE CITY AND-COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SHELTER SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON AB
ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
STAYING MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. IT IS CERTAINLY
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE SO MANY ON
SHELTER CALIFORNIANS LIVING ON
THE STREETS IN UNSAFE
CONDITIONS WE SHOULD ALWAYS
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
IMPROVEMENTS TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESS. SUPPORT PROGRAMS WITH
THE CLARIFICATIONS IMPROVEMENTS
TO SERVICE DELIVERY INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA A BETTER HOME
FOR FAMILIES. I REGION ABOUT.
THANK OF US FONG SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
MATTER CARCLUB THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
ONE SEVENTY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
KNACK LIVING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY PAYER RELATED THE
BUDGET. MISTER TECH THE
COMMITTEE SPEAKER THIS IS OUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TRAILER
BILL THE BILL AMENDS THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INCLUDES
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING LIMITS
RELATED TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
I ALSO RELATED TO SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS INCLUDING MICRO
BUSINESSES VENUES AND NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS CALIFORNIA
COMPETES BRECHER PROGRAM AS
WELL AS- TECHNICAL MOMENTS TO
THE HOMELESS THE HOMELESS
HIRING TAX CREDIT IN THE FILM
TAX CREDIT. IT ALSO PROVIDES
MICRO BUSINESSES ON OCTOBER
NINETEEN THE VENUE'S PROGRAM
GRANTEES THE SAME TAX EXEMPTION
STATUS OF THE GRANTEES OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS COVERT NIGHT
COVERED NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM AND FINALLY LIMITS THE
ABILITY OF THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO COLLECT COURT ORDERED
VEHICLE RELATED DEBT FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN LOW
WAGES ARE OF LOW BACK AND
LOCALES ALEX IS- PLEASE. PLEASE
VOTE AYE. ON AB ONE SEVEN SIX.
MR FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN THE OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BIT ADVOCATE HAS OFFERED
SUPPORT TO SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING TO OVERCOME THE
PANDEMIC AND THE RECESSION.
THIS BILL ENSURES CONTINUED
ASSISTANCE TO ELIGIBLE
BUSINESSES AND AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE. TAKE THIS FALL SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ADAM. CLUB THE ROLE. IT IS OUT
OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARABLE.
THAT'S RIGHT. WELL CLOSER TIDE
ABOUT I. SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
AND THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE AB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET NATURALLY IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN MAKING A
PROBATIONER FORCE TAKE AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY PRIVILEGE TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER TECH. THANK A
SPEAKER AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN IS
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL
IT'S OUR LAST. BUDGET TRAILER
BILL FOR THE YEAR THAT WE JUST
TAKE THIS MOMENT. AGAIN TO
THANK. ALL THE HARDWORKING
STAFF BAKER VICE CHAIR THINK
ARE REPUBLICAN BUDGET STUFF.
OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET STUFF IN
OUR SPEAKERS OR SPEAKERS OFFICE
BUDGET STAFF AS WELL AS THE
SENATE. BY SENATE COUNTERPART
SENATOR SKINNER AND- HER BUDGET
TEAM. THIS IS BEEN A HISTORIC
YEAR IN TERMS OF BUDGET WORK
THIS IS OUR THIRD. ROUND THE
BUDGET BILLS WE DID SIXTY SIX
BUDGET BILLS AT ALL. THE
PREPARATION OF THE PAST THE-
LARGEST BUDGET IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY WITH HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS. IN EDUCATION AND
CHILD CARE HEALTH CARE SMALL
BUSINESSES WORKING TO BRING
BACK. ALL THE BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
DURING THIS LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS DURING THIS PANDEMIC- WE
REALLY HAVE. DONE EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE WE COULD TO REALLY
HELP ALL THOSE WHO REALLY
NEEDED. THE HELP OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA VERY PROUD OF ALL
THE VERY HARD WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE THIS YEAR. I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR THIS POSITION AND
THE- MANY NUMEROUS HOURS A
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING. IT
ALL THE WORK THAT WENT INTO
PUTTING EACH AND EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THESE TRAILER BILL
TOGETHER. SO WITH THAT. AB ONE
SEVEN SEVEN THE TRAILER BILL TO
EXTEND THE USE OF REMARK REMOTE
COURT PROCEEDINGS AS
AUTHORIZED. UNDER GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER UNTIL. JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE BILL ALSO LIVE SEVENTEEN.
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AS OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THANKS COUNTY TO PROVIDE
TO THE BATTLE OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR IN THE FIFTY MILLION
ONGOING AND FUTURE FISCAL
YEARS. THE BILL ALSO MAKES A
VERY IMPORTANT A MODEST
INCREASE. TO THE TRANSCRIPT
RATE FOR COURT REPORTERS WHICH
IS THE FIRST INCREASE IN THE
LAST. ONE HUNDRED YEARS THE
ONLY ONE INCREASE IN THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS WHICH IS A
NINETEEN NINETY. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN. AND
COULD A FEW MISTER TANK MR FONG.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER HI
ALL I TO ALSO ONCE YOU ARE
PROOF THAT THANK THE CHAIR FOR
HIS PATIENTS AND IN
COMMUNICATION. THROUGH THIS
NEVER ENDING BUDGET PROCESS I
ALSO CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK
THE WORK OF OUR BUDGET STAFF ON
BOTH SIDES- FOR THEIR WORK AS
WELL UNFORTUNATELY I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE SEVEN
SEVEN- PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE
NEEDED SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
PROVIDED TO THOSE IN THE COMING
JUSTICE SYSTEM. IT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CANNOT AFFORD TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES SERVICES
IMPORTANT REHABILITATION AND
PREVENTION PROGRAMS WE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED IN ADDITION
THIS BILL ALSO EXTENDS AND
CODIFIES EMERGENCY AUTHORITY TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT IS
QUESTIONABLE AND DEMANDS FOR
THE REVIEW. I URGE A NO VOTE.
THE SHIP ALONE. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LET ME TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO- THANK OUR
BUDGET CHAIR BUDGET VICE CHAIR-
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THIS YEAR
AND AS WELL- ARE BUDGET
DIRECTOR AND ALL OF THE BUDGET
STAFF ON THE MANY- OF PEOPLE ON
THE FLOOR WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR- ONE MIGHT
THINK THAT BECAUSE WE HAD A LOT
OF EXTRA FUNDING THAT THEREFORE
THIS IS A GREAT PROBLEM AND
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE TO RESOLVE
ALL THE MANY BUDGET ISSUES BUT
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE IT
WAS- YOU KNOW. ORDERS OF
MAGNITUDE MORE WORK THAT WENT
INTO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THAN
HAS GONE INTO PAST YEAR SO
KUDOS TO EVERYONE FOR GETTING
IT DONE. ON TIME- I WE OWE A
DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO EVERYONE
WHO'S WORKED ON THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. ON THE
ADAM MISTER CHANG YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH I WAS A MISTAKE
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA I
DIDN'T THINK OUR FIVE A
PHENOMENAL BUDGET STRUCTURES
INCLUDING OUR RESEARCHER FROM
SANTA MONICA FOR THEIR
NCREDIBLE WORK FOR CHEERING
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEIR HEARINGS AND SHEPHERDING
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THEIR
ITEMS- EVEN AFTER WE PASS THE
BUDGET IN JUNE- SO MANY ITEMS
THAT WERE LEFT OVER SPECIALLY
IN. OUR BUDGETS OF THREE
NATURAL RESOURCES AREA THAT
WERE LEFT FOR APPROVAL TODAY SO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THEIR
ENGAGEMENT OVER THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THEIR HARD WORK WITHOUT
RESPECT FOR RESTAURANTS. HER
CLUB THE ROLE. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
EIGHTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS. R.
CONCURRED IN. AND MS RANTS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I JUST WANTED
TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF REPORT WHAT
WE'VE DONE. WE BEGAN TODAY WITH
AHUNDRED AND FIVE ASSEMBLY
BILLS AND WE'VE TAKEN UP EIGHTY
NINE OF THOSE. WE ALSO POUNCED
NOW WITH THE LAST BILL WE VOTED
ON SIXTEEN BUDGET BILLS WE'VE
TAKEN UP AND DISPENSED WITH
TWENTY THREE SENATE BILLS WE
RECENTLY RECEIVED TWENTY FOUR
SOMETHING BILLS FROM THE SENATE
AND BEFORE WE JOURN THIS
EVENING WE WILL BE TAKING THOSE
UP THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF WAR FILE ITEMS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP AT THIS TIME.
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FOUR THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FOUR WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND ACCOLADES COMMUNICATIONS MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FOUR STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE THAT ALL MODERNIZE AND
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU RESIDENTS ALL
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF EIGHT ON
THE ADAM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLARK. WELL CLOSER
ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY FIVE
KNOWS FIVE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. AND WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN. WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE AB FOURTEEN
CLERK WILL READ A SYMBOL
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY NECKLACE IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS TO CLEAR THE
ABSENCE EITHER OF THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY THIS AGUIAR-CURRY
GOOD EVENING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. I APPRECIATED THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION LAST NIGHT SO
I WILL MAKE THE SHORT THIS BILL
IS THE COMPANION BE IT BILL TO
US BEFORE WHICH PASSED THE
HOUSE WITH A TWO THIRDS
MAJORITY LAST NIGHT. IT IS MY
HALF OF THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A GENERATIONAL INVESTMENT
IN INTERNET CONNECTIVITY FOR
ALL OF OUR STATE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. GLOBAL ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY SIX KNOWS FOR
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN AND MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENCE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY IS AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY MR SANTIAGO.
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EVANS SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS NOT PUTTING THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS MR
SANTIAGO. THAT FIGURE SPEAKER
FOR AT AND MEMBERS AB SEVENTY
SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AND I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THIS HOUSE WHO AND WHO
INVESTED THEIR TIME AND ENERGY
INTO CREATING A ROBUST
CONVERSATION THAT NOW LET US.
TO IT TO A BETTER BILL THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A MARKET
ANALYSIS OF THE CALLACHAN
PROGRAM IT WOULD GIVE ALL
CALIFORNIA'S ACCESSIBLE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WHICH IS A FREE
DEBIT CARD A SAVINGS ACCOUNT
DIRECT DEPOSITS. I WOULD RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO TREASURE NOW
SUPPORTS THE BILL- CAL CHAMBERS
NEUTRAL AND STATE CONTROL HAS
NO POSITION WHERE THEY WERE
OPPOSED I AT THE TIME IN THIS
HOUSE. THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY
OVER TWO HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS BUT ENVIRONMENTAL
LABOR AND COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS NOW. I URGE A YES
VOTE TODAY ON THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BANKING OPTION ACT.
THANK YOU MISS AT THE ECHO
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LA AND THE MANY.
THE JOINT AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
THIS IS TO ADDRESS THE ONE AND
FOR. CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS WERE
UNBANKED OR UNDERBANKED. WHO
ARE LARGELY LOW INCOME. WHO ARE
PAYING WAY MORE TO ACCESS THEIR
MONEY THAN HIGHER INCOME BANKS
COUNTERPARTS. PAYING UP 210% OF
TAKE HOME PAY IN FEES AND
INTEREST. FROM HIGH COST
FINANCIAL SERVICES AS YOU'VE
JUST HEARD THIS BILL WILL
STUDY. OUR STATE CAN PROVIDE
BASIC FINANCIAL SERVICES TO
HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
IT'S CRITICAL GIVEN THAT THE
LAST FEDERAL MINISTRATION STOP
STUDYING. UNDERBANKED
HOUSEHOLDS IN AMERICA BY THE
FDIC AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CHIU SAYING NO DIVISIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. MR SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. CIRCLE OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
TWENTY ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL. ON
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SB.
SEVENTY THREE. PURPLE POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY TWO KNOWS
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT
AB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY MISTER
LEAVE THE CARPOOL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL. TIVER
HIGHS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. EIGHTY NINE
WOOD. AB FIFTY SIX SALAS AB
THREE SEVENTEEN PATTERSON AB
THREE EIGHTY NINE GRAYSON.
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE CHIU.
AB SIX SIX THREE CHEN. AB EIGHT
SIX ONE BENNETT. AB TEN FORTY
TWO JONES SAWYER. AB TAP ON.
CORRECTION AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT RUBIO AB TWELVE ALL ONE
TEAM AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
MCCARTY. AB THREE THIRTY NINE
LEE AB FOUR FIFTY GONZALEZ AB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE TRUE. AB FIVE
EIGHTY RODRIGUEZ AB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE DAVIES AB SIX FIFTY ONE
GIPSON AB SIX NINETY FOR
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE. AB TWELVE OH FOUR
WEEKS. AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
RUBIO. AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
SANTIAGO AND AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN
WOOD WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO WORK THIS CAN
CURRENT FILE IF YOUR BILL IS ON
THE CONCURRENCE FILE ATHIS BE
AT YOUR DESK AND READY TO
PRESENT WE WILL START WITH. A
REFERENCE TO FILE AB NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME AGO NINE
BY SIMILAR WOULD MACLAINE FIRE
SAFETY ACTUALLY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB NINE
MAKES PERMANENT THE REGIONAL
FOREST AND FIRE PASSED THE-
PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM IS ALREADY
UP AND RUNNING AT THE PARTMINER
CONSERVATION SENATE AMENDMENTS
AT A SECOND COMPONENT TO THIS
BILL THAT IS GOING TO CHANGE
HOW CALIFORNIA PREPARES HOMES
AND NEIGHBORHOODS FOR WILDFIRE.
THE BILL NOW IDENTIFIES THE
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
BE DOING IN COMMUNITIES. AND
NEIGHBORHOODS AND PUTS HIM IN A
NEW BRANCH AT THE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE. THIS PRESS
WILL HAVE A NEW DEPUTY DIRECTOR
TO LEAD THE CHARGE. AND ALL OF
THE STAFF AND LEADERSHIP IN
THIS BRANCH WILL BE THE LOWEST
PRIORITY TO RESPOND TO FIGHTING
FIRES. THE GOAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO CREATE URGENCY
AND FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES. IT
NEEDS TO BE A FULL TIME JOB.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ACCURATE SEED HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THAT OUT OF
THE PARK WILL OPEN ALL MEMBERS.
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
YOU CAN MAKE. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX
BUT OUR FRIENDS TO FILE CLERK
WILL READ OR AB FIFTY SIX
PURPLE RAIN ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
pOTHERS NOT GOING TO BENEFITS
THIS IS ALICE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU BETTER FIGURE EIGHTY FIFTY
SIX IS BACK ON CAN CURRENTLY BE
FIFTY SIX IS THE EDT REFORMS.
COMMONSENSE REFORMS. AND THAT'S
MUCH NEEDED IN OUR STATE
MEMBERS I KNOW YOU GUYS OF ALL
RECEIVED. A LOT OF PHONE CALLS
JUST LIKE I HAVE LET'S DO
SOMETHING ABOUT EDT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
PROBLEM WITH OUR MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERVE A. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR NEW ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE WE WILL NOW GO TO AB
THREE SEVENTEEN CLERK WILL
READ. SOME AGO THREE SEVENTEEN
BY SINGER PATTERSON ACCORDING
TO FOSTER CARE. PATTERSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK THURMOND
SPEAKER MEMBERS- AB WHATEVER
THIS IS. HIS BACK. THREE
SEVENTEEN THREE SEVENTY. BOB
ASK FOR YOUR- BIBLE FOR CONSENT
AFRICANS OUT FORGET ABOUT IT I
NEED AN AYE VOTE. NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE VOTE. WELL MEMBERS
GO TO THEIR TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU THAT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN WE
WOULD HAVE FILE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB THREE
EIGHTY NINE PARK READ. SOME
REAL THREE NINE BY SUMMER
GRAYSON ACTIVATED EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES GRAYSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THAT'S INCREDIBLY HARD
ACT TO FOLLOW. I WILL DO MY
BEST AB THREE EIGHTY NINE IS
BACK FROM- ON CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE REQUIRES BOTH COUNTIES
EMPIRE AGENCIES TO ADOPT A
WRITTEN POLICY ON
SUBCONTRACTING PRIOR TO ANY
SUBCONTRACTING AGREEMENT AND TO
ENSURE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE FOR
WORKER PROTECTIONS AND A FOR A
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS THE
AMENDMENTS REFLECT A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BY.
SPONSORS AND OPPOSITION GROUPS
THE BILL NO LONGER HAS ANY.
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON
SEEING OR FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONVERTING WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE NEW TO EAT.
AMERICANS FILE EIGHTY SIX SIXTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
AGO SIX SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHEN AN ACTIVE
IN THE BUSINESS CAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A. P. SIXTY THREE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER HE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSER ALL INSIDE OF IT I
SEVENTY NEW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
WILL TAKE UP WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE AB SIXTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE AGE
SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY REPENTANT
NATURALLY THE MOBILE HOME PARKS
SERVE ANY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS EXEMPT NONPROFIT
OWNED IN GOVERNMENT AGENCY ON
PARKS THAT HAVE AFFORDABILITY
COVENANTS AND ALLOW THESE PARKS
TO CONTINUE READING MOBILE HOMEUNITS AT AFFORDABLE PRICES TO
MAINTAIN THEIR WELFARE
EXCEPTION. OUTSIDE OF THAT THE
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THIS WILL PRESERVE THE
RENT CONTROLLED PARKS THAT ARE
OUT THERE PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR SENIORS AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AND KEEP THEM
FROM. BEING PURCHASED AND
REMOVED FROM LOCAL RENT CONTROL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
SEEING HEARING THERE FOR THE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THIRD OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE-
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY ONE NEWS EIGHTEEN
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WILL MOVE TO WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FIVE TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS NOT
GOING TO ENERGY YOUR TO YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD HELP JUMPSTART IN
OFFER WIND INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA IS BACK ON FOR
CONCURRENCE. SENATE AMENDMENTS
EAST IMPLEMENTATION ON THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AND ALSO ADDED MORE SUPPORTING
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY BOOK THANK YOU MISTER
CHOOSING HEARING THERE FOR THE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO THE.
ON NUMBER THIRTY TO THEIR VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SPOKE TO FIVE
NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WILL MOVE TO
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
TEN FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ FOR SOME PEOPLE TEND FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER ACTUALLY THE LONG TERM
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES JONES
SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
FORTY TWO IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE RECENT
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES RELATED
APARTMENT A PUBLIC HEALTH
NOTIFICATION OF RELATED PARTIES
A POTENTIAL LEGAL ACTION TO
COLLECT IT STARTING JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND S.
SPECIFICATIONS ON WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT MAKES TERMINATIONS
THAT ARE RELATED PARTY IS NOT
FINANCIALLY VIABLE AND RECOVERY
OF DEBT IS UNLIKELY THIS BILL
GETTING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SAYING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- THIRD OF A- ALL.
MEMBERS GO TO THIRD OF THE-
WHERE WILL FOOD LOWS THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT AS FIFTY TWO
KNOWS FOURTEENTH AND AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO
WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME OF ROLLOVER
THIRTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO NATURALLY IN THE
CANNABIS MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT IS BACK ON
THE CURRENTS WITH CHATTERING
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS RUBIO SEEING HEARING THERE
FOR THE DEBATE AND I DON'T
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE WHERE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE I. SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE WILL NOW TAKE
UP WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
TWELVE OH ONE READ. SOME REAL
TROUBLE ONE BY ASSEMBLY
REVERTING AND OTHERS NOTREALLY
THE SOLID WASTE MISTER KING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWELVE ALL WAS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. SAID AMANDA BY
THE BILL TO PRODUCTS INTENDED
TO BECOME ORGANIC COMPOST
REQUIRES. CAL RECYCLE TO
DETERMINE IF IT IS FEASIBLE TO
HAVE AN ORGANIC AND NON ORGANIC
COMPOST LABELING PROCESS. MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES. CFDA
AND OTHER PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS
ARE DOWN NEUTRAL. BUT LAKE
CONCERNS WERE RAISED BY THE
RULE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
AFTER THE AMEND THE DEADLINE
I'M COMPLETELY. COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS BY
INTRODUCING CLEAN UP LANGUAGE
NEXT SESSION AHEAD OF SUBMITTED
A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL. TO
MAKE MY INTENT CLEAR WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON A. B. TWELVE ALL ONE. THANK
YOU MR TANG SEEING HEARING
THERE. FOR THE DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. VERY GOOD. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO WITHOUT REFERENCE
FILE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BY THE
SUMMER MCCARTY AND OTHERS NOT
GOING REAL PROPERTY. MCCARTY
WERE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS IS THE BILL
RELATED TO RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION DISCRIMINATORY
COVENANTS ON HOUSING DEEDS AS
BILLS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WE
TOOK SOME TIME TECHNICAL AND WE
THINK- CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION FROM THE
REALTORS LAND TITLE ASSOCIATION
AN ESCROW OFFICERS. ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED VERY THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
NONMEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW INTERNET ICE FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THE KNOWLEDGE
WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE EIGHTY
THREE THIRTY NINE THE
CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE THREE
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE AND OTHERS NAKED IN THE
PUBLIC MEETINGS REALLY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE THREE
NINE IS BACK OF CONCURRENCE-
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE
AT THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
BILL REQUIRES CITY COUNCILS AND
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEETINGS IN JURISDICTIONS THE
POPULATION OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC TO PROCEED AT THEIR
INTERNET OR TELEPHONE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
EXPECTATIONS. BY LOCAL AGENTS
AND WE WORKED VERY HARD WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS STRICTLY
ANSWER EITHER. THANK YOU MISTER
LEASING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE TWO THIRDS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THERE TO VOTE.
THIRTY WILL. CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THAT ICE WOULD YOU TO
NOTIFY SEND MEN MENS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO WITHOUT
REFERENCE FILE EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY THE CLERK WILL READ
SYMBOL FOR FIFTY BY IS MINIMAL
RENDON SALAS AND OTHERS NOT
GOING TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL THAT'S RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
CONCURRENCE. SEEING HEARING
OVER THE DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- VERY
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR
TO VOTE. BURKE WILL COLUSA
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO FORTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND
DOLLARS NAPOLI TO MILITARY
EQUIPMENT MR TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MANAGED TO
HER COLLEAGUES AT FORTY ONE IS
BACK AGAIN CURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATIONS AND ADDRESS
CONCERNS BY THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT ICE FORTY ONE NEWS TWENTY
ONE SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON AB
FIVE EIGHTY MOVED TO WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME AGO FIVE EIGHTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO MATTER TO
CLEAR THE ABSENCE EITHER OF
SIGNIFICANTLY. IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M HERE 2%
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT THREE WHICH
IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE AB FIVE
EIGHT THREE SIX TO KIND OF
FIGHT UNTIL TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FOUR THE PRACTICE FOR
ELECTRONIC ISSUING A MARRIAGE
LICENSE SOME STATIONS ARE MORE
IS TO BE DONE VERY LIVE
INTERACTIVE VIDEO TECHNOLOGY
THAT CALIFORNIA. COUNTIES HAVE
EMPLOYED OVER THE LAST YEAR DUE
TO COPE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
RECENT AMENDMENTS COME AT THE
REQUEST OF THE CD PH RICHER ALL
TYPE OF MARRIAGE LICENSE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PRACTICE HE
CLARIFIED THAT ALL PARTIES MUST
BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
STATE BUT MAY USE REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY TO CONDUCT A
CEREMONY THIS BILL HAS NO RISKS
THIS BILL HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY
NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I DO. THANK YOU MISTER.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN WE WILL NOW
MOVES WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE SIX FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
ACTIVATING THE CEMETERIES
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATTER SPEAKING MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY ONE IS
BACK OF HERS ARE STRICTLY ASPEN
AYE VOTE ON CEMETERY
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE. BURKE WILL FOODS THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN WHEN THEY TO THAT
REFERENCE OF HIGHLY BE SIX
NINETY FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIX NINETY FOUR BY
THE COMMUTER PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION IN ABILENE CONSUMERS
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS I
OUR ANNUAL PRIVACY COMMITTEE ON
THE MOST BILL MAKES A VARIETY
OF TECHNICAL AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHOPPING OUT
ISSUES THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION. RESPECT
YOUR QUESTION I VOTE. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL SEEING AND HEARING
OVER THE DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERY GOOD. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
WILL MOVE BACK UP IN THE LAST
TWO WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
AB FIVE EIGHTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE FIVE EIGHTY
BY A SUMMER RODRIGUEZ AN
ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
MR RODRIGUEZ ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. THE
MEMBERS EIGHTY FIVE IT IS BACK
FROM CURRENT FROM SENATE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL ENACT
RECOMMENDATIONS IDENTIFIED. IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUTRES
REPORT TITLED CALIFORNIA IS NOT
ADEQUATELY PREPARED TO PROTECT
ITS MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
FROM NATURAL DISASTERS. MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS NOT POSITION HAS
BEEN NO NO VOTES ARE STRICTLY A
STRUGGLE. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS VOTED A VERITABLE. ALL
MEMBERS FEDERAL RESERVE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE AB
TWELVE- FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TRAVEL FOR BY
SUMMER WICKS AND OTHERS NOT
GOING TO HOSPITALS THIS WORKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TOLD BEFORE
REQUIRE HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS TO SUBMIT EQUITY
REPORTS OF EACH OTHER
PERFORMANCE ACROSS. A STANDARD
SET OF MEASURES SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE ESTABLISHING
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE ALSO
ADDING ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT ON REPORTING
TIMELINES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WAXING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER BURKE WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. OF
THE- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. CLERK WILL LOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE IS FORTY
EIGHT NO SEVENTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THE TEST WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE BY ASSUMING OR BLANCA RUBIO
AND OTHERS NATURALLY THE
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. THIS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE WITH
CHATTERING AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
SEEING HEARING THERE FOR THE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE IT. WHERE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITHOUT REFERENCE OF HIGHLY BE
THIRTEEN OH FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND OTHERS INCLUDING
LAND USE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SEGMENTS BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
BACK FOR CAN PERSIST BY CLASS
AND I'VE- SEEN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE THIRD
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. WHERE. WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THEIR EYES
FIFTY ONE NO SEVENTEEN
SENTIMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN WILL
MOVE TO WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE
AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
NATURALLY DIVERSE RECYCLING
ACCURATE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
MUCH OF THE MODERN RECYCLING
MOVING CAN TRACE ITS ROOTS BACK
TO HUMBLE COUNTY AND THE CITY
OF ARCADE IN MY DISTRICT FOR
DECADES LEADERS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE LED THE WAY.
TRAGICALLY EXISTENCE TODAY IT'S
EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
RESIDENTS IN THE COUNTY TO
REDEEM THEIR CRB CONTAINERS WE
WORK WITH LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY A HANDFUL OF SMALL
CHANGES THAT WOULD ALLOW
RECYCLING CENTERS TO RE OPEN IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY IS MODEST
CHANGES WERE BY NO MEANS SOLVE
ALL THE PROBLEMS FACING THE
BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM BUT THEY
WILL ADDRESS A CRISIS OF MY
DISTRICT HOPEFULLY THEY WILL
HELP OTHER COMMUNITIES
STRUGGLING WITH THE SAME
CHALLENGES TO ACCESS REJECT
REDEMPTION CENTERS AS WELL. THE
BILL HAS HAD OF NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TWENTY AFTER WITNESSING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO
THEIR. TO BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
NINE IS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE WILL NOW
TAKE UP. FILE ITEM FORTY THREE
AB TEN NINETY FIVE A KERKORIAN
SOME PEOPLE TO NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AND ACT
LIKE IT'S A HOUSING. MR BERMAN.
I'M NOT PICKING ON YOU FOR YOUR
RECOGNIZED AGAIN. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IN COLLEAGUES IT
IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
THIS BILL REPRESENTS THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUE MR
COOLEY- AB TEN NINETY FIVE
CREATES A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
PROJECTS. BY TREATING
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND RENTAL
DEVELOPMENTS THE SAME IN STATE
GUIDELINES THE MOMENT IN THE
SENATE WERE CLARIFYING AB TEN
NINETY FIVE HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE AND
SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU MR BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
BOTH YOU TO THIRTY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS MOTIONS ARTICLE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS IF YOU
HAVE A CHANGES WE CAN ENTERTAIN
THOSE AT THIS TIME THIS RAZOR
MIGHT NOT RECOGNIZE YOU.
THIS
AROMAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
THE CHANGE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER RAMOS VOTE CHANGE AB
EIGHT SIX ONE I TO NOT VOTING.
PRO CHANGE ASSEMBLY MAHRAM MOST
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY ONE I
TO NOT VOTING. MISS DAVIES
AMERICANIZE REMOTE CHANGE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES
MAKES VOTE CHANGE FROM AB
SEVENTY FOUR FROM OPPOSE
TONIGHT. NO CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FOUR NO TÁI. IF
YOU'RE FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF. SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN
NOT VOTING TO HI. PRO CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER SENATE
BILL SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN NOT
VOTING TO AYE.
MISTER GRAYSON
RECOGNIZED ME ABOUT CHANGE
GRAYSON AB FOUR EIGHT ONE FROM
ITEM NUMBER. CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BEFORE
ANYONE I TEND TO KNOW.
CORRECTION GRAYSON IS ILLEGAL
FOR ANYONE TO NOT VOTING.
YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR A CHANGE
VALIDATORS ON AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR. NO IT'S NOT VOTING.
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FELT
THERE IS SOME WIGGLE ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR NO TO NOT VOTING.
MR DALYYOUR RECOGNIZED FOR
READ CHANGE THANK YOU AB FOR
EIGHTY ONE VOTE CHANGE FROM YES
TO NOT VOTING. WE'LL CHANG
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY ASSEMBLY
BEFORE ANYONE- TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TAKE A ONE
MORE CONCURRENCE ITEM. AT WHICH
IS. I AM ONE OF THREE AB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO MIDDLE LEVEL NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO AND OTHERS
NATURALLY INTO CONSERVATORSHIP.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MASSACRE
AND COLLEAGUES. OOPS I DID IT
AGAIN. AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
HELPS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
REFORMS ON CONSERVATORSHIP ITS
OPERATIVE TO ENSURE THAT WE
STRENGTHEN OUR LAWS THAT
THEY'RE STRONGER THAN YESTERDAY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
WITH MAX SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OUR MEMBERS
GO TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. ALL MY
MESSAGES ARE THE- BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING OF IT
I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO
I'M REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB THREE
SIXTY SIX RUBIO TO HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR. BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS TO THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS. THIS IS NOT ME
JOURNEYING JUST TO BE CLEAR BUT
THAT WILL HAPPEN SOON. BUT IN
THE MEANTIME WE ARE MOVING
TOMORROW SESSION START TIME TO
ELEVEN THIRTY. RIGHT I KNOW YOU
ALLOWED ME RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE
THANK YOU VOTE CHANGE
CUNNINGHAM AB ONE OH FIVE I TO
KNOW. GO CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
FIVE- IT TO KNOW.
I HAVE MORE
GOOD NEWS FOR YOU MEMBERS LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE WILL
COMMENCE COMMENCE TOMORROW AT
TEN THIRTY AM. OUR LEADER AND
NGO WILL COMMENCE AT TEN THIRTY
AM SO WE MOVE THE TIMES OF
THOSE TWO COMMITTEES AS WELL.
STAY TUNED FOR THE START TIME
FOR COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEY.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
MOTION. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET.
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN GRAYSON AB
EIGHT ONE SIX CHIU AND SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE PORTANTINO ON FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER TENTH UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE IN ROOM
FOUR THREE SEVEN. DOWN TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB FOUR OH
SEVEN SALAS. AB EIGHT THIRTY
FLORA. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AB
FIFTY THIRTY FIVE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS ON FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
TEN UPON A GERMAN. UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE IN ROOM%
FOUR TWO OH TWO. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. OKAY CANADIAN ED SKEWS
ME.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE
COULD DO WELL CHANGES. A SCORE
SILVERCORP PLEASE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PERKS SILVA VOTE CHANGE
AB FOUR EIGHTY ONE I TO KNOW.
CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY
ONE- TO KNOW.
MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE SESSION
SCHEDULED AS FOLLOWS TOMORROW
WE WILL BE RETURNING AT ELEVEN
THIRTY AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS AND RETAIN
LL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
THEY'RE OPERATING MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN THOSE. AND RUBIO
SECOND. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER TENTH AT TEN AM FOR
PUBLIC DIDN'T. WE ARE TURNING
ELEVEN THIRTY AM NOT TEN AM
MEMBERS.